LET ME. YEP YEP. LET'S SEE IF
THAT'S BETTER I MUTED THE
COMPUTER PERFECT OKAY. SEE WEEK
AFTER WEEK YOU FINALLY TEACH ME
HOW TO DO THIS- SO WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND CALL THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES- TO ORDER-
GOOD AFTERNOON I WILL MAKE
SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO
EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES THAT
WE'VE DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
CENTRAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS WE
TRULY APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
WHILE I GO THROUGH IT YET AGAIN
FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE TUNING IN
FOR THE FIRST TIME. SO LET ME
COVER THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF
THINGS FOR TODAY. IN RESPONSE
TO THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS
AND SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING TONIGHT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS. THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WELL
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT. THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN. RIGHT NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE. AND OUR
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT ONE SEVEN
NINE FOUR FOUR FIVE. WILL SHOW
THAT A COUPLE TIMES DURING THE
pON THE SCREEN. BUT REMEMBER IT
IS ON OUR WEBSITE AS WELL. WHEN
WE DO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
OUR COMMITTEE. HE'S NOTED IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU
ARE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND SO WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN THAT
REGARD. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS. SO AGAIN PLEASE BE
PATIENT SO EVERYONE CAN BE
HEARD. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY.
LET ME JUST ASK ON BEHALF OF
OUR STENOGRAPHER. ALL SPEAKERS
MY COLLEAGUES AND WITNESSES
ALIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND
CLEARLY. SO THAT SHE CAN
CAPTURE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING AND-
I WILL INTERRUPT AND ASK YOU TO
STOP FOR A MOMENT IF YOU'RE
TALKING TOO FAST OR NOT CLEAR
ENOUGH. SO THAT ARE STILL NOT
REFER CAN CAPTURE YOU'LL
FORGIVE ME IN ADVANCE FOR A FOR
HAVING TO DO THAT BUT- I JUST
WANNA LET YOU KNOW IN ADVANCE.
SO BEFORE WE GET TODAY'S ACTUAL
AGENDA LET'S GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM- AS A
REMINDER COLLEAGUES. YOU'LL
NEED TO TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE
FOR THE ROLL CALL AND EVERY
TIME THAT WE VOTE SO MADAM
SECRETARY WITH THAT WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROVE.
HERE HERE KAMLAGER RATHER THAN
WATER PRESENT LAYERED HERE HERE
EIGHT YOUR NEEDS HERE ATKINS
HERE ATKINS HERE. THANK YOU I
COLLEAGUES I'M GOING TO ASK IF
WE CAN LOOK AT OUR- GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR THAT WOULD BE ITEM TO-
AND THAT WOULD BE FOR SARAH
OLSON MEMBER OF THE COMMISSION
ON STATE MANDATES AND SEE IF I
CAN GET A MOTION ON THAT. THANK
YOU ARE SENATOR GROVE OF
MOTION- MADAM SECRETARY WE CALL
THE ROLL. HI I. HI LONGER FIVE
LAYERED HI. THERE I STATE HI
EIGHT I. HI. THANK YOU THAT WAS.
I GONNA GO AHEAD AND ASK IF WE
CAN TAKE ITEM TO THREE BILL
REFERRAL AND ITEM NUMBER FOR
OUR SESSION SCHEDULE FROM MAY
THROUGH JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND IF SOMEONE WOULD MAKE WITH
SO MOVE THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED- WITH THAT- SEEING NO
COMMENT FROM ANYONE MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I AM LONGER I WHERE I HI
I. FIVE TO ZERO THANK YOU
CALLING FOR THE WERE OFF A GOOD-
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND NOW
MOVES TO THE FIRST GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT AREN'T REQUIRED TO
APPEAR THAT WOULD BE ITEM ONE
EIGHT MS KATHLEEN A ALISON AS
SECRETARY OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
SO LET ME SAY WELCOME-
SECRETARY ALISON I LET ME ASK
YOU TO INTRODUCE YOURSELF-
ANYONE WITH YOU THAT YOU'D LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE MAKE ANY
WELCOME- ALLY I'M SORRY MAKE
ANY OPENING REMARKS OR COMMENTS
THAT YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE AND
THEN AFTER THAT INTRODUCTION
ALL GO STRAIGHT TO COLLEAGUES
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS SO.
SECRETARY ALISON WELCOME GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERING MY CONFIRMATION AS
SECRETARY OF STATE YOU SEE OUR-
I'M KATHLEEN ALISON BEFORE I
GET STARTED I WOULD DEFINITELY
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE SPECIAL
PEOPLE IN MY LIFE. OR WATCHING
TODAY MY WONDERFUL HUSBAND JACK
WHO HAS BEEN WITH ME AND
SUPPORT AND- OF OUR CRAZY
LIFESTYLE. AND MY LOVELY
DAUGHTER JENNIFER WHO HAS BEEN
WITH ME FOR MY ENTIRE JOURNEY
OF MY CAREER. SHE WAS A YOUNG
SINGLE MOTHER HAVING TO WORK
NIGHTS WEEKENDS. HOLIDAYS AND
FREQUENT OVER TIME- MANDATORY
OVERTIME NO LESS- SHE HAS
CERTAINLY SUFFERED THE MOST-
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER. LIFE HAS
BLESSED ME IN MANY WAYS
INCLUDED BRINGING IN CHILDREN
AND OTHER CHILDREN IN MY LIFE I
LOVE MY HOME. AND NO ONE GETS
TO A POSITION REQUIRING
CONFIRMATION WITHOUT A
SUPPORTIVE NETWORK OF FRIENDS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHO BECOME
FAMILY WHO ALSO SERVE AS
METORS. ALTHOUGH MY GREATEST
MENTORS FOR MY LOVING PARENTS.
WHO UNFORTUNATELY HAVE PASSED I
WOULD NOT BE HERE TODAY.
WITHOUT THE VALUES OF HONESTY
INTEGRITY HARD WORK THEY
INSTILLED IN ME AT A YOUNG AGE.
WITNESSING MY MOTHER'S
RESILIENCE MY FATHER'S
DEDICATION ABOUT ALWAYS DOING
THE RIGHT THING FOR OUR FAMILY
AND COMMUNITY. ADDITIONALLY I
WOULD NOT BE. FOR YOU TODAY AS
THE FIRST FEMALE SECRETARY IF
IT WASN'T FOR THE GENERATION OF
STRONG FEMALE LEADERS IN THIS
DEPARTMENT SUCH AS CHERYL PILAR
SUSAN HUBBARD. KATHLEEN MENDOZA
POWERS JUST TO NAME A FEW-
DIRECTLY IMPACTED MY FROM. WHEN
YOU ARE ALL PART OF MY SUPPORT
NETWORK TODAY. THEY TAUGHT ME
TO LEAD WITH STRENGTH AND GRACE.
GROWING UP IN THIS AGENCY HAS
BEEN A CHALLENGE IN AND OF
ITSELF. BUT AS A WOMAN IN A
PREDOMINANTLY MALE ENVIRONMENT.
I UNDERSTAND THE VALUE OF
DIVERSITY A DIVERSE WORKFORCE
INCLUSIVE AND EQUITABLE FOR ALL
WITHIN CDCR. I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY RESPECT AND
APPRECIATION TO MY C. D. C. R.
TEAM FOR THEIR ENORMOUS HARD
WORK AND DEDICATION. IN MAKING
CDC ARE DEPARTMENT OF INTEGRITY
WHO BELIEVES IN THE CORE
MISSION. A REHABILITATION AND
PUBLIC SAFETY I COULD NOT BE
PROUDER OR MORE GRATEFUL TO ALL
OF OUR FRONT LINE WORKERS. CAME
TO WORK EVERY DAY DURING THE
PET PANDEMIC DESPITE THE REST
OF THEIR OWN. HEALTH AND WELL
BEING. LASTLY I WANT TO EPRESS
MY APPRECIATION TO GOVERNOR
NEWSOM FOR HIS CONFIDENCE IN
APPOINTING ME TO THIS POSITION.
AS YOU KNOW I HAVE A DIVERSE
BACKGROUND STARTING AS A
MEDICAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
WHICH IS A NURSE WITH PEACE
OFFICER STATUS. BUT A DIRECT
PATIENT CARE FOR THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS OF MY CAREER. FOLLOWED BY
A SUPERVISORY ROLE IN HEALTH
CARE. FOR SEVERAL YEARS. I TOOK
ON THE ROLE OF COMMUNITY
RESOURCE MANAGER AT AN
INSTITUTION WHICH AFFORD ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPERVISE
RELIGIOUS PROGRAMS. OUR
PROGRAMS VARIOUS- VISITOR
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAMMING. I WAS ABLE
TO SEE FIRSTHAND THE TREMENDOUS
IMPACT OF PROGRAMS TO THE
POPULATION. I LOVE THE JOB SO
MUCH I ACTUALLY GAVE UP MY
PEACE OFFICER STATUS FOR
SEVERAL YEARS SO I COULD REMAIN
IN THAT CAPACITY. ULTIMATELY
RETURNING BACK TO HEALTHCARE IS
A HEALTHCARE ADMINISTRATOR TO
LEAD AN INSTITUTION CRISIS.
UNTIL RETURNING TO ACOSTA ROLE
SERVING AS ASSOCIATE WARDEN
THREE WHARTON AND EVENTUALLY
SERVING IN VARIOUS POSITIONS
NCDC OUR HEADQUARTERS TO
INCLUDE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
UNDER PROGRAMS. LAST HOUSING
GAP IN DIRECTOR OF FACILITIES
SUPPORT. AFTER RESULT
INSTITUTIONS AND UNDERSECRETARY
OF OPERATIONS OVER A NINE YEAR
PERIOD OF TIME. MY NURSING
DEGREE AND MY PASSION FOR
TREATING OUR POPULATION. IS NOT
DISSIPATED WITH THE VARIOUS
CHANGES IN CLASSIFICATION. I
TOOK ON THIS CHALLENGING ROLE
IN MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC.
BECAUSE I BELIEVED I COULD LEAD
FROM A PERSPECTIVE CARE AND
TREATMENT. FOR THOSE WHO LIVE
AND WORK IN OUR FACILITIES. AS
YOU KNOW CONGRESS YES YOU SEE
ARE VERY HARD. WITH OVER FORTY
NINE THOUSAND CASES AMONGST THE
POPULATION AND OVER SIXTEEN
THOUSAND CASES MARKS ARE STAFF.
TODAY WE HAVE SIXTEEN ACTIVE
CASES MARKS POPULATION AND TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE CASES
WITH OUR STAFF. CERTAINLY
SADDENS ME TO SAY WE LOST. TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE PATIENTS AT
TWENTY SIX STAFF. FORTUNATELY
WE BELIEVE WE'VE TURNED THE
CORNER AND COATED WE HAVE
OFFERED VACCINES 291% OF THE
POPULATION AND HAVE BOXING NAY
DID OVER SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND-
PATIENTS. WITH THE FIRST JONES
AND OVER TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
STAFF. THIS PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
HARD ON EVERYONE THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD. BUT FOR ALL OF US WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAINTAIN OUR RELATIONSHIPS WITH
OUR FAMILIES AND OUR SUPPORT
NETWORK. ASSEMBLY NOT LOST ON
ME THAT THE POPULATION DID NOT
HAVE THAT SAME. OPPORTUNITY DUE
TO THE SAFETY PRECAUTIONS- WE
HAD TO GO. TO TAKEN KOVIC
FAMILY VISITATION- WAS
SUSPENDED. I AM PLEASED TO
ANNOUNCE THAT LAST WEEK AND WE
OPEN UP IN PERSON VISITATION
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OVER A
YEAR. THE NEW PROCESS ALL THE
MORE STRINGENT SAFETY
GUIDELINES WERE RELATIVELY
SMOOTHLY. HOWEVER DUE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS OR
FEWER VISITORS THAN NORMAL.
THAT DIDN'T STOP THE SMILES AND
JOY IS ON EVERYONE'S FACES YOU
COULD EVEN SEE IT THROUGH THE
MASS I PERSONALLY TOWARDS U. S.
P. SACRAMENTO ON VISITATION DAY.
AND MY HEART WAS WARM SEEING
THAT BEGINNING OF FAMILY
REUNIFICATION OUR POPULATION.
REHABILITATION IS OUR MISSION
AND FAMILY VISITS ARE THE CORE
REHABILITATION. IN THE WEEKS TO
COME WE WILL WORK WITH OUR
HEALTHCARE PARTNERS TO BRING
CHILDREN BACK TOWARDS DOING
ROUNDS. THE POPULATION HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY UNDERSTANDING OVER
THE LAST YEAR AND EVERYBODY'S
LOOKING FORWARD TO GETTING BACK
TO PROGRAMMING WITHIN OUR
FACILITIES. IN MY OVER THIRTY
THREE YEAR SERVICES YOU SEE ARE
I'VE SEEN THIS AGENCY INVOLVED
OVER THE YEARS. FROM THE
PRIMARY MISSION OF HOUSING TO
MISSION OF REHABILITATION AND A
REAL LIFE IMPACT AWAY. I
WITNESSED FIRST HAND HOW
VARIOUS CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORMS HAVE INSPIRED HOPE
WITHIN THE POPULATION. IS
ENCOURAGING TO SEE THE
MOTIVATION AND DESIRE. OF OUR
POPULATION TO CHANGE OUR LIVES.
WITH THE VARIOUS PROGRAMMING
OPPORTUNITIES. KNOWING THAT
HARD WORK AND POSITIVE BEHAVIOR
MOST WILL GET A SECOND CHANCE.
THE SUPPORT OF CCAR'S PROGRAMS
WILL REMAIN THE KEY FOR SUCCESS
OF THIS AGENCY AS WELL AS OUR
RETURN CITIZENS. OVER THE YEARS
SERVING COUNTLESS IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE AGENCY STRUCTURE THERE'S
UNDOUBTEDLY MOVE FOR. ROME FOR
MORE. IMPROVEMENTS THROUGH
TECHNOLOGY TRAINING AND
IMPROVEMENTS CHANGE%
INSTITUTIONAL BUYER MEANT FOR
THE LIVES AND WELL BEING OF OUR
POPULATION STAFF. WE MUST
CONTINUE TO REIMAGINE CBC ARE
IMPROVE THE CONDITIONS WITHIN
OUR FACILITIES BY CREATING A
CULTURE OF REHABILITATION AND
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. THE DUTIES
AS SECRETARY I HAVE PUSH FOR
EQUITY AND DIVERSITY WITHIN
CDCR. I GATHER SEVERAL JUST THE
DIVISIONS WORKING COLLECTIVELY
ON THIS GOAL SHOULD AS WE WORK
TO IMPROVE RECRUITMENT
RETENTION AND PROMOTIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DIVERSE WORK
FOR. FOR SEASON THREE. DEVERS
WORKFORCE. THE GOVERNMENT
ALLIANCE ARE RAISING EQUITY
STEERING COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
WORKING EFFORTLESSLY TO RAISE
AWARENESS. UNDERSTANDING OF THE
BENEFITS OF A DIVERSE WORK. AS
THE FIRST FEMALE SECRETARY FOR
CDC ARE I REALIZE I HAVE AN
INTENTIONAL RESPONSIBILITY TO
THIS AGENCY. THAT IS INCLUSIVE
OF ALL AND BREAKS DOWN THE
BARRIERS ALONG THE WAY I MUST
BUILD A SUSTAINABLE PROCESS TO
ENSURE ONGOING INCLUSIVENESS.
AND I INTEND TO MAKE THIS A
PRIORITY. IN MY TIME AS YOU ARE
THE POPULATION GROW FROM FORTY
THOUSAND TO OUR HIGHEST ABOUT
HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND.
TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY WITH
APPROXIMATELY NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND- HOUSE WITHIN OUR-
INSTITUTIONS AS WELL AS OUR
COMMUNITY FACILITIES. DO NOT
SUBSTANTIALLY. OVER THE YEARS
DUE TO VERY AS- STATE
LEGISLATION VOTER INITIATIVES
FEDERAL COURT ORDERS AND
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIONS TAKEN BY
THIS AND- AS A RESULT. ALL THE
DECLINE IN POPULATIONS WE HAD
TO MAKE THE DIFFICULT DECISION.
RELATED TO PRISON CLOSURE. WE
RECENTLY HAD TO ANNOUNCE THE
CLOSURE OF CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL CENTER SUSANVILLE.
AS WELL AS THE CLOSURE OF ONE
SECURE LEVEL ONE FACILITY A
CORRECTIONAL TRAINING FACILITY
AT SALT ACT. ACTIONAL SKEWS ME
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
INSTITUTION AT TO HATCH. BUT
JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO THESE
ARE AN ADDITIONAL TO THE DOOR
VOCATIONAL INSTITUTE WHICH WAS
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED IN
SEPTEMBER AND WILL CLOSE IN
SEPTEMBER OF THIS YEAR. I WILL
LEAD THIS AGENCY WERE ST CITY
AND WITH SENSITIVITY AND
COMPASSION. AS WE CLOSE THESE
INSTITUTIONS MAKING SURE THAT
WE TAKE CARE OF OUR STAFF AS
WELL AS THE POPULATION DURING
THIS TIME OF THE ADJUSTMENT AND
TRANSITION. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
FOCUS OUR ATTENTION ON STOCK
WELLNESS UNDERSTAND THESE THESE
JOBS ARE STRESSFUL. OUR STAFF
NEED OUR SUPPORT. EVEN MORE SO
IN THE SPACE IN ON CERTAIN SHE
IS UNCERTAIN TIMES I WILL WORK
DILIGENTLY TO IMPLEMENT THE
CHANGES OF STATE LEGISLATION
AND VOTER INITIATIVES. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD
THIS AGENCY. I'M HUMBLED AND
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY AND
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR QUESTION.
SECRETARY THANK YOU- I'M GONNA
GO AHEAD AND GO TO MY
COLLEAGUES AND GIVEN THAT WE
HAVE IT AND ONE COLLEAGUE THAT
IS ON TO COMMITTEES- RIGHT NOW
I'M GOING TO START WITH US
SENATOR GROVE TO MAKE SURE SHE
HAS A CHANCE TO. ASK HER
QUESTIONS TO MAKE HER COMMENTS
SENATOR GROWTH. THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEM AND- THANK YOU- MISS
ALLISON FOR ALLOWING ME TO ASK
YOU THESE QUESTIONS- MYSELF.
CENTER DOLLY AND- SENATOR
CAFIERO- READ YOUR PRESS
RELEASE LAST NIGHT. WE CALLED
OUR PRISON SYSTEMS THE WARDENS
ARE CITY MANAGERS OUR COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. AND NO
ONE KNEW ABOUT THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT. TO CLOSE THESE
FACILITIES IN OUR DISTRICTS- I
THINK THAT- ALL OF US EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE ON DIFFERENT
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT SHOULD
HAVE SOME TYPE OF DECENCY AND
RESPECT. THAT AND IF THE
DEPARTMENT IS GOING TO MAKE A
DECISION ABOUT CLOSING
FACILITIES THAN- WE SHOULD AT
LEAST BE SOMEWHAT NOTIFIED IN
SOME TYPE OF ADVANCE ORDER. AND
I'D LIKE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
THAT SPECIFIC SUBJECT THAT'S
OKAY. OKAY SO THE WHEN I SERVED
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND PART OF
THIS A SMALL FOR VERY SMALL
SHORT TIME IN THE SENATE I
WORKED ON- BUDGETS THAT DEALT
WITH THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHEN THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS-
PROGRAMS WERE BEING DOWNSIZED
AND CLOSED. THEY HAD A PLAN IN
PLACE AND- THEY HAD- IN
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM THEY PUT A
PLAN TOGETHER THEY DID AN
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM FOR
DISPLACED STAFF THEY CONFERRED
WITH COUNTY GOVERNMENT IN CITY
GOVERNMENT IN THE CITIES WHERE
THESE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
WERE LOCATED BECAUSE- THERE
WOULD OBVIOUSLY BE AN IMPACT ON
THE COMMUNITY THAT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS BUSINESS BECAUSE OF JOB
CLOSURES. IN THEIR DISK IN
THESE AREAS. THEY HAD AT LEAST
ONE PUBLIC HEARING SO THAT THE
HE- PUBLIC COULD BE AWARE. OF
THAT THE CLOSURE OF THESE
FACILITIES. THEY ACTUALLY HAD
TO SUBMIT A PLAN TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT INCLUDE A
DESCRIPTION OF THE STAKEHOLDER
IMPACT INCLUDING THE
DESCRIPTION OF LOCAL ISSUES
CONCERNS RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING THE PROPOSED
CLOSURES. AND ALTERNATIVE USES
OF THE PROPERTY. AND THEY
WANTED TO KNOW THE IMPACT ON
RESIDENTS AND FAMILIES THE
RESIDENT PLACEMENT WHERE WOULD
THEY GO THE DESCRIPTION OF JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DISPLACED
EMPLOYEES. AND THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF CLOSURE SPECIFICALLY
ON THE AREA AND A TIME LINE FOR
THAT CLOSURE- AND- THAT'S A- A
FAR CRY FROM WHAT WE JUST
EXPERIENCED WITH CDC ARE SO AS
SOME AND I'M NOT. I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE ONLY BEEN IN CHARGE FOR
JUST A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME.
BUT CAN YOU TELL ME HOW YOU'RE
GOING TO ADDRESS THIS IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU MA'AM I WILL
SAY GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM DID
HIGHLIGHTS THE TO PRISON
CLOSURES IN HIS TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET- AND THEN OF COURSE
WE ARE FOLLOWING OURTHE PENAL
CODE GUIDANCE- AS IT RELATES TO
FACILITIES CLOSURES. SO WE HAD
VERY AS- AND NOW SPENDS OF
CLOSURES IN THE PAST AND HAD
NOT ACTUALLY COMPLETED THOSE
FOR VARIETY OF REASONS MOST OF
THEM POPULATION PRESSURES. I
WILL SAY OUR POPULATION IS DOWN
AS FAR AS I HIGHLIGHTED YOU
HAVE- YOU KNOW NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND. I THE REASON FIRST
SOME OF THE REASONS FOR THE
SELECTIONS OF A PARTICULAR
FACILITY AND THAT THE
PRIORITIZE FOR CLOSURE IS THE
COST TO OPERATE A FACILITY. THE
CURRENT CAPACITY. IMPRACTICAL
ON THE WORK FORCE. THE HOUSING
NEEDS- WE HAVE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION A GENDER
RESPONSIVE NEEDS- WHETHER WE
NEED WHATEVER TYPES OF
FACILITIES THAT WE NEED A LONG
TERM INVESTMENT IN THE
FACILITY- AS WELL AS PUBLIC
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE DURATION
OF THE STATE'S SOLUTION FOR
OVERCROWDING. SO HOW DO I SAY
THIS AND I CERTAINLY WILL LOOK
AT WHICH YOU BROUGHT UP AS FAR
AS HOW OTHER AGENCIES HAVE DONE
THAT'S- TYPICALLY- THESE THESE
THINGS ARE KEPT VERY
CONFIDENTIAL UNTIL THE VERY
END. WHEN WE GO TO ANNOUNCERS
NAMES HIGHER UPS UNIFICATION
PLAN THAT HAS WORKED OUT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE CALLING I
PERSONALLY CALLED THE SHERIFF I
CALLED THE WARDEN WE ACTUALLY
HAVE THE UNDERSECRETARY. OF
OPERATIONS PHYSICALLY BEAR
YESTERDAY TO TELL THE STAFF
FIRST THING IN THE MORNING- WE
DID THE SAME THING FOR THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF DVI SECRETARY
DS PHYSICALLY WAS THERE I WOULD
HAVE BEEN THERE YESTERDAY
MYSELF HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR
HEARING TO DAY- IT'S CERTAINLY
NOT LOST ON ME IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME FOR THE STAFF. I
WILL SAY THROUGH THE VOLUNTARY
TRANSFER PROCESS FOR THE STAFF
AT DVI- ALL WERE WORRIED THAT
THE STAGES OF GETTING THAT
FINALIZED BURKE. TO MY
KNOWLEDGE WAS EVER SINGLE STAFF
HAS HOW HAS A PLACE TO LAND-
YOU KNOW ANOTHER INSTITUTION WE
HAD NUMEROUS VACANCIES. IN THE
STATE WHEN THAT DECISION WAS
MADE. WORDS CC HAS FIFTY PER
COUPON. I AND SO ONE OF THE
FACTORS THAT HAS TO BE TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION. TO HATCH A
P. IS 47% CAPACITY ON THEIR END
AND WHEN I STATE TO HATCH A P.
IT'S JUST OUR SECURE LEVEL ONCE
WAS ONE YARD WITH IN THE
INSTITUTION OF VARIOUS ARMS I
THINK THEY HAVE FOR FINE. AND
THE SAME CTF IS THAT 61%
EMPHATIC. THANK I'M NOT SURE
WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE HOLD ON
JUST A SECOND LET US MAKE SURE
WE'VE GOT THAT COVERED. HOW'S
THAT IS THAT SOUND OKAY NOW
WE'RE GOOD OKAY. I'M NOT SURE
WHAT HAPPENED THERE AND
TECHNOLOGY HI AGAIN I JUST WANT
EXPRESSED MY CONCERN- FOR THE
WARDEN KATE'S INTACT TO BE
THERE'S THREE OR FOUR INMATES
IN SEVENTY FOUR STAFF. HE FOUND
OUT. A THIS MORNING. I FOUND
OUT BECAUSE OF MY COLLEAGUE
ASKED ME TO ASK THESE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE SUSANVILLE CLOSURE IN
HIS DISTRICT WHICH IS ONE OF
THE LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN HIS
DISTRICT. AND QUITE IRONICALLY
IT'S WHERE YOU TRAIN ALL THAT
INMATE- OR INCARCERATED
FIREFIGHTERS. IN A FIRE PRONE
AREA IN FIRE SEASON WHICH WE
DEAL WITH- IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT FACILITY
IS CLOSING- AND THEN AS I READ
THE PRESS RELEASE THAT WAS
ATTACHED TO IT I NOTICED THAT
THEY HAD TO BE WAS THERE AND I
NOTICED THAT- SOLEDAD WAS
THERE. AND SO I AM TEXANA
CABALLERO INTO HAD NO IDEA
EITHER I JUST THINK THAT AND-
THE WAY THAT YOU GUYS WENT
ABOUT THIS NEEDS TO CHANGE AND
I WANT- I REALLY DO WANT TO
COMMITMENT FROM YOU THAT THAT
THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY WON'T-
CONTINUE IN THIS WAY. AND WE
SHOULD LOOK AT MOVING FORWARD
IN MODELING AT PRACTICES LIKE
OTHER AGENCIES SO THAT THERE IS
COMMUNITY INPUT I MEAN EVEN
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SEVENTY FOUR
STAFF AND- EVEN INTO HATCH BEER
YOU LOOK AT SENATOR DOLLIES
DISTRICT OR SENATOR COPIERS
DISTRICT WAS SOLID AT. THERE'S
IMPACTS ON OUR DISTRICTS THERE
THESE PEOPLE OWN HOMES HAVE
CARS AND HE YOU'RE GONNA
TRANSFER INDUSTRY TO TRANSFER
TO A DIFFERENT LOCATION AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BUY OR
CONSUME IN THESE AREAS. AND
IT'S IMPACTFUL ON EACH ONE OF
OUR DISTRICTS AND SO I'M ASKING
FOR A COMMITMENT THAT THIS WILL
BE FROM YOU THAT THIS WILL BE
ADDRESSED A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT OR AT LEAST
DIFFERENTLY IN THE FUTURE- AND
WE AS LEGISLATORS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES WILL FIND OUT
BECAUSE OF A PRESS RELEASE. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE DISCUSSION OF THE CLOSURE
OF THE FACILITY. MA'AM I. THANK
YOU- I PERSONALLY CALLED WARDEN
SHEETS ON ON MONDAY AFTERNOON-
AND I WILL SAY THAT- WE DID
HAVE A COMMUNICATION PLAN IF
THERE WERE SOME PEOPLE MISSED
IN THAT COMMUNICATION PLAN BY
VARIOUS DISTRICTS I WILL
DEFINITELY BE ADDRESS MATCH AND
I WILL WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AS FAR AS AN
OVERALL PLAN- I UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE OTHER STATE HOSPITALS- THE
OTHER FACILITY I THINK WAS
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER SHE SAID.
I THINK THAT WAS KIND OF A
HOLISTIC APPROACH THAT THEY
WERE CLOSING SEVERAL
FACILITIES- THERE ARE NO
WEATHER FACILITIES PLANNED AT
THIS TIME BUT WILL DEFINITELY
TAKE ALL THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION GOING FORWARD SO
THAT WE DO ADDRESS SOME
CONCERNS I WILL SAY THAT
WHENEVER WE HIGHLIGHT THAT YOU
SOLD IS GOING TO CLOSE. WE
ALMOST HAVE A MASS EXODUS OF
STAFF AND I STILL HAVE TO
OPERATE A FACILITY AND I IS.
MANY OF YOU KNOW ON THIS. IN
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY THAT WE'VE
BEEN OUT C. R. C. R. CAL REAL
BILL. CENTER FOR. NUMEROUS
TIMES OVER THE YEARS AND WE
NEVER CALL. BUT EVERY SINGLE
TIME THAT WE'VE ANNOUNCED THAT.
THEY THEY HAVE BEEN KIND OF
SICK STRUGGLE WITH STAFFING.
AND SO THAT'S OF REASON BUT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE DO NEED
TO WORK ON AND I LIKE I COMMIT
YOU TO WORK WITH YOU WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION ON
THE BEST PATH FORWARD. M. THANK
YOU FOR THAT I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR HIM AND MY
COLLEAGUES SENATOR DOLLY. AND
HE'S CURIOUS ABOUT WHAT
CRITERIA DATA THAT USED TO MAKE
THE CLOSURE DETERMINATION AND-
WAS THERE EVEN AN ECONOMIC
IMPACT STUDY DONE ON HOW MUCH
THE CLOSURE WILL AFFECT THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY LOCAL
BUSINESSES CURRENT EMPLOYEES IN
THE PRISON IN SUSANVILLE. AND
THE FACT THAT- THERE ARE HIGH
PRONE WHILE AREA DEADLIEST FIRE
IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA
PARADISES IN THAT COMMUNITY IN
THAT AREA- I BELIEVE CAMPFIRE
IS IN THAT AREA. AND THAT'S
WHERE THE TRAIN INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS TO FIGHT THESE
FIRES IN THAT HIGH PRONE
MOUNTAIN AREA- JUST- IT FOR
REFERENCE I HAVE A BUSINESS IN
A IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR. AND IN
WHEN THEY TRAIN THEY DO
SPECIFIC TRAINING FOR SPECIFIC
JOBS IF IT'S IN THE DESERT THEY
TRAIN IN THE DESERT THEY DON'T
TRAIN AT THE BEACH AND THEN GO
PERFORMING THE DESERT. AND SO-
THE TRAINING THAT'S OFFERED IN
THIS COMMUNITY UP THERE IS A
MOUNTAIN COMMUNITY. BECAUSE
FIGHTING FIRES AND CLIMBING UP
AND DOWN HILLS IS WAY DIFFERENT
THAN FIGHTING FIRES ON A FLAT
LANDSCAPE. AND SO COULD YOU
ANSWER ANY OF THOSE QUESTIONS
PLEASE. YES MA'AM. A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION OKAY SO ALL THE
FIRE CAMPS WILL REMAIN INTACT-
WITH THEIR SINGING STOCKING AND
THE SAME POPULATION. THE FIRE
TRAINING COMPONENT THAT IS
CURRENTLY AT CCC WILL TRANSFER
TO SIERRA CONSERVATION CENTER
FOR THAT EXACT SAME TRAINS THEY
ALREADY HAVE THE FACILITY
THERE. THEY CURRENTLY TRAINED
FIREFIGHTERS FOR THE SOMETHING
RECHARGE NOW THEY WILL TRAINED
FIREFIGHTERS FOR THE NORTHERN
REGION- AND I KNEW THERE WAS
SOMETHING ELSE YOU SAID ALL YOU
ASKED ABOUT THE CRITERIA THAT
WE UTILIZE YES SO WE FOLLOWED
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE SECTION
TWENTY SIXTY SEVEN AND FIVE
ZERO ZERO THREE POINT SEVEN
WHICH PROVIDES GUIDANCE FOR CDC
ARE FACILITIES FOR CLOSURE.
THAT INCLUDES COST AND I THINK
I'VE I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE
RECOUP THE COSTS THE IMPACT OF
THE CLOSURE OF THE WORK FORCE-
AND I SAID ALL THOSE OTHER
THINGS EARLIER BUT HE DID NOT
INCLUDE- AND ACADEMIC- EXCUSE
ME AND- ECONOMIC IMPACT AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT
INCLUDED- IN. THAT PENAL CODE
SECTION BUT CERTAINLY SOMETHING
TO EVALUATE WILL CERTAINLY NOT
LOST ON ME THAT YOU KNOW. THE
TWO PERSONS UP THERE AND SUSAN
BELL IS THE PRIMARY EMPLOYERS.
ONE OF THE FACTORS THAT WE HAVE
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION AND
FORCE FOR PICKING A LOCATION
WHICH IS THE FACT THAT ANNUALLY
WE HAVE TO SEND UP
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED NEW
CADETS. UP TO THAT LOCATION I
THINK IT'S ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
EACH- AND SO IT'S LIKE A
REVOLVING DOOR STAFF GO THERE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO- STAY SO
THEY LEAVE THEY THEY WAIT TO
TIME DEVELOP LATERALLY TRANSFER
CAL. THAT'S FOR THE- THE
CUSTANCE OUT MAJORITY OF OUR
NON CUTS TO STAFF ARE PRETTY-
STATIONARY STAFF IN THE FROM
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY. I WILL SAY
THAT OBVIOUSLY THESE
NEGOTIATION PROCESS FOR ANY
KIND- TRANSFER OR REAL. OF
STAFF. BUT ONE OF MY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE TEAM
THAT'S DEVELOPING THIS IS
DEFINITELY AFFORD AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
NOT FROM THAT COMMUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO TRANSFER OUT. SO THAT
THE WHAT. ARE THE MEMBERS FROM
THAT COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN BORN
AND RAISED IN DEDICATED THEIR
LIVES. TO THIS DEPARTMENT. YOUR
LIVE AND IN THE- KIDS GO TO
SCHOOL AND THEY THEY DATA THEY
DON'T A JOB RESIDENTS BUT THOSE
ARE THE STAFF TO GET TO REMAIN
PLANES. SO WE WILL WORK VERY
VERY DILIGENTLY OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE UNION NEGOTIATIONS TO GO
THROUGH BUT WE DEFINITELY HAVE
MY COMMITMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE STAFF. ARE TAKEN CARE OF AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE WE PROVIDE ALL
THE FIRE SUPPORT AS POSSIBLE IN
THAT AREA WITH OUR EXISTING
WITH THE FIRE CAMP CENTER. OKAY
I. THAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT STAFF IS HAD YOU KNOW HAS
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
RELOCATE AND GO TO A DIFFERENT
JOB. BUT I ALSO WANT A
COMMITMENT FROM YOU THAT. YOU
KNOW THE IMPACTS ON THE
COMMUNITY AND THE STAFF THAT
LIVE UP THERE THEY BY LOCAL
VEHICLES THEY BUY HOMES OR RENT
HOMES THEY- SHOP AT THE LOCAL
GROCERY STORE THEY SHOP AT THE
LOCAL- CLOTHING STORE. AND THEY
SUPPORT AND THE LOCAL LITTLE
LEAGUE- YOU KNOW EVERYTHING
THAT YOU DO AS A GOOD CITIZEN
IN THE COMMUNITY. S. THESE
INDIVIDUALS DO THAT AND
SHUTTING DOWN THAT FACILITY-
LOSING THE- LUMBER MILLS THAT
HAVE BEEN UP THERE. IT'S
DECIMATING THAT PART OF OUR
STATE AND I JUST THINK OF THE
STATE I MEAN WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL RIGHT
AND IF THE STATE IS GOING TO
HAVE. THESE CLOSURES THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOME TYPE OF.
PUBLIC INPUT FOR THESE
BUSINESSES AND HEALTHIER AND
THESE COMMUNITIES. ALL
DISTRICTS ALL THEY'RE ALL TO BE
AFFECTED BY THIS. AND I KNOW
THAT YOU'VE OF FOCUSED ON STAFF
AND I APPRECIATE THAT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT STAFF IS
COMMITTED TO THIS TYPE OF WORK
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO
ANOTHER FACILITY AND CONTINUE
THEIR CAREER- BUT WE ALSO.
THESE CLOSURES. ABSOLUTELY
MA'AM I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THAT AND ALMOST ALL OF OUR WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF THE VERY FEW
OF US ALL OF OUR PRISONS ARE IN
REMOTE LOCATIONS AND THAT. YOU
KNOW. I STARTED THIS BUSINESS
IN AND WHEN THEY WERE BUILDING
PRISONS ON EVERY CORNER AND I
KNOW THE IMPACT THAT THE
INSTITUTIONS HAVE ON OUR VERY
SMALL COMMUNITIES- AND THE AND
THE MANY COMPANY KIND OF
CLOSURE ANNOUNCEMENT- THAT HAS
A THIS VERY SPOT. OF SOMEBODY'S
OUT AND ALSO PRISON MOST PEOPLE
DON'T EVEN KNOW ALLEN ALL. AND
I WOULD EVERY TIME I GO ANYWAY
AS MY NINE FIVE. I'M SORRY WHAT
TYPE IT EVERY. EVERY TIME I'M
MY WAY TO GO HOME AND I FOR.
OKAY SO YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE I
WOULD. YEAH I CERTAINLY. NOT
LOST ON ME IF WE WERE TO LOSE
THAT THE IMPACT ON THE
COMMUNITY- AND SO WE CERTAINLY.
WILL TAKE THAT- INTO
CONSIDERATION. GOING FORWARD
IT'S YOU KNOW IT. IS WE'RE
WE'RE REALLY STUCK IN A IN A
CONTACT POINT THREE HERE
BECAUSE- OUR LARGER
METROPOLITAN AREAS LIKE TO
RECRUIT STAFF. AND THEY WOULD
HAVE TO BIGGEST IMPACT WHERE MY
MORE MORE LOCATIONS I HAD
DIFFICULTY STAFFING. A SO YOU
KNOW IT IT IS A VERY COMPLEX
PROBLEM. BUT I'M DEFINITELY
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE IT
SEAMLESS THANK YOU MA'AM I
APPRECIATE THAT COMMITMENT. I
ALSO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS- FOR
SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW THAT THE RULES
COMMITTEE- REPRESENTS ALL OF
OUR COLLEAGUES ON THE DECISIONS
THAT ARE ARE MADE IN THIS IN
THIS- COMMITTEE. SO ON BEHALF
OF MY COLLEAGUE THIS YEAR'S
CENTRAL VALLEY IN KERN COUNTY
WITH ME MISS HER TADO. AT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SHAFTER DELANO
IN TAFT. ARE THESE GOING TO BE
PERMANENT CLOSURES. I I'M SORRY
I DON'T THINK I QUITE
UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION. ARE
THAT SHE'S ASKING IF THE
OPERATIONS WITH THE LAST THREE
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SHAFTER DELANO IN TAFT.
SHE WANTS TO KNOW IF THESE ARE
GONNA BE PERMANENT CLOSURES SO
THERE. TEMPORARILY OR SUSPENDED
OR WHATEVER THERE. THERE ARE NO
ONE IN THESE FACILITIES AND-
ARE THESE GOING TO BECOME
PERMANENT CLOSURES. SO WE HAVE
ANNOUNCED THOSE CLOSURES
PREVIOUSLY DUE TO THE
POPULATION REDUCTIONS. I WILL
SAY THAT WE DON'T HAVE THAT
SAME LOW LEVEL OFFENDERS THAT
WE DID IN YEARS PAST AND SO I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
AGREEMENTS WITH EACH OF THOSE
FACILITIES AND I DON'T KNOW THE
NUANCES OF THEIR INDIVIDUAL
CONTRACTS I WOULD NOT WANT TO
SPEAK TO THAT. BUT I WILL SAY
THAT THERE IS CURRENTLY NOT IN
NEED FOR THOSE FACILITIES
WITHOUT POPULATION BEING- AND
NOT NINETY FIVE THOUSAND WE DO
HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL POPULATIONS
IN THE COUNTY JAILS BUT WE KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS- AND SO AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT NEED THOSE
FACILITIES. I SO I GUESS THE
SECOND FOLLOW UP IS THAT YOU
HAVE THESE FACILITIES HAVE BEEN
ANNOUNCED FOR CLOSURE THEY'VE
BEEN CLOSE THERE'S NO PEOPLE IN
THESE FACILITIES. AND THE CITY
OF SHAFTER IN TAFT INCLUDING
ARE STILL HAVING A COST OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO MAINTAIN THE EMPTY PRISON-
BECAUSE OF THE LEASE. IS THERE
ANY WAY THAT CDC ARE CAN BE A
LITTLE CONGENIAL AND LET SOME
OF THESE SERVICES CITIES AND
COUNTIES OUT OF THESE LEASES.
BECAUSE THE FACILITIES ARE
EMPTY. AND THEN THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE STILL REQUIRED TO
PAY THESE AND YOU KNOW THESE
FEES AND MAINTAIN THESE
FACILITIES WHEN YOU HAVE NO
INTENTION OF OPENING THEM BACK
UP. SO WE'VE BEEN THERE
NUMEROUS NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
CITY'S AND CONVERSATIONS-
REGARDING THESE VERY SPECIFIC
ISSUES I KNOW WE PAID OUR
RESPONSE FOR THOSE FACILITIES
ON IT AND I DON'T KNOW THE
FREQUENCY NAME TO MR BARR CAN
DRESS A LITTLE BETTER THAN I
CAN. BUT I DO KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
BASICALLY SUBLEASED SOME STRESS
CELANESE- AND THEY COULD DO NOW
I THANK REMEMBER THE TIME FRAME
FOR THE CONTRACT. BUT THEY THEY
COULD SUBLEASE THE SO. WITH X.
ON CON IF THEY IF THEY NEED TO-
I'M NOT I'M NOT DIRECTLY
INVOLVED WITH ANY CURRENT
NEGOTIATIONS IF THERE ARE
CURRENT NEGOTIATIONS GOING ON.
WITH THOSE SPECIFIC FACILITIES-
LIKE I SAID MAYBE THAT COULD BE
ADDRESSED SEPARATELY AND I JUST
DON'T KNOW OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD EXACTLY. WHERE EVERYTHING
HAS KIND OF. YOU KNOW LANDED
WITH OUR CURRENT NEED FOR WITH
OUR CURRENT NOT NEEDING NOW
COUPLED WITH ANY LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS BASED ON THE LEAST
BOND STUFF THAT IS REALLY
STOPPED I OBVIOUSLY DON'T
CLEARLY UNDERSTAND ALL THE
NUANCES. THERE- BUT HOPEFULLY I
CAN ANSWER I DO NOT. THINK
THINKS JUST. TO RELEASE- OUT OF
THOSE CON ON A SURE IS THAT
SENATOR LET ME UP A PEN AND
NECK- BECAUSE THE SECTOR. MAY
ARE. MAYBE DIRECTOR OR BOARD
YOU CAN RESPOND TO THAT
QUESTION AND SHOULD THAT ALSO
THEN LATER NOT BE ADEQUATE
ENOUGH LET ME REFER TO STAFF
THAT THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS
HERE ABOUT THE LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS- THAT AS IT RELATES
TO THE CITIES AND THE COUNTIES.
AND WE WILL DRAFT A LETTER AND
GET IT WE WILL EXPECTED WHAT
FOLLOW UP ON THAT SO WE'LL PUT
IT. YOU CAN ASK THE QUESTION
AGAIN BUT SHOULD WE NOT GET AN
ANSWER AND IT'S NOT CLEAR TO US
WE WILL SEND A LETTER FROM
RULES AS WE HAVE DONE- OTHER
TIMES AND MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
SOME RESPONSE ON ON THAT AND
WHAT THE OPTIONS ARE- ON THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM- ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE IS A SAID IN THIS IS
ACTUALLY IN SENATOR HER TAUGHT
US DISTRICTS AFTER BUT IT'S IN
KERN COUNTY AS A COMMUNITY WE
BOTH CARE ABOUT- YOU KNOW LIKE
I SAID THE CITY OF SHAFTER A
SMALL. CITY IF I WAS TO TAKE A
GUESS I WOULD PROBABLY SAY AND
AGAIN IT'S A GUESTS BUT IT'S A
PRETTY DARN GOOD WENT THAT IT
SAID NINETY THREE OR NINETY
FOUR PERCENT. OF LATINO- OF THE
FARMING COMMUNITY IN THE
SHAFTER AREA. IT IS- THIS OF
SHAFTER THEY WERE TO TURN THIS
pFACILITY IN A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BECAUSE AFTER IS ROUGHLY. MILE
AWAY FROM SPELL. AND THEY WOULD
HAVE TO THOSE CAN. MEMBERS HAVE
DRIVE TO BAKER. OR TAFT IF THEY
WANT TO GET ANY TYPE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND THEY COULD PUT
THAT FACILITY TO GOOD USE. AND
THEY CAN'T DO ANYTHING WITH IT
BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL PAYING A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE. THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR TO MAINTAIN A
FACILITY THAT. IT APPEARS CDCR
IS NOT EVER GOING TO OPEN BACK
UP. SO IF YOU COULD LOOK AT
THAT OR HAVE SOMEBODY REACH OUT
AND THEN. THE SENATE PRO TEM
HAS OCCURRED YOU KNOW IT'S
GONNA HAVE STAFF ROOF YOU KNOW
PUT THE LETTER TOGETHER
REGARDING THE RULES AND HOW
THAT WORKS BUT- SENATOR- HER
TADO WOULD BE VERY GRATEFUL. IF
YOU WOULD TO INFORM HER- ON
THAT PROCESS BECAUSE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN THAT AREA.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE HIGH LATINO
POPULATION. I WOULD BE VERY
BENEFICIAL FOR THAT COMMUNITY.
AND I THINK THAT'S ALL THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME. VENT. CENTER GROVE
THANK YOU- AND WITH THAT I'M
GOING TO GO TO SENATOR COME
LONGER NEXT. THANK YOU MADAM
HOTEL HOW ARE YOU DOING SECOND.
FINDING YOU SO MUCH FOR ASKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON SO I ALSO HAVE A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS FOR YOU- I
THANK YOU FOR AGREEING TO MEET
WITH ME EARLIER TODAY THAT WAS-
NICE WHEN WE FIRST MET IT
ACTUALLY SOMETIME AGO IT WAS IN
RESPONSE TO A HEARING THAT I
HAD- ON. CONDITIONS THE
CONDITIONS OF THE OUR WOMEN'S
PRISONS. AND IN THAT HEARING
WOMEN TALKED ABOUT NOT BEING
ABLE TO FILE GRIEVANCES HAVING
THE GRIEVANCE PROCESS STALLED-
BECAUSE OF COBIT POSSIBLY THEY
TALKED ABOUT UNSANITARY UNSAFE
CONDITIONS THEY TALKED ABOUT
NEEDING TO USE THEIR OWN
SANITARY NAPKINS AND PROVISIONS
TO CLEAN THEIR CELLS TO CLEAN
THEIR COVERT CELLS. THE CLEAN
THE CELLS OF WOMEN WHO HAD
CONTRACTED COBIT AND HAD BEEN
MOVED- AND THAT THEY WERE
GETTING NO SUPPORT FROM CDC
ARE- I MENTION THIS CDCR STAFF
DISMISSED AND DISPUTED THE
CLAIMS- AND YET IN IN- IG
REPORT- SPECIFIC TO THE
GRIEVANCE PROCESSES. THE O.I.
G. REPORT ACTUALLY FOUND THE
CDC OURS IMPLEMENTATION OF
THEIR STEPS MEANT TO IMPROVE
THE HANDLING OF INCARCERATED
PERSONS ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT FAILED AT BOTH
FAIRNESS AND INDEPENDENCE SO I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW YOUR
RESPONSE- TO THIS ISSUE AND I
GUESS I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT I
BELIEVE THE WOMEN. THANK THANK
YOU MA'AM I WILL SAY THAT- OUR
STAFF COMPLAINT PROCESS- THAT
WAS MODIFIED LAST YEAR THAT
WENT INTO EFFECT JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN FULL
IMPLEMENTATION IN APRIL OF
TWENTY TWENTY WAS EXTREMELY
PROBLEMATIC- IT NEEDS MUCH
IMPROVEMENT. NOW IT WAS A
PROCESS THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
THAT- WE MADE IT TOO COMPLEX SO
WE'VE BEEN WORKING TIRELESSLY
WITH THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AS WELL AS
COURT EXPERTS TO REFINANCE
PROCESS AS WE TAKE ALL OF THE
ALLEGATIONS OUT OF THE
INSTITUTION. GO TO A
CENTRALIZED SCREENING LOCATION
OFF FOR PROCESSING AND
ASSIGNMENTS WE WILL HAVE
INDEPENDENT EVALUATORS EVALUATE
MAJORITY OF THOSE- COMPLAINTS-
SOME MAY RETURN THERE WILL BE
IMPACT MATRIX AGREED UPON WITH
THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL OF OURSELVES AND OUR
COURT EXPERTS ON WHICH WHICH OF
THESE GRIEVANCES MAY RETURN TO
THE INSTITUTION. AT WHICH WILL
BE ASSIGNED TO A LIEUTENANT AND
WHICH WILL BE ASSIGNED TO A
SPECIAL INVESTIGATOR THAT'S
KIND OF WE'RE STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF FINALIZING THOSE-
AND THEN WE WILL HAVE TO FILE
THAT WITH COURT HERE VERY
SHORTLY. I'M STILL VERY
COMMITTED TO MAKING THAT A
PROCESS THAT IS THE. PROCESS OF
INTEGRITY. ACOSTA STUDENTS TRY.
AT AND TO SERVE THE- I HAVE
KNOWN FOR MANY AND BILL IS THAT
A IT IT'S ACROSS THAT NEEDED TO
BE. A CORRECTED I ACT WAS
INVOLVED. EARLY WHEN I WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF CHILDREN'S- TAX GET
THIS. THAT WE HAVE CHANGE OUR
APPEALS. AND I KNEW THAT
BECAUSE AS A HIGH AT THE AS
WELL. I THAT YOU KNOW YOU SEE
STAFF COMPLAIN COME THROUGH AND
LET'S 9098% NO FINE. HOWEVER I
HAVE TO KNOW MANY ADVERSE ACT I.
ALL THE STAFF AND INVESTIGATE
GOING TWENTY THERE WAS A D. SO
THOSE POSH IS BUT THE WORKS FOR
A LONG TIME. HONESTLY GOT IT
WRONG WE GOT A RAW WE NEED. WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF- AND I
LIKE THIS WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE OFFICE INSPECT GENERAL
WELL AS THE BILL- STAFF- THAT
HAVE BEEN VERY IN. ON IN EACH
REVIEW IN DROUGHT AND JUST
THINGS AS WE GO ALONG- WE AYE
AYE OUT FOR TIME TO SLOW DOWN
GET BY. I DO NOT WANT TO BE IT
FOR IT TO BE A- PAW. THAT WE
THAT WE DO NOT GET RIGHT THE
FIRST. MMHM THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF I. G.
THAT CAME OUT AS I AM. YOU KNOW
AND MOST OF THEM WERE PRETTY.
WE DID YOU DID TALK ABOUT THE-
THIS AMES. BUT THEY'RE ALSO-
REPORTS ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DISASTER RESPONSE TO COVET. AND
THERE ARE THERE WAS A REPORT ON
THE ABUSE OF- CARS RATED PEOPLE
WHO ARE DISABLED. BY STAFF. AND
SO. THE TWO BIG ISSUES BUT
WOULD CERTAINLY WANT YOUR
RESPONSE ON THE CHANGES THAT
CDCR IS MAKING SO THAT A WERE
NOT. ABUSING INCARCERATED FOLKS
WITH DISABILITIES- AND BE WE
ARE FIGURING OUT A MORE HUMANE
WAY TO RESPOND TO THE NEXT
CRISIS THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
IN CDC ARE. SO THAT WE ARE ALSO
NOT HAVING STAFF FILING
GRIEVANCES AND SAYING THAT
THEY'RE WORKING IN UNSAFE
CONDITIONS ALONG WITH HAVING
INCARCERATED FOLKS. CRYING TO
EACH OTHER AND TO THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS SAYING THAT THEY'RE
GONNA DIE IN THERE. THANK YOU
MA'AM- I. SO HOW CAN I TAKE
THIS UNDERTAKEN SINCE PARTS IT
OUT JOHN OUT OKAY ALL RIGHT SO.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF. OUR
CCAR'S FOR TO COPE WITH. THERE
WERE SOME DECISIONS MADE THAT
TODAY WE WOULD HAVE MADE THE
SAME DECISIONS THERE'S NOT
ANYBODY IN THIS WORLD WOULD
MAKE THAT SAME DECISION- AND SO
IT WAS PROBLEMATIC WE
STRUGGLED. AS WITH THE REST OF
THE WORLD TO GET PP AND
ACTUALLY WE STRUGGLE TO GET
HAND SANITIZER AND JUST SOME OF
THE BASIC CLEANING SUPPLIES
THAT SOME OF THE POPULATION YOU
REFER TO. EVERYBODY STRUGGLE
THERE WAS HUGE DEMAND WE
FORTUNATELY OUR PRISON
INDUSTRIES KIND OF STEPPED UP
THEY STARTED MAKING SOME OF THE
SUPPLIES FOR US SO WE HAVE
AMPLE SUPPLY WE'RE ACTUALLY
HEADED THAT GAME A LITTLE BIT-
THANKS TO THE SUPPORT OF
CALLAWAY YES WE'RE ABLE TO GET
THE APPROPRIATE PP. YOU KNOW IT
WASN'T FIRST IT WASN'T IN MARCH
AND I COULDN'T EVEN TELL YOU
EXACTLY WHAT IT WAS. WE ALL
KNOW I HAD RETIRED FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME- AND SO I DON'T
KNOW EXACT WHERE AND ALL THE-
SUPPLIES CAME BUT I WILL SAY
CAL. RALLY THE MINISTRY RIGHTS.
TO GET US THE NOT. SUPPLIES
THAT WE NEEDED TO KEEP OUR
POPULATION AND OUR STAFF SAY.
SO THAT WAS THE INITIAL OPTIONS
I WILL SAY EARLY ON IN KOBE.
NOBODY KNEW IT WAS- EVERYONE
THOUGHT IT WAS LATE RELATED.
AND SEARCHES SAYS. AND THINGS
LIKE THAT BUT AIRBORNE BE NOT
NOW I FOR DISEASE CONTROL NOT
REALLY. THAT AND TO FIVE. AND.
AND THE TINY MIGHT BE A LITTLE
MY- BUT I. IN IT'S DEFINITELY
WE COME WAY. YOU KNOW WE FROM
REALLY SICKENING OUTCRY
SURFACED ANSWERED. BAD OUTCOMES
TO WALK POSITIVE OUTCOMES TO
THE TREE OUR HEALTH STAFF
DOCTOR. AND BE WORKED. TO A US
AS WELL SUITED. YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET. FOR OUR IN THE POPULAR
THAT OF TEST SIX BROKEN OF AND-
OF IT WAS FULL- REALLY MATTER.
DIFFICULT DECISION AS FAR AS
HOW FOR CORN ISOLATED SPACE AND
FOR ANY KIND MOVE- THE STATE
STILL THE- FOR HIGH RISK. CASES
ARE. WE UTILIZE CENTER FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AS WELL AS HELP
PARTNER OF PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE AS FAR AS HELPING US
THESE TO. THE TESTING THT WE
ARE ABLE TO DO THAT ARE FOR. NO
HAVE WE TAP WE HAVE TESTING-
FOR EXAMPLE I ABOUT- WE'RE ABLE
TO TEST THE SEVEN HOURS. WE'RE
ABLE TO TEST THE WHO DID NOT
COME WITH THAT WHAT THE TASK
WITH A POINT OF CARE REAL.
NURSE STAFF THEIR TO I SHOULD
HAVE ALL THEIR TIME INVOLUNTARY
FOR ALL ON THE WE TO THAT IT'S
DON'T EVER WORK WEEKEND BUT A
VOLUNTEER TO BE ABLE TO. AND
PROVIDE THAT TYPE COUCH AND A
COURSE WHICH WE DON'T HAVE A
SEPTIC OUT- THE HEALTH STAFF
OUR TEST THE POP WHO WAS DUE TO
MAKE SURE SO I TESTING FOR
CHANGE SHOULD I SAW. ALL SEEM
TO BE THE KEY FOR SUCCESS
INCOME AS WELL AS THE TRUE THE
OR TREAT NOW WHICH YOU KNOW I
DON'T THE SPECIFIC AND IF THE
DOCTOR FIX NOT HERE TO HAVE TO
DRESS THAT TO THE BY- WE
INSTRUMENTAL ONE OF PROVIDED NO
CORRECTIONAL. WILL THE FIRST IN
THE NATION TO PROVIDE- WITHIN
OUR- IN DECEMBER REACHED FOR
STARTED NOW ABOUT TO OUR POP
THAT ARE SKILLED FOR AS INSTEAD
OF BE IN A PAY RECEIVE BACK AND
HOW AT THE SETTING BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALL SKILLED NURSING AND
THAT'S CAL MEDIC STILL. IN BACK
AND CAL HEALTHCARE IN STOCK AS
WELL THE CWF THE WOMAN JUST SO
WHICH SO WE HEADED THE GAME I
WE WILL WE HAD- OVER SIXTY JOBS
IT MANAGED WHEN OTHER STATES
ARE GETTING NOW HAVE YOU DO.
AND WE THAT THROUGH THE DAY. OF
OUR CARE SO. THE OR- PLANS DID
MANAGE BACKS THE LAW CAMPAIGN.
TO I ENCOURAGE. THE ENTIRE POT
AS WELL AS- DO YOU. OF THE- US-
THE MINISTRY THEIR BACKS. TO
STAFF I MYSELF GOT- WITNESS GET
MY- AND SO WE DID A LOT OF
EFFORTS TO TRY AND GET TO UNDER
THE IMPORTANCE VACCINE AND HOW
THAT. WAS TO HELP US TO REACH
ALL OPERATIONS. SO AS. TO- YOUR
COMMENT IT AS THE- O. I. G.'S
REPORT ON- IT APPROPRIATE TREE
OF A- WHETHER THEY AMERICANS
WITH JUST ACT- OR ANY OF. I
DON'T TOLERATE. THE ENTIRE POP
BETWEEN DIGNITY RESPECT. AND SO
I CERTAINLY SOME THE EFFORTS
THAT WERE DUE AT LARGE R. G.
JOHN- AND NOT ONLY BODY CAMERA
BUT THE CARE. OUT OF FIXED
CAMERA EMPLOY MAPLE OF THIS. WE
HAVE A SUPER STAFF TO A- AS
WELL TO REALLY HOW US. TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WHAT THE
PROBLEM ONCE I WILL SAY WE HAD
A SIMILAR ALLEGATION AND ISSUES
HIGH THAT'S A SUPER SEVERAL
YEARS AGO WE IMPLEMENTED
CALLOUS ABOUT THIS. AND THE
THAT NUMBER- COMPLAINTS DROP DR.
AND SO. I LOW FORWARD TO FOR
TECHNOLOGY OUR FACILITIES TO
IMPROVE THE CONDITIONS FOR A
POPULATION OF OUR STAFF. THANK
YOU FOR THAT WELL I TO AGREE
THAT EVERYONE SHOULD BE TREATED
WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT
REGARDLESS OF IF THEY'RE
INCARCERATED OR NOT AND AS I
SHARED WITH YOU AND OUR
MEETING- IT MAKES ME THINK OF
HOWARD FORD WHO I WANT TO RAISE
UP WHO. IS SEVENTY SEVEN YEARS
OLD WHO IS AT C. S. P.
LANCASTER- WHO'S BEEN
INCARCERATED FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS WHO COULDN'T GOT CODED.
IN PRESENT AND IN DECEMBER. AS
A RESULT HE GOT GANGRENE AND
HAD BOTH OF HIS LEGS AMPUTATED
AND HAD AN ACCELERATED HEART
CONDITION. CDCR DID THAT TO HIM.
AND WHILE THAT MAY BE AN
EXTREME CASE IT'S STILL A CASE
NCDC ARE AND WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE STORIES. DON'T
HAPPEN. BECAUSE HE WAS NOT
TREATED. WITH RESPECT. I WANT
TO. ASK ABOUT. ARE YOU TALKED A
LOT ABOUT REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS AND HOW PROGRAMMING IS
VERY CLOSE TO YOUR HEART IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE STATE
AUDITOR- REPORTED OUT THAT CDCR
IS NEITHER. SHE CONSISTENTLY
PLACE PEOPLE ON WAITING LISTS
FOR NEEDED REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS NOR HAVE THEY
PRIORITIZE THOSE WITH THE
HIGHEST NEED CORRECTLY IT TALKS
A LOT ABOUT THE EFFICACY OF THE
IN PRISON COGNITIVE. BEHAVIORAL
THERAPY PROGRAMS. AND CALLED
INTO QUESTION- IN SAYS THAT
CDCR FAILED TO MEET THE
REHABILITATIVE NEEDS OF OVER
HALF OF THE PEOPLE RELEASED.
AND SO JUST WANNA. HEAR FROM
YOU WHAT IS CDC ARE GOING TO DO
TO PLAY A MORE MEANINGFUL. ARE
AN EFFECTIVE ROLE IN MAKING
SURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
AVAILABLE. ACCESSIBLE AND
ACCOUNT AND- AFFECTIVE. THANK
YOU MA'AM WHAT I WILL SAY IS
THAT WE HAVE EXPANDED THOSE
PROGRAMS AT ONE TIME WE HAD A
HARD PROCESS WHERE WE HAD TO.
MOVE THE POPULATION FROM ONE
INSTITUTION TO ANOTHER TO
RECEIVE PROGRAMMING- AND THAT
PROVED TO BE ONE DIFFICULT BUT
YOU KNOW. IT IT JUST WASN'T
APPROACH EVERYBODY AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PROGRAMMING AND
SO THANKS TO THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE WE HAVE
RECEIVED THE FUNDING NECESSARY
TO PROVIDE THESE PROGRAMS WE
HAVE HERE IS PROGRAMS AT ALL OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS TO INCLUDE A
COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR THERAPY- OUR
INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT THROUGHOUT
THE THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM WHICH
IS ANOTHER KEY COMPONENT- FOR
THE SUCCESS OF. A LARGE
MAJORITY OF OUR POPULATION
SUFFER FROM SOME SUBSTANCE
ABUSE OR ANOTHER WE OFFER
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION- AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT COME IN AND PROVIDE
VARIOUS PROGRAM WITHIN OUR
FACILITIES SO WE HAVE THOSE
FORTUNATELY ALL OF OUR
FACILITIES CURRENTLY TODAY WE
HAVE FACE TO FACE COLLEGES
EVERY SINGLE FACILITY IN THE
STATE. THAT IS A TWO YEAR
COLLEGE THANKS TO LEGISLATION
THAT WAS PASSED AND- FORD'S THE
POPULATION OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTEND- AND IN ADDITION TO THAT
WE HAVE A BALLOT FORTY FIVE
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE A FOUR
YEAR- FACE TO FACE COLLEGE
PROGRAM LANCASTER STATE PRISON
BEING ONE OF THEM. R. J. D. B.
IN ANOTHER- STORE WHAT YOU KNOW
AND WE'RE ALSO HOLD AND WE VERY.
AS PAL ARE REUNIONS TO THE
FEDERAL GRANT WHICH IS READ-
ACTIVATED THIS TWENTY TWENTY.
THE FEDERAL GRANTS BE SPREAD-
YOU LOOKING FOR TO FURTHER
EXPAND OF THE FOR YOU CALL
SHOPPER. THE YOU THINK SO- SHE
BE CAN CONTRA. I IN FAMILY
COMMUNITY I WILL IN LEAD
COMMUNICATION. SO BECAUSE OF
OUR COMMITMENT TO LEGAL
COMMUNICATION WE HAVE- WE JUST
RECENTLY- COMPLETED A CONTRACT-
FOR FURTHER EXPANSION OF OUR
FAMILY COMMUNICATION EFFORTS
WHICH AND THAT INCLUDES- PHONE
CALL. WHAT THE LOWER PHONE
RATES IN THE NAY. COUPLE AN BE
SPENT WHEN I SAY THE RATE IN
THE NAY. OUR RATES WENT FROM
SEVEN POINT SIX CENTS A MINUTE
TO TWO POINT FIVE CENTS PER
MINUTE SO AN AVERAGE FIFTEEN
MINUTE CALL IS A THIRTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE CENTS- WITH THAT
CONTRACT WE WERE ABLE TO
SOLICIT ARE WERE ABLE TO
OBTAIN. TWO FREE PHONE CALLS
AMONG FOR THE POPULATION THAT
STARTED IN THE PANDEMIC I WILL
GO THROUGHOUT THE REMAINDER OF
THIS CONTRACT- IN ADDITION TO
THAT WE WILL HAVE VIDEO
COMMUNICATION AS IT RELATES TO
EMAIL. VIDEO GRABS- EVERY
SINGLE. PERSON IN THE
POPULATION WILL RECEIVE A
CHALLENGE THROUGH THIS AND THEN
THE SERVICES- ON THOSE TABLETS
THE YOU DON'T NEED TO BE PAID
FOR SO FOR EXAMPLE A VIDEO CALL
WE DO GET THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR VIDEO CALL- WHICH WE HOPE
TO HAVE YOU KNOW. IN THE END
IT'S GOING TO BE A PHASED
APPROACH JUST BECAUSE OF THAT-
LINES THE- COMPUTER LINES THAT
HAVE TO BE DROPPED- FOR THE
TABLET. WHEN YOU MEAN WHEN YOU
SAY PHASED MEAN FACE BASED.
PERSON DEEMING PHASE BASED LOW.
OR DO. THANK YOU I'M SORRY I'M
I'M A TEACHER PERSON GOT TO BE
WITH ME YEAH THIS IS LOOKING
QUESTIONS- ANYWAY- WE HAVE TO
DROP LINES FOR ACCESS TO ANY.
OF A TECH. SO WE TO DRUM A DRAW.
LINES FOR THE COMPUTER SO
THERE'S A- AT THE TOP THAT BUT
SHE- OF FOR THEIR DUTY CALL.
AND SO- AND THEY WILL HAVE. I'M
SORRY GETTING CAN CHIU BECAUSE
WE ALSO HAVE TABLETS FOR THE
POPULATION TO RETAIN COLLAGEN
WIFI EFFORTS THERE SO I DON'T
WANT TO CONFUSE IT TO EFFORTS-
ANYWAY WE HAVE WE DO HAVE A
PHASED APPROACH AS IT RELATES
TO. INITIAL IN THE PHONE CALLS
WE'VE ALWAYS HAD THE PHONES ARE
FACT. IS BEING IMPLEMENTED NOW.
WE HAVE THE- THE TABLETS THAT
ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED NOW
THROUGH DECEMBER IT JUST
DEPENDS UPON THE PHYSICAL PLANT
STRUCTURE. OF THE FACILITY AND
I'LL USE AN EXAMPLE-
INSTITUTIONAL IS NEW LOW SAY
LAW. ONE YEARS ONE THAT'S HIGH
FIFTY YEARS ALL SHE DECENT. HOW
YOU THE LAW TO THE CAN. FOR THE
TECHNOLOGY I'M HOPING SAY THAT
CORRECTLY- BUT THAT. THAT IS
HOW I DO BELIEVE THAT LEAVES.
IS THE BEST METHOD GOING
FORWARD. WELL AS WE KNOW- PHONE
ARE STILL BEING IN THE PER. AND
SOME OF THE FOLKS WHO ARE
SMUGGLING THEM IN ALSO HAPPEN
TO BE PEOPLE WHO WORK THERE WE
KNOW THIS IS TRUE. YES AND WE
KNOW THAT PROHIBITION. DOESN'T
FIX PROBLEMS WE THAT WE HAVE
HISTORY- DID TO GIVE US THAT-
AND SO I BELIEVE THAT IF YOU.
CAN GIVE SOMEONE TABLETS YOU
CAN GIVE SOMEONE PHONES BECAUSE
THEY'RE STILL THEY- PEOPLE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THEIR FAMILIES PEOPLE ARE NOT
WE DON'T HAVE FAMILIES THAT
LIVE IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
WHERE THEY ARE BEING HOUSED-
AND IT WILL DRASTICALLY
ALLEVIATE- THE ISSUES AROUND
CONTRABAND CONFISCATION IN
EVERY SINGLE I MEAN YOU POP OUT
OF A WALL NOWADAYS AND SOMEONE
IS GIVING YOU A FINAL. SO I-
THINK WE JUST HAVE TO LIVE IN
REALITY WHEN WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT. TECHNOLOGY AND DEVICES
AND HOW PEOPLE COMMUNICATE AND
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
THERE'S CURRENCY AN ECONOMY
THAT IS HAPPENING IN OUR
PRISONS. AND USING THAT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- RESTRICT OR TO
VIOLATE OR TO- CONTINUE TO
PUNISH IS NOT HOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE THROUGH THIS WE JUST
HAVE TO BE REALISTIC ABOUT THE
FACT THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING
IN PRISON ARE STILL NEEDING TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR LOVED
ONES. I HAD ANOTHER QUESTION
ABOUT FOLKS WHO ARE WORKING-
INCARCERATED FOLKS WORKING- AND
THE WAGES THAT THEY EARN. AND
WANT TO KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT- THERE ARE NONE OF THERE'S
A NATIONWIDE DISCUSSION AROUND.
SLAVE LABOR HAPPENING IN THE
PRISONS. AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SOME VENDORS WHO
CONTRACT WITH THE PRISONS AND
YOU KNOW HIRE FOLKS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED TO DO THE WORK IN
PRESENT. THOSE SAME COMPANIES.
WILL NOT HIRE THEM WHEN THEY
GET OUT. WHICH I THINK IS.
IRONIC TO SAY THE LEAST. BUT
THEY CERTAINLY WANT TO GET THE
LABOR OF THE PERSON WHILE
THEY'RE INCARCERATED BECAUSE
THE WAGES ARE SO LOW SO I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS ON-
THIS POPULATION THAT'S WORKING
FOR THESE- YOU KNOW DE MINIMUS
WAGES- AND WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS
ARE ON THAT BECAUSE THIS IS A
GOOD DISCUSSION THAT'S
HAPPENING AROUND THE COUNTRY-
AND ASKING US TO RECONCILE.
THIS VERY GROSS INEQUITY. THANK
YOU MA'AM I WILL SAY OUR JOINT
VENTURE PROGRAMS I THINK IS
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AS
RELATES TO. WHAT IF WITHIN THE
FACILITY- THOSE OFFER MINIMUM
WAGE ARE THOSE PROGRAMS NOW I
HAVE NOT HEARD THAT WE HAD
DIFFICULTY WITH THEM. SECURING
EMPLOYMENT IN THE COMMUNITY-
ACTUALLY. I LIKE TO USE THE
LAST MILE FOR EXAMPLE HE AYE I
KNOW THAT THAT PROGRAM OFFERS.
SEVERAL OFFENDERS
OPPORTUNITIES- AND I KNOW WE
HAVE VARIOUS JOINT VENTURE
PROGRAMS AROUND THE STATE- OF
THE BILLS DO OFFER A MINIMUM
WAGE WHERE THEY HAVE THEY HAVE
TO PAY RESTITUTION AND CERTAIN
THINGS COME OUT OF THAT I DON'T
KNOW THE DETAILS BUT HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ALL THAT COMES OUT OF
BATCH- BUT THAT'S SPECIFIC TO
JOINT VENTURE PROGRAMS. IN
ADDITION WE DO HAVE- AS YOU NO
FIRE FIREFIGHTERS AS WELL AS
WORKERS THAT THAT HAVE JOBS
WITHIN THE FACILITY H. AND I AM
CERTAINLY- SUPPORTED WITH ANY
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES. TO THAT
THROUGH THAT PROCESS. WHAT
EIGHT- SIMILAR TO MR BY I'M
GONNA ASK THAT I GET A CA FROM
TO LOOK THE OF WITH YOU'RE CON.
WITH BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
SHOULD BE- CON. WITH A COME.
THAT WILL HIRE FOLKS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED FOR THOSE WAGES
AND THEY STILL HAVE A POLICIES
THAT EXPRESSLY FORBID THEM FROM
HIRING THEM WHEN THEY GET OUT.
SHAME ON EVERYONE SHANGHAI
SHAME SHAME. YES. I'M SO. HAVE
BEEN FOUND- THROUGH A NUMBER OF
STUDIES TO BE A VERY-
ALGORITHMIC TOOL ARM WITH THAT
SORT OF. SOME VERY- GROSS
OUTCOMES AS IT RELATES TO-
DISPARITIES THROUGH ITS THE
ASSESSMENTS RACIAL DISPARITIES-
AND YET CDCR BEEN USING IT FOR
A REALLY LONG TIME I THINK I
HEARD SOMEONE SAY THAT YOU ALL
ARE NO. YOU DISCONTINUE THAT
CONTRACT OR THE CONTRACT- HAS
ENDED I THINK I COULD BE WRONG
BUT- I WANT TO KNOW ABOUT
COMPASS. THANK YOU MA'AM WHEN
YOU SHARE THAT WITH ME EARLIER
TODAY I HAD STAFF FEVERISHLY
TRYING TO. LOOK INTO THAT ISSUE
I HAD NEVER HEARD THAT BEFORE
SHE AND IF THAT IS THE CASE
THAT IS APPALLING I DO KNOW
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY.
RESEARCHING OTHER OPTIONS AND I
KNOW THAT WE WERE GOING TO A
BIG PROCESS. FOR OTHER OTHER
POTENTIAL OPTIONS I DO NOT.
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO DETERMINE
EXACTLY WHERE ABSENCE SINCE OUR
EARLIER CALL TO DAMAGE BUT
AGAIN THAT'S SOMETHING I CAN
MEET YOU BOTH PROVIDING YOU AN
UPDATED STATUS OR WE ARE. FOR-
UPDATING CONTRACT THERE WAS IN
JUNE IS A RED NEEDS. AND ONE OF
THE PROBLEMS WITH IT IS IT IS
STAFF. SO INSTEAD I JUST. RISK
POINTS. EACH AND- IT IS NOT
DYNAMIC BACK YOU WILL. OTHER
FACT. OF SOME- POLICY CONDO
ANOTHER OTHER THINGS IT DOESN'T
THOSE IN ACCOUNT THAT I AWARE
OF. IT DOES TAKE A ACCOUNT AGE
BUT- THE BIGGEST. WHEN SOMEBODY
SOMEWHERE ON THE DRAW. ON THE
REAL- ASSESSMENT PIECE OF IT SO
I I'M VERY. INTERESTED IN ACT
WHAT AT AND JUST. KEEP THAT WE-
THAT I APPRECIATE THAT GREAT-
MY AND I'M VERY ME I HAVE A FEW
MORE. YOU- MENTIONED. ARM WELL
SO I HAPPEN TO GO ON THE TOUR
TO NORWAY WITH A NO OF- STAFF
AND FOLKS FROM LEADERSHIP IN
CDC ARE- AND DURING THE CALL OF
THAT TRIP WE ARE TALK ABOUT-
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND WILL BE
OF THOSE THAT WERE IN THE PER.
AND IMPORTANT- AND LEARNED
ABOUT THE HIGH RATES OF
SUICIDE- THE ONES FOLKS RETIRED
THEIR LIFE IS PERFECT AND SEE
IS JUST THREE OR FOUR YEARS-
BEYOND THEIR RETIREMENT- WE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN THE HOMES AND
ALCOHOLISM HIGH RATES OF
ALCOHOLISM IF TONIGHT WAS A FOR
A FOUR PACK OR A SIX PACK
NIGHT- VERY CONCERNING- AND
WHILE EA PEAS ARE GREAT- YOU
KNOW I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT
THERE SHOULD BE SOME MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT. SUPPORTS BETTER
REQUIRED OF OUR STAFF IT'S VERY
SIMILAR TO BEING A THERAPIST A
FAIR PASSED HAS A THERAPIST. TO
HELP THEM DEAL WITH THE WORK
THAT THEY'RE DOING- COUPLED
WITH THAT THE VERY LOW
THRESHOLD- FOR HIRING WE TALKED
ABOUT THAT A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA AND BEING TWENTY OR
TWENTY ONE- IN BEING ABLE TO
WORK IN ONE OF THESE FACILITIES
HIGH STRESS. HIGH DEMAND. I'M
AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
MORE ABOUT YOUR PLAN FOR HOW WE
ARE. BECAUSE SAYING THAT THEIR
HARD JOBS TO FILL AFTER A WHILE
ISN'T ENOUGH IF WE STILL NEED
PEOPLE IN THOSE POSITIONS WE
NEED PEOPLE IN THOSE POSITIONS
SO WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT YOUR
COMMITMENT IS TO MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE HAVING  SAFE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THOSE THAT ARE
WORKING THERE. BUT AND ALSO
ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE'RE
PROVIDING THE KIND OF TRAINING
AND SUPPORT AND MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS THAT ARE REQUIRED TO
DO THIS KIND OF WORK. THANK YOU
MA'AM AND I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AGREE WITH YOU I WILL TELL YOU
WHEN I WAS. THE DIRECTOR OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS ARE THEN
EMPLOYEE WELLNESS PERSON CAME
INTO MY OFFICE AND SHE WAS VERY
PROUD. OF HER NEW PRODUCT- WHAT
HER RECOMMENDATIONS WERE FOR
EMPLOYEE HEALTH. AND SHE WAS
FOCUSING ON. THE CANTEEN WHAT
WAS AVAILABLE IN THE SNACK BAR
AND THE VENDING MACHINES. AND
SHE WANTED SHE WAS ALL PRIVATE
SHE'S GONNA MAKE SURE THAT
BATES SALLINS. HAMBURGERS AND I
KINDA LOST BY MY. AND I SAID.
HOLD ON A MINUTE I'M NOT SIT
HERE REGULAR WAS SOMEBODY EATS
WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IS
BALCO IS TO MASTER ALL ABOUT BY
AND I SEE EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
WHENEVER WE GET NOTIFIED OF
STAFF TO GET A REST FOR. YOU
ALL RIGHT OR THEY GET ARRESTED
FOR DRUG FONG WE NEED TO FOLLOW
ON IN ON. I WILL SAY WE'VE COME
A LONG WAY WITH HER FOR A WHILE
AFTER. WE NOW HAVE AN ALBUM
JHELUM FOR ALL STAFF THEY CAN
PRIVATE DOWN THE- TO GET FIRST
RATE. OR SUPPORT- SUPERSTAR
SUPPORT FOR SOME OF AND THEY
CAN BE IN A PRO. WITH OTHER
FIRST RESPONSE- IT HAS A
VARIETY OF THAT AS LIKE. AND WE
ALSO HAVE ON STAFF WHO LEADS UP
OR ONE IS THE SHE ANSWERS. AS
WE SHOULD WANT JOB- WE THERE'S
A C. CAMPAIGN CITY THAT ARE NOT
RICHARD WE DEPLOY AT OF. ARE TO
GO OUT TO THOSE INSTEAD WITH.
ON SUPPORTS. OFTEN TELL THEIR
MEDICAL. ON HEALTH. APPEAR
OFFICE. WHO WHO ARE. THE TRIM
FONG OF BEING A- THEY'VE BEEN
ASSAULTED DIPPED TALKED THROUGH
THAT- AND REALLY BE THERE A
SUPPORT PERSON FOR IF THEY NEED
SOMEONE TO CALL. WHEN THEY'RE
HAVING ROUGH NIGHT OF HOW A
ROUGH SOMEONE TO TALK TO YOU I
THINK WE NED YOU MORE
ABSOLUTELY I DO. AT BECAUSE YOU
YOUR WE STUFF. YOU KNOW. STAFFS
THAT THE HI AFTER AFTER WE TALK-
SURE SOME YOU KNOW DIE I
LITERALLY OPENED UP MY EMAIL
DAY I SAT. IT WAS JUST A NOW
SYSTEM WHO JUST RETIRED. WHO
PASSED A IN AN MARCH I WAS LIKE
OH MY GOD. IT JUST BLEW. YOU
KNOW WE WERE. TO ONE. I MEAN I
DO I MEAN AND THAT PERSON WAS
NOT USED BUT IT'S NOT HER
MOTHER ANY BY LOS AT WORK THERE
IS LIFE. ASSAULTS ARE REAL WE
KNOW THAT PRISON RAPE IS
HAPPENING- AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT- AND I DON'T WANT TO
CONFLATE THE TWO BUT I AM- AS
CONCERNED ABOUT- WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH FOLKS THAT WORK
IN THE PRISONS AS I AM ABOUT
FOLKS THAT LIVE IN THE PRESENT.
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT OUR TRANS
COMMUNITY THE TRANSOM PLEASE
THAT ARE WORKING IN OUR PRISONS
AND THE TRANSIT INCARCERATED
FOLKS AND WHAT BECAUSE I KNOW
WE PASSED THE LAW AND I KNOW
WHAT CDCR SAYS IN THE MISSION-
AND THEN I KNOW HOW PEOPLE ARE
TREATED. SHE AND I WANT TO HEAR
FROM YOU WHAT THE COMMITMENT IS
TO PROTECT. BECAUSE WE CAN WE
CANNOT ALLOW FOR THESE THINGS
TO HAPPEN FOR DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES AGAINST OUR TRANS
COMMUNITY BUT ALSO AND FOR
RAPES TO CONTINUE TO BE
HAPPENING IN OUR PRISONS ACROSS
THE STATE AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S THAT THE FEDERAL
SCREENING I KNOW ABOUT THAT I
THINK IT'S THE PRE OP. AND I
KNOW THAT THESE THINGS ARE
STILL HAPPENING- AND SO. I
THINK I NEED TO HEAR FROM YOU
WHAT THE COMMITMENT IS FROM CDC
ARE ON BOTH OF THESE FRONTS.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THEM TOGETHER
THEIR SEPARATE. AND I AND I
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE NOW
AND UNFORTUNATELY- I THINK THE
DATA SHOWS THAT THE TRANS
GENDER POPULATION- HAS BEEN
HIGHER RISK FOR OPREA ISSUE.
ARE. AND I WILL SAY THAT WE
IMPLEMENTED THE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES BUT MANY OTHER
STATES DID. WE DID TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WE IMPLEMENTED THE
FEDERAL GUIDELINES. WE ARE
OBSERVED BY OTHERS SO WE GET
AUDITED ON EVERY THREE YEARS SO
IT'S A PROCESS WHERE EVERY
THREE YEARS AND- WE GET AUDITED
ME DO SO MANY INSTITUTIONS IN
HERE IN ORDER TO TAKE TO GET
THEM ALL DONE- AND THOSE ARE
INDEPENDENT AUDITORS FROM
AROUND THE NATION. I WILL SAY
THAT- AS WE JUST RECENTLY
IMPLEMENTED- SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY TWO. OUR GENEROUS BACKED
AGENCY IN DIGNITY ACT THAT WAS
SIGNED BY OUR GOVERNOR NEWSOM
ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE'RE STILL IN THE PROCESS
OF IMPLEMENTING THAT WE HAVE
RECEIVED TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN TRANSGENDER WOMEN A
REQUEST FOR TRANSFER WE
RECEIVED TWENTY SEVEN NON
BINARY- INMATE- REVIEW REQUEST.
WE HAVE TRANSFERRED A TOTAL OF
SEVEN TRANSGENDER FEMALES FROM
MALE INSTITUTION TO A FEMALE
INSTITUTION AND THERE ARE
SEVERAL SCHEDULED FOR TRANSFER
I THINK NEXT WEEK A BARBER
CONFLICT IN THE NINETEEN- AND
SO IT'S A PROCESS WHEN THEY
HAVE TO APPLY. THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH- COMMITTEE AT THE LOCAL
INSTITUTION LOCAL INSTITUTION
MAKES A RECOMMENDATION WE ARE
PRIORITIZING AB ARE TRANS
GENDER HOLDEN SITUATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN. HOUSE FOR MANY
YEARS- WE'RE PRIORITIZING NOT
POPULATION FOR THOSE WHO TO GET
THE FIRST COMMITTEES- THEY
LIVED IN OUR COMMUNITIES AS
TRANSGENDER SOME FOR YOU KNOW
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS AND SO
TRYING TO FOR THEM THAT
OPPORTUNITY FIRST- AND THEN WE
AS FAR AS TRAINING BECAUSE I DO
THINK TRAINING IS A KEY
COMPONENT. SO THAT EVERYBODY'S
TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT THEN IT TAKES TIME YOUR
TRANSGENDER HUBS TO SOMEBODY
WHO HAD A TRANSGENDER UP WHEN I
WAS WORKING. I KNEW THAT I HAD
TO BE OUT ON OF IT TO TRAIN
STAFF TO BE RESPECTFUL AND TO A
FOR THE POPULATION THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS AS ANYBODY.
ELSE- SO WE HAVE. WITH THE
TRANSGENDER CULTURAL INFLUENCE-
TRANSGENDERS ARE CENTER OF NEW
MEXICO- TO SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS
WE ALSO HAVE IN STATE EXPERTS
THAT- WE CONSULT WITH- WE ARE
WORKING ON A TRAINING FOR ALL
OF OUR INSTITUTIONS STAFF.
THROUGH A GENTLEMAN BY THE NAME
OF- ADRIAN LAWYER WHO HIMSELF
IS A TRANS GENDER MALE WHO
UNDERSTANDS THE POPULATIONS AND
THE NEEDS- FOR THE POPULATION.
WE ALSO HAVE- CLASSES FOR THE
POPULATION THEMSELVES IT'S
CALLED THE RIGHT PERSON RIGHT
MISSION- THIS IS MANAGED BY A
FEMALE OFFENDERS AND
SPECIALIZED HOUSING ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR TO ASSIST WITH THE
TRANSITION FROM LIVING IN A
MALE INSTITUTION AND TO LIVING
IN A FEMALE INSTITUTION AND
VICE VERSA. IT IS A TWO HOUR
CLASS DURING A FOUR WEEK
SESSION SO WE'RE STILL IN THE
INFANCY STAGES OF THAT BUT
DEFINITELY ALL HAS TO BE PART
OF THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION AND SAFETY FOR
ALL BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT WE
HAVE TO PROTECT. EVERYBODY ARM
SO IT'S VERY THOUGHTFUL
DECISIONS AS WE AS WE CONTINUE
TO IMPLEMENT THIS PROCESS AND
DEFINITELY- COMMITTED TO MAKING
SURE THAT IT IS SUCCESSFUL.
WELL CAN I COUNT ON YOUR-
COMMITMENT TO. FOLLOW UP WITH
ME ON ON THIS ISSUE AND ALSO ON
THE ISSUES AROUND- PRISON RAPE
AND HAVE WHAT IS BEING DONE TO-
ELIMINATE OR- DECREASE THOSE
NUMBERS- AND THEN ALSO ON
HOWARD FORD- WHO NOW HAS NO
LEGS AT LANCASTER. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU FOR SHARING HIS
INSTITUTION ON BUT I HAVE STAFF
SEARCH WE DID HAVE SEVERAL
HOWARD FORTS. HOW ANYWAY SO
YEAH I APPRECIATE KIDS I'M SURE
I CAN FIND HIM NOW THEY KNOW
EXACTLY AS YOU'D SEASON YES
ALLEN CASTOR SEVENTY SEVEN BEEN
THERE FOR FORTY YEARS PLUS.
AMPLUG DOUBLE AMPUTEE. WHEN I
HEARD. ABOUT YOUR WEIGHT YEAH
AS- I'M SURE YOU KNOW MEDICALLY
I CAN'T KNOW ALL THE DETAILS
BUT- YEAH I WILL DEFINITELY TO.
WITH OUR UNDER SECRETARY OF
HEALTHCARE EACH AND SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO TO EVALUATE THIS CASE
AND WE WILL DEFINITELY GET BACK
TO YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH I AM.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME I KNOW
WHY IT ASKED A LOT OF QUESTIONS
AND I AM- GRATEFUL THAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE INDULGED ME IN
THIS TIME WITH YOU- I AM TELL
I'M ASKING YOU THESE QUESTIONS
BECAUSE I I'M LETTING YOU KNOW
THAT I'M I'M GOING TO BE IN
YOUR BUSINESS ABOUT THESE
ISSUES. I'M GONNA BE IN YOUR
BUSINESS- THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME. AND SO I'M I'M
SAYING IT ON THE RECORD- AND I
HOPE THAT WHEN PEOPLE CALL IN
IN SUPPORT FOR YOU IT IS MORE
THAN JUST THE TWO FORMAL
LETTERS THAT WE RECEIVED FROM
PROBATION AND FROM SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT I HOPE THERE ARE
OTHER FOLKS THAT CALL IN THAT
SAY- WE ARE ALSO GOING TO BE IN
THE BUSINESS. OF MISS ALLISON
BECAUSE WE WANT HER TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. SO THANK YOU FOR
THIS TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR LET ME TURN TO THE VICE
CHAIR WOMAN- AND ASK SENATOR
BATES WHO SHE WOULD LIKE TO GO
NEXT. THANK YOU ARM THEM CHAIR
IAN THANK YOU MISS SELFRIDGE
SECRETARY ALLISON FOR YOUR VERY
IN DEPTH RESPONSE TO MANY MANY
QUESTIONS SANDRA WE DID HAVE
THOUGH I THINK I WAS VERY VERY
COMPREHENSIVE FIVE DISCUSSION
ONE ON ONE AND NOT THE OTHER
DAY I'M VERY IMPRESSED WITH
YOUR RESUME. I AND I MENTIONED
I DIDN'T MEAN TO DEMEAN YOUR
ROLE. IN THE MEDICAL PROFESSION
THAT I SAID TO A SECRETARIAL
THING YOU STARTED IN THE MAIL
ROOM I GOT ALL THE WAY TO THE
TOP AND THAT'S PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT. BUT I DON'T I
DIDN'T MEAN TO DO ME AND I'LL
FOLLOW NOT AT ALL THE SO I
THINK WE HAD A CHUCKLE OVER
THAT SO THAT WAS GREAT BETTER.
I HAVE TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT-
I BELIEVE THAT YOU ARE SO VERY
VERY QUALIFIED FOR THIS
POSITION YOU'VE MADE A NUMBER
OF COMMITMENTS TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE. ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES-
BUT I DO THINK THAT THE MANNER
IN WHICH- THE VERY LATE NOTICE
OF THE CLOSURE. OF THE
SUSANVILLE PRISON AND MORE ARE
AS IMPORTANT COOLEY- THE FIRE-
CAMPED THERE HAS MADE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT. OF HERE AND
I'M NOT A POSITIVE WAY
REGARDING THE MANNER IN WHICH
THESE THINGS TAKE PLACE AND
WHAT HAPPENS TO OUR LEGISLATORS
TO REPRESENT THOSE AREAS AND
WHAT WE CONTEND WITH. ALL WHEN
WE GET CALLS ABOUT WHY DID THEY
DO IT WHAT'S THE DATA WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN TO ME ON AND ON
AND ON. SO I'M GOING TO ASK YOU
BECAUSE TODAY I AM GOING TO
ABSTAIN. BUT WITH THE FULL
INTENTION BECAUSE I THINK ALL
OF THE CANDIDATES UP TODAY HAVE
ARE SIGNIFICANT RESUMES THAT
NEED TO BE SUPPORTED. BUT I
WANT TO HAVE IN WRITING THE
PLAN AND WHAT YOU SHARED IN
TERMS YOUR COMMITMENT THAT
WOULD BE ABOUT A TWO PAGER WITH
BULLET FIVE BELIEVE. THAT WE
WILL HAVE GOING FORWARD MANNER
IN WHICH IS AN ECONOMIC IMPACT
THAT'S GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTED
LANDERS CLOSURES AND LET LET ME
JUMP TO THE CLOSURE SIDE. WITH
A MEMBER OF THE CDC WE ARE
THERE IS A COME. THAT I WAS A
POOR TO BY THE GOVERNOR. FOR
TWO THOUSAND. WHEN I WAS ON THE
BOARD SUPERVISORS. AND THAT'S
WHEN THE ISSUE OF PRISON OVER.
WAS VERY VERY MUCH IN THE NEWS
AND WE HAVE THE FEDERAL.
MANDATE TO REDUCE- ISN'T
POPULATION AT THAT TIME THERE
WAS BUDGET. OF ALLOCATION FOR A
BUILDING PRISONS ANDWE'VE GONE
THE OTHER WAY BECAUSE WE'RE NOW
LOOKING AT. A CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM AND YOU KNOW THAT WE HAD
A CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT I AM
VERY VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
IT WOULD BE NICE OF THESE
FACILITIES THAT ARE BEING CLOSE
TO WOULD IN FACT- B.
REHABILITATION CENTERS WHERE
PEOPLE COULD GO FOR THOSE
SPECIAL PROGRAMS BUT THAT'S%
SOMETHING. THAT I MIGHT ASK
THOUGH THE FACILITIES- OF.
CANDIDATE THAT YOU'RE TELLING
ME THAT THERE WAS A HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND. IT'S
NOW DOWN TO NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND IN ONLY THE TO PRESENT
YOU MENTIONED. THERE'S A 45%
CAPACITY- SO THAT LEAVES A LOT
OF ROOM OUT FAILED TO ONE OF
THE FACILITIES THE 65% CAPACITY
AT THE OTHER ONE WHICH MEANS
THEY'RE STILL PROVIDING
SERVICES. AND THOSE ON THE
CLOSURE LIST SO WE HAVE NO
IDEA. WHAT'S THE STANDARDS ARE
FOR DETERMINING THAT. WE'VE
HEARD FROM YOU SOME OF THOSE
BUT I THINK WE NEED THAT IN
WRITING BECAUSE THEN. WHEN WE
ARE STANDING UP FOR YOUR
CONFIRMATION OR STANDING UP TO
SAY THAT. THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING JOB THAT YOU'VE-
YOU. YOU'LL COME BACK AND TAKE
DO YOU WANT TO RECONSIDER THAT
RIGHT AWAY. I JUST THINK THAT
IF YOU DON'T EVEN. I CAN SEE
YOU STANDING UP AND RUNNING OUT
OF THE ROOM YET SO ANYWAY I
THINK IT'S JUST IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WHEN WE DO THAT AND I'M
SPEAKING OF A LACK OF OFFICIAL
ONE I CAN SHARE WITH MY
CONSTITUENTS THE SPECIFICS OF
WHY HIGHER VOTED. WHY A PERSON
ARE I AM TOTALLY COMMITTED TO
THAT PERSON OR THAT ISSUE OR
AND I SHOW THEM THE DATA THEY
MIGHT NOT ALL AGREE AGREE WITH
ME BUT THEY HAVE TO TAKE MY
FINAL DECISION AND I DON'T DO
THAT WITHOUT PROVIDING SOME
EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE AND THAT'S
WHAT'S MISSING HERE. CANNOT
THAT YOU'RE WORTHY OF THE GOLD
HOLDEN THAT I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO COMMUNICATE THAT SO I WAS
JUST SAYING BETWEEN NOW AND
WHEN WE ARE READY TO DISCUSS
THIS- IN THE CHAMBERS I OUR
SESSION. EACH ONE OF US WILL BE
ABLE TO STAND TALL WITH THE
QUESTIONS COME OUT FOR MY
COLLEAGUES AND WE WILL HAVE
SOME OF THE DATA THAT WAS USED
TO MAKE THESE DECISIONS AND IN
PARTICULAR THAT MEANS SHARE
THAT WHEN WE'RE AT 45% 265% THE
QUESTION IS WHY THAT BLOCKED.
THE LESS YOU ACTUALLY HAVE AN
EMPTY PRISON LIKE. MY
COLLEAGUES. I FROM CURRENT
MANAGER. YEAH THAT'S THAT'S THE
WHOLE DIFFERENT THING AND IF
THERE'S AN EMPTY FOR. THERE
THAT OPENS DISCUSS ABOUT THE
OTHER NEEDS THAT WE HAVE WITH
HOME OF THE OTHER NEEDS WE HAVE
FOR REHABILITATION PROGRAMS. ON
AND ON AND ON AND THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT. ARE BECOMING
EXTREMELY EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
POLICY WISE. FOR OUR
LEGISLATION IN OUR LEGISLATURE.
SO YOU JUST HAVE MY FIVE FIVE-
VERY VERY SUPPORTIVE BUT- I TO
ME IT'S JUST A SIMPLE. REQUEST
OF YOU. AND I'M SURE THAT
KNOWING YOUR CAPABILITIES. THAT
YOU CAN POP ME SOMETHING PRETTY
QUICK ON ON THE- DIFFERENT
ISSUES THAT WERE BROUGHT UP IN
IF THERE IS. SOMETHING SPECIFIC
IN TERMS OF A- STANDARD THAT IS
USED FOR ECONOMIC IMPACT. THAT
SOMETHING THAT PERHAPS NEEDS TO
BE DEVELOPED BECAUSE I THINK
WILL BE VERY CONVINCING. THAT
WE NEED TO GO THIS WAY AND NOT
THAT WAY BUT WHEN YOU'RE
LEAVING A TOWN- SHORT OF A
THOUSAND JOBS. AND YOU WANT ME
TO SAY THAT'S OKAY THAT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT UNLESS I KNOW
WHAT. IS HAPPENING TO THOSE
THOUSAND JOBS WHAT'S GOING TO
REPLACE THEM. AND WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO THE PEOPLE IN THAT
TOWN. IN TERMS OF JOB
OPPORTUNITIES SO. THAT'S WHERE
I AM BUT I DO. HAVE I THOUGHT
YOU DID AN EXCELLENT JOB IN ON
MANY OF THE POINTS WE
DISCUSSED. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR. OUR COLLEAGUES
HERE IF THEY DIDN'T DISCUSS IT
ABOUT THE EDT FAILURES AND- HOW
YOU HAVE NOW WORKED WITH EDIE
D. TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS. A
CONVERSATION THAT GOES BACK AND
FORTH. BASICALLY IT'S GOING TO
BE ON. THE DATA TO SO THAT THEY
WILL HAVE KNOWLEDGE EIGHTY
DVDS- THAT. APPLICATIONS ARE
FOR PEOPLE NOT ELIGIBLE WHO ARE
STILL. INCARCERATED THE FUTURE
THAT BRIEFLY AND THEN LIKE I
SAID. YOU HAVE MY FIVE FIVE BUT
TO I GOTTA WAIT A FEW DAYS. OF.
FOR A LITTLE MORE INFORMATION
TO COME MY WAY. THANK YOU MATH
I WILL SAY THAT ARE FULL.
CURBSIDE IS A EIGHTY PER. OF
OUR CAPACITY- 81% OF OUR OVER A
THREE JUDGE PANEL PASSED AT ONE
THIRTY FIVE AND SO OUR OVERALL
NUMBERS SO MANY OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS ARE WELL BELOW
ARE- WHAT ARE BUILT CAPACITY SO
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT'S
HIGHLIGHTED SO CASH THE
POPULATION THAT IS NOT THE
EXACT SUSAN BELL. AS WELL AS-
GOES TO SECURE LEVEL ONE
FACILITIES- IS EASY EASILY
ABSORBED INTO OUR NUMEROUS
VACANCIES AROUND THE STATE. I
WILL SAY THAT- EDG FRAUD IS A
PROBLEM. WE HAVE WORKED WE- ARE
OFFICE OF CORRECTIONAL SAFETY
IS PARTNERED WEST OF THE D.
A.'S ON WE HAVE NUMEROUS STAFF
ASSIGNED TO THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS AS WELL AS
INSTITUTIONAL STAFF ASSIGNED TO
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS. WE EARLY
ON SIGNED A DATA SHARING
AGREEMENT WITH YOU DO YOU DO
YOU TO BE ABLE TO FACILITATE-
SHARING OF INFORMATION TO
PREVENT FROM ACROSS. THE EFFORT
FINAL COMMENT IS ON THE A
NUMBER OF FOLKS- WHO ARE
AVAILABLE FOR FIGHTING FIRES
AND THE TRAINING THAT GOES ON-
HASN'T BEEN ANY CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW TO REPLACE THEM
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE- ON. YOU
KNOW YEAH I CAN RIGHT IN FRONT
OF ALL THE WILD LAND FIRE
SEASON AND JUST COMMITTED. FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
EFFORTS IN THAT AREA. ALL OF
THE CURRENT FIRE CAMPS WILL
REMAIN OPEN OKAY. THERE ARE
SOME BIG MISUNDERSTANDING YEAH
GOOD THEN I PUT THAT ON YOUR
LITTLE NOTE BACK TO ME AND I'M
GOOD. THANK YOU MA'AM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR- CENTER LAYER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND- THERE IS SOME ADVANTAGE TO
GOING TO THIS PLACE IN THE
ORDER. OF IT I KNOW I DID IT TO
ALL OF YOU WITH THE PARKS
DIRECTOR LAST WEEK AND IT WAS A
KARMIC REPAYMENT TODAY SO IT IS
GREAT A. N. IT JUST TO
ACKNOWLEDGE R. A AND WE'RE
GOING TO TALK IN THE NEXT OUR
SESSION WITH THE NEXT THREE.
OCCUR ABOUT FIRE CAMPS- BECAUSE
I HAD THAT DISCUSSION ABOUT-
TODAY WITH THEM AND IF THE
ISSUE IS AS MUCH. NOT JUST AT
ALL THIRTY FIVE FIRE CAMPS- ARE
STAYING OPEN UNDER REALIGNMENT.
WITH THE ARE WHATEVER YOU CALL
IT OF THE LESSER OFFENDERS
MOVING BACK TO THE LOCAL LEVEL
THEY MOVED OUT OF THE ABILITY
TO COME THROUGH THE STATE
SYSTEM TO THE OF FIREFIGHTING
AND SO THE ISSUE IS NOT SO MUCH
THE FIRE CAMPS REMAINING OPEN
THAT'S THE ISSUE THAT THERE ARE
LESS PEOPLE TO GO INTO THE FIRE
CAMPS FROM THE SYSTEM. AND THAT
IS A QUESTION THAT HAS TO BE
ASKED BY AUSTIN IT AND OTHER
PIECES OF THE OF THE POLICY
DISCUSSION I APPRECIATED OUR
DISCUSSION. AND I. TO OUR
SENATOR ARE WALKED THE
SECRETARY THROUGH THE- THEIR
PROGRAMS ON ON TRANS PEOPLE AND
I ALSO NOTED THAT IT IS AN
UNUSUAL CAREER PATH TO GET TO
WHERE YOU ARE AND I THINK IT'S
BEEN NOTED BY EVERYBODY ON THE
WAY AND I THINK IT IT IS GREAT
THAT THERE IS. APAPA DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE DEAD DEAD THE GROUP
WHEN YOU ARRIVE AT THE TOP IN
THE END. AND THAT'S OUR
HELPFUL. SINCE EVERYTHING HAS
BEEN ASKED LET LET ME DO TWO
THINGS IN THE FIRST ONE IS TO
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION WE'VE
BEEN HAVING. ABOUT THE CLOSURE
BECAUSE I WAS GOING TO COME AT
IT. AND FROM A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT WAY IT'S REALLY BEEN
DRIVEN HOME AND NOT IN THE
CONVERSATION THUS FAR BUT AS
THE NUMBER THAT'S BEEN SAID WE
SAID IN OUR- CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY. GOING FROM A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND IN
THE SYSTEM TO NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND. IN EVAN EE THERE IS
GOING TO BE. OUR LESS USE OF
FACILITIES SO HOW. YOU IS HOW
DO YOU MAKE THE DECISION OVER
TIME. YOU JUST GO IT 80%
CAPACITY OF EVERY FACILITY
DECIDE YOU WANT 80% CAPACITY
FULL IN MOST FACILITIES AND
CLOSE OTHERS. WHAT IS THE
DECISION MAKING FOR DEALING
WITH THE REDUCTION UP AGAINST
THE FACILITIES THAT EXIST IN
THE SYSTEM. F. N. THIS IS JUST
GRANTING. ARE THE OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT YOU'LL RESPOND
ON THE CRITERIA FOR THE
SPECIFIC CLOSURES BUT IT SEEMS
TO ME THERE'S JUST LARGER
POLICY QUESTION- SYSTEM IS BEEN
DOWNSIZING AND POPULATION. HOW
DO YOU RESPOND WITH THE
FACILITIES. THANK YOU SIR AS
YOU NOW- SOME OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORMS WERE- CONNECT
HIM TO STABILIZE. OUR COURT
COMMITMENTS TO WHAT WE CALL THE
THREE JUDGE PANEL WE HAVE A
COURT ORDER TO MAINTAIN OUR
OVERALL STATE POPULATION A
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN POINT FIVE
PERCENT. SO SOME OF THOSE
INITIATIVES AND CHANGES WAS TO
BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
GOAL. AND SO- THAT'S WHAT
STARTED THE INITIAL PUSH AND
REALIGNMENTS ARE REALIGNMENT
WAS- COMPLETED YEAH ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE ON NINE AND TWO
THOUSAND AND ELEVEN. AND THAT
SO IT TOOK THAT SAME LOW LEVEL
OF GENDER NON SERIOUS
NONVIOLENT NON SEX OFFENDERS TO
SERVE THEIR TIME AT THE COUNTY
JAIL. OBVERSES TO STATE PRISON
AND SO THAT'S REALLY THE
BIGGEST CHANGE- THERE WERE
OTHER CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMS
TO DAHLE ALONG THE WAY BUT I
WOULD SAY WAS THE MARKET
DIFFERENCE SH AND SO AS WE GO
FORWARD. I WILL SAY THAT WE
HAVE TO PAUSE AND REEVALUATE
POST CODE. WHAT WE HAVE
DISCOVERED IS ARE OPEN DORM
SETTINGS VERSUS CELLS WITH
SOLID SOUTH CORRIDORS. IT IS
DIFFERENT. MARKET IN DIFFERENT
AND SO WE HAVE TO PAUSE IN
REIMAGINE WHAT THAT'S GOING TO
LOOK LIKE- YOU KNOW I SAY OUR
POPULATION IS AT NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND BUT WE DO HAVE. LIKE
TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS IN THE
COUNTY JAILS THAT HAS ADVERSELY
BEEN IMPACTING THE COUNTY JAILS
AND SHERIFFS HAVE BEEN VERY
VERY VOCAL ABOUT THAT
UNDERSTANDABLY SO BECAUSE WE
HAVE WE WERE CLOSE TO AND TAKE.
FOR THE MAJORITY OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. N. EXCUSE TO
JUST QUICK FOLLOW UP QUESTION
TO THAT MEAN IF THERE HADN'T
BEEN COVERT DO DEF TEN THOUSAND
MORE PEOPLE. IN THE SYSTEM
BECAUSE THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
TRANSFERRED DURING THAT PERIOD
OF TIME. YES SIR OKAY. AND MANY
HAVE BEEN RELEASED FROM THAT-
COUNTY JAILS AFTER AFTER THEIR
CREDIT IS APPLIED- WE TOOK IT
WE ASK FOR ALL THE SENTENCING
DOCUMENTS FOR EVERYBODY TWO
YEARS ALL LAST SO MANY TIMES A
POPULATIONS ACTUALLY POLLING
BIKES FROM THE COUNTY JAIL AND
I WORK WITH INDIVIDUAL SHERIFFS
ON THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS- AS IT
RELATES TO BRING AN END BASED
ON THEIR OWN OVERCROWDING
ISSUES- BUT I WILL SAY WE HAVE
TO REALLY CONSIDER WHAT ARE WE
DOING AS FAR AS- THE POPULATION
NOW ANYTHING. YOU KNOW. HOW IS
IT WE HAVE TO RESPOND TO THE
LAWS TAT ARE GIVEN OKAY- AND-
FOR EXAMPLE YOU LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE PRISON
POPULATION IN THE LATE EIGHTIES
EARLY NINETIES. THAT WAS BASED
ON LAW CHANGES THAT THINGS
CHANGED WE'RE NOW KIND OF
REVERSING SOME OF THAT WITH
REALIGNMENT SOME OF THE CREDIT
EARNING CHANGES THAT HAVE
SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGED. THE
PROPOSITION THIRTY SIX WITH THE
THIRD STRIKE LAW FOR A NON
SERIOUS NONVIOLENT. ALL OF THE
LAWS ACTUALLY IMPACT THE
POPULATION FOR HOW LONG THEY
STAY THAT COUPLED WITH- YOU
KNOW OUR BORDER PRISON-
HEARINGS AS YOU KNOW. THE RATE-
GRANTS. IT HAS IT HAS INCREASED
I MEAN THAT'S THE REALITY OF
THE LAST YOU KNOW THROUGH BUT I
THINK YOU'RE DOING A REALLY
GOOD JOB OF DESCRIBING WHAT THE
CHANGES WERE INTHE POPULATION.
AND I THINK PART OF MY QUESTION
IS HOW ARE YOU RESPONDING TO
THE CHANGES SO THAT IT IN TERMS
OF OUR FACILITIES THE AND THE
OTHER THING IS THAT THAT SORT
OF GOT NOTED BUT NOT DIRECTLY-
WITH THE- THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
KEPT IN THE COUNTY JAILS IT
MEANS THE ONES. THAT REMAIN IN
THE STATE SYSTEM MORE FOR MUCH
MORE SERIOUS OFFENSES. A. N. SO
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT CHANGES.
ARE ARE SORT OF WHAT YOUR SPACE
FOR YOUR YOUR FACILITIES NEEDS
ARE BECAUSE OF THE NATURE WHO'S
THERE. ARE MY QUESTION IS JUST
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO ADJUST
WHAT ARE YOUR POLICIES FOR JOSH
TO EVEN IF. WE HAVE A SITUATION
THAT JUST HAPPENED IN THE LAST
DAY OR TWO WHERE. NOTIFICATION
IS AN ISSUE WATER ALL THE
DECISIONS UP TO THE
NOTIFICATION THAT DECIDE WHERE
AND WHEN BECAUSE- ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE. ONE IS IN A RURAL AREA
SO IS GOING TO. OUR MEN ARE
MEMBER WHEN I WAS. SECRETARY
GOVERNMENT. I THINK IN SIERRA
COUNTY THE FORCE. OFFER AND
JUST KILLED THE COUNTY SEATS.
KANEMI ARE JUST KILLED IT IN
EVERY WAY SO. THAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN BUT I'M WONDERING WHAT
THE BECAUSE I HAVE A FEELING IF
YOU'RE TRANSPARENT WE CAN
FIGURE THIS OUT AS IT HEADS UP
TO IT WE CAN SEE THE POPULATION
CHANGES AND IF WE KNOW. IT
DOESN'T MEAN YOU'RE GOING TO
LEAVE EVERYONE OPEN AT 80%
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT EFFICIENT
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
MOVE. TO CLOSE SOME FACILITIES
WE CAN START TO LOOK AT. WHAT
THE PRIORITIES ARE AND HOW TO
DO IT AND THAT'S WHAT I WAS
JUST TRYING TO PROBE WITH YOU.
IS A LONG TERM AT THE HIGH
LEVEL HOW DO YOU DECIDE. WHAT
IT IS THAT. AND I KNOW. IT'S
ALSO ABOVE YOUR PAY GRADE
PEOPLE HELP YOU MAKE THE
DECISION. BUT IT'S LIKE THE FOR
YOUR INPUT HOW DO YOU START TO
DECIDE WHICH ONES. WHAT KINDS.
OF THINGS YOU HAVE TO SHRINK
BACK- I THINK THAT'S FAIR THAT
YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID KOBE DOES
IMPACT DORM SETTINGS VERSUS
CELL SO WE HAVE TO START THERE
IN MY OPINION. I HAVE TO WORK
WITH THE RECEIVERS OFFICE TO
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS GOING
FORWARD- IN ADDITION WE FILE.
FOLLOW THE PENAL CODE SECTIONS
AS I HIGH ALREADY HIGHLIGHTED
TO DAMAGE- ALL THOSE. ON HOW TO
PRIORITIZE FACILITIES
FORECLOSURE- AT THIS POINT IN
TIME WE HAVE NOT HAD FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS AS IT RELATES TO
ADDITIONAL CLOSURES OUTSIDE AND
AGAIN GOVERNMENT THIS YEAR AND
EIGHTY PERCENT. OF WHAT YOUR
RECEIVER CATEGORIAS IT'S CLEAR.
THAT UNLESS THERE'S SOME BIG
BURST OF ACTIVITY YOU'RE HEADED
IN A DIRECTION WHERE SOMETHING
LIKE THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AND
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO DECIDE
WHAT THE PRIORITIES ARE- THEN
LET ME TRY TO OTHER THINGS R.
ONE IS AND I DIDN'T TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THIS CLEARLY IN OUR
MEETING. BUT YOU SEE I HAD THE
MISFORTUNE BEEN BUDGET CHAIR
WHEN IT WAS THE POPULATION WAS
AT THE HEIGHT. THE A AND WHEN
IT WAS A TWO THIRDS REQUIREMENT
FOR THE BUDGET AND WE STRUGGLED
ARE WITHIN THAT TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT TO DO. AND WE ADOPTED THE
FIRST PROGRAMS FOR
REHABILITATION IN MORE MODERN
TIMES. ARE HOW WITH REGARD TO
SCHOOLING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES- AND WE STARTED
WITH THE WOMEN'S PRESENCES AYE
I RECALL WHEN WE DID THE FIRST
REHABILITATION HOW. IT HAPPENED
HOW HAVE YOU SEEN THE AFFECT
CHANGE THERE AND WHAT YOU DO IN
TERMS OF. SORT OF TRAINING AND
DIFFERENT STYLES OF
REHABILITATION WITHIN THE
SYSTEM. WELL I CHANGE OVER THE
YEARS FOR THE BETTER- YOU KNOW
WE'VE ALWAYS HAD ACADEMIC AND
VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS WITHIN OUR
FACILITIES. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
OUR CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
WHICH IS ALSO BROKE I USE AN
OLD TERM SO BEAR WITH ME- THEY
HAVE THE BALLS TO BE JOBS THAT
REQUIRE CERTAIN PAY RATE A
LIVABLE WAGE- UPON RELEASE THEY
THEY HAVE TO PARTICIPATE FOR
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME TO GET
THEIR CERTIFICATES WE'VE ADDED
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS YOU'VE
TAKEN AWAY PROGRAMS. THAT
DIDN'T- PROVIDE A LIVABLE WAGE
AND SO MAKING THOSE ADJUSTMENTS
ALONG THE WAY I THINK ARE
CRITICAL WE ALSO HAVE SOME SOME
HIGH TECH- PROGRAMS OUT THERE-
THAT TEACH COMPUTERIZED CODY
MANAGE AND WE ALSO UNDER WATER
WEALTHY YOU HAVE UNDERWATER
WELDING YOU GRADUATE YOU YOU
RELEASED TOMORROW YOU CAN
REPORT- THE NEXT DAY TO THE
DOCKS THE OF LONG BEACH AND
HAVE A JOB THAT PAYS YOU KNOW
HUNDRED DOLLARS AN HOUR. SO I
MEAN THOSE ARE OBVIOUSLY THE
EXTREME PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
BUT YOU KNOW THE ONE NUMBER ONE
REQUIREMENTS THEY HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO GET A LIVABLE WAGE WE
HAVE TO RESTORE THE POPULATION
IS AFFORD AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
BASIC ADULT EDUCATION MANY OF
OUR POPULATION ARE I'M THINKING
WHICH IS A SECOND LANGUAGE
INSERTED BREAK DOWN THOSE
BARRIERS SO NOT ONLY CAN THEY
LEARN. ON THAT THEY CAN SUCCEED
AS WELL- GO GOING FORWARD- SO I
WILL SAY I'VE SEEN IT CHANGE A
LOT YOU'RE RIGHT IT DID START-
THE FEMALE PROGRAMS AND WE HAVE
FURTHER EXPANDED WE'VE ALSO YOU
KNOW WE FOLLOW UP. PROCESS
THAT- THAT ARE. NEED TO BE
BASED AT THAT THEY TO FOR IS
CRITERIA IN ORDER TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR PROGRAMS- TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES
WITHIN OUR FACILITIES FOR SOME
OF OUR CONTRACT BASED
PROGRAMMING WHICH I WILL SAY
SOME OF THOSE OF THE RICHEST
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE. YOU KNOW
SO THOSE ARE THE COGNITIVE
BEHAVIOR THERAPY KIND OF LIFE
SKILL KIND OF BEING CREATIVE
WRITING THOSE KIND OF PROGRAMS.
ALSO BENEFIT THE POPULATION- AS
SEEN BY YOU KNOW THE- SIX AT
THE- BOARD- FOR A POTENTIAL
RELEASE OR EVEN EXCEPTIONAL
CONTACT OUT. THE REFERRALS FROM
THE SECRETARY'S OFFICE UNDER
PENAL CODE ELEVEN SEVENTY D.
THOSE- PEOPLE THAT HAVE REALLY
MADE A CHANGE IN THEIR LIVES
WERE ABLE TO PRESENT THOSE
CASES TO A COURT FOR
RECONSIDERATION OF SENTENCE.
FACE SOME PASTA PROGRAM THANK
YOU THAT THAT IS VERY HELPFUL
AND I JUST A. N. AS WE
MENTIONED THE FIRST TIME AROUND
THE LEGISLATURE I DID NOT HAVE
A- FACILITY IN MY DISTRICT I DO
THIS TIME AND SAN LUIS OBISPO
AND I'VE VISITED THERE FOR. THE
PRICE THAT THEY MAKE SHOES AND
IT WAS IMPRESSIVE AND EVERYBODY
REALLY WANTS TO GO THERE ARE
THAT THAT'S INSIDE TOWARD TO
WORK THERE SAW IT WAS AN
IMPRESSIVE HOME PROGRAM. LASTLY
JUST SOMETHING I ASKED YOU. IN
THE MEETING BUT- JUST TO LET
YOU COMMENT ON IT IN PUBLIC. I
HAD A RATHER STRANGE EXPERIENCE
WITHOUT WHEN I WAS WORKING MY
WAY TO BUDGET CHAIRED THE FIRST
YEAR IT WAS THE TIME OF THE
RECALL AND GOVERNOR SORTS AND I
AGREE. AND WE- HEARINGS RIGHT
AWAY. ON THE PRISON SYSTEM AND
WE WERE SIX MONTHS INTO THE
BUDGET YEAR. AND THE SYSTEM
NEVER ENTERED. WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR HAD
APPROVED SIX MONTHS BEFORE THEY
WERE OVER SPENDING BY SOMETHING
LIKE A BILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T EVEN ENTER IT IN
THEIR BOOKS. WHAT HAD BEEN
APPROVED FOR THE BUDGET THAT
YEAR. ARM JUST ASSURE ME HOW
DIFFERENT IT IS THESE DAYS
WITHIN YOUR SYSTEM. OH BOY IT'S
DIFFERENT I WILL SAY I'M VERY
PROUD OF OUR BUDGET SHOP WE
HAVE A SOLID BUDGET SHOP- AND
WE HAVE SEVERAL MEMBERS THAT
USED TO WORK FOR DEPARTMENT
FINANCE THEY KEEP US ON TRACK
WHICH- IS YOU KNOW DEPARTMENT
FINANCES VERY LONG. A RECEDING-
OUR PROCESSES TO ENSURE CDCR
STAYS WITHIN OUR BUDGET. I WAS
CURIOUS HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
DESCRIBE THE DEPARTMENT. OF
FINANCE WHEN YOU STARTED THAT
SENT. IN ANY EVENT THAT THANK
YOU. IT'S MUTUALLY NOW I'VE GOT
A- HER I'M FED THEY TRIED TO ME
IN THE AND DO NOT WORK- BUT LET
ME THANK YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATED OUR ABILITY TO TALK
AND YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS AND I'M
GOING TO BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
YOU TO. THANK YOU SIR. SENATOR
THANK YOU- FOR THE RECORD I
THINK SENATOR COME LONGER NEEDS
TO CORRECTED NAME- IF YOU WOULD
ON THE RECORD US SENATOR AND
THEN I NEED TO GO BACK TO
SENATOR GROW FOR AN ADDITIONAL
QUESTION THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IT- MISS ALICE AND I SAID
HOWARD FORD IT'S HERALD
FORWARD- OKAY THANK YOU. I
THINK I MIGHT MAKE IT EASIER.
YEAH I CAN IMAGINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM PROTEIN
FOR ALLOWING ME TO HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL COMMENT. I AT A
SECRETARY I DO JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE AGAIN- I JUST HEARD
BACK FROM ANOTHER COLLEAGUE WHO
WAS AGAIN NOT AWARE. OF THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT WAS RELEASED
BY CDC ARE A SENATOR KABIRU IN
DISTRICT TWELVE. WITH SOLEDAD
AND- I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THE QUESTIONS THAT SHE HAS
ASKED ME TO ASK HER. A PRETTY
SIMILAR OR EXACTLY THE SAME AS
WHAT I'VE ASKED BEFORE ABOUT
HOW YOU CAME ACROSS PROCESS WHO
DETERMINES WHAT PRISONS ARE
CLOSE WHAT PROCESS FOR THE
COMMUNITY IS GIVEN. WHEN IS A
DECISION A DECISION FINALIZED-
WHAT'S THE CRITERIA I MEAN ALL
OF THESE ARE ONES THAT YOU'VE
WHO LOSE THEIR JOB AHEAD STAFF
ISSUES AHEAD COMMUNITY ISSUES.
THEY'RE ALL QUESTIONS THAT I
HAD ASKED YOU PREVIOUSLY
REGARDING THE TO HATCH A P. AND
THE- THE SUSANVILLE PRISON- I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED
EARLIER AND NOT AND EXCLUSIVE
THEY'RE NOT IN EXCLUSIVE AND
ANY OTHER. QUESTIONS THAT
LEGISLATORS HAVE I DON'T WANT
TO PLAN FOR- FOR DISPATCH BE A
ONE MAKE SURE THAT IT'S CLEAR
AND THAT THERE'S NO
MISUNDERSTANDING THAT ALL OF US
LEGISLATORS ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE WAY THIS PROCESS IS.
IS HAS BEEN IN THE PAST. AND
THAT ALL OF THIS- ESPECIALLY
THE ONES THAT HAVE MAYBE NOT
ALL OF THIS BUT SPECIFICALLY
THE ONES THAT HAVE ASKED FOR
THIS- REQUEST A BETTER PROCESS
MOVING FORWARD AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT CENTER. SENATOR
KABIR UNDERSTANDS THAT- HER AT
DISTRICT IS INCLUDED IN THAT
REQUEST. THANK YOU MA'AM OF
COURSE I WILL SAY THAT WE-
ACCORDING TO THE- MY CURRENT
KNOWLEDGE AS WE DO NOT
ANTICIPATE- CTO OR CCI TO
ANTICIPATE- LAYOFFS FOR-
DISPLACEMENTS THERE'S ENOUGH
VACANCIES AT THOSE LOCATIONS TO
ABSORB THAT THE REJECTION OF
THE STOCK ON THAT ONE
INDIVIDUAL YARD. OKAY THANK YOU
MA'AM VERY MUCH IN A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION ON MY COLLEAGUES FROM
ORANGE COUNTY- REGARDING THE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS- DECEIVE
YOU SEE ARE CURRENTLY ACROSS
REFERENCE SO SECURITY NUMBERS
WITH THOSE IN. M. IN CUSTODY
WITH THOSE APPLYING. FOR
BENEFITS AT THE EDT OFFICE. WE
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION FOR
EDG TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT CROSS
REFERENCE THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALL. AND LET
ME- SAY HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE
YOUR TAKING THE TIME ALL RIGHT
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH ME
MUCH EARLIER THAN THIS WEEK WE
HAD WE DID THIS- A BIT AGO- I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS I KNOW
THAT MY STAFF HAVE HAVE
COLLECTED THEM- ARE ARE THERE
SO THAT WE CAN GET AN ADEQUATE
RESPONSE I HAVE A FEELING THAT
THE- THE RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT
ABOUT CLOSURES. SORT OF TOOK
PRECEDENCE OVER- SOME ISSUES
ALTHOUGH I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
AND SAY THANK YOU TO SENATOR
COM LONGER FOR THE QUESTIONS AS
SHE ASK AND CERTAINLY RELATED-
ALSO CENTER LAYERED REFERENCE
OF SOME OF THE ISSUES AROUND
THE TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY AND
HOUSING- ISSUES APPRECIATE ALL
THAT THERE IS ABSOLUTELY A
BENEFIT TO GOING LAST- BEFORE
WE GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT BUT I
WANTED TO- I JUST WANT TO PUT
ON THE RECORD- YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE YOUR EXPERIENCE MUCH
TO THE POINT THAT SENATOR BATES
THE VICE CHAIRWOMAN. MENTIONED
YOUR HISTORY YOUR DIVERSE
BACKGROUND AND WHAT YOU BRING
TO THIS POSITION- AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU I
THINK WHEN WE MET I OUT LET YOU
KNOW THAT THE PRIOR- SECRETARY
HAD A AT A PRACTICE. AT OUR
REQUESTED THE RULES COMMITTEE
OF MEETING WITH US ON A PRETTY
REGULAR ON A QUARTERLY BASIS
BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER OF.
CONCERNS AND ISSUES- THAT WE
HAD- AND MANY TIMES THAT
INCLUDED SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM. THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE- I MIGHT WANNA IT
JUST SUGGEST IN TERMS OF THE
CAPACITY ISSUES. THAT THIS IS
AN ITEM THAT CAN BE. A JOINT
AYE INFORMATIONAL HEARING
CLEARLY NOT RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC BUT AS
WE GET INTO. HOPEFULLY SUMMER
AND FALL THAT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE IN THE BDGET SUB
FIVE COMMITTEE CAN DO TO TALK A
LITTLE MORE EXTENSIVELY AND I
HEARING FASHION ABOUT THAT SO
THAT THE- LEGISLATURE
UNDERSTANDS- THIS THE STRATEGY
AROUND CAPACITY AND HAVE AND
WE'RE- HAPPY TO SEE- A
DECREASING POPULATION- AND THE
LESSENING OF OVERCROWDING IN
OUR PRISONS- THAT'S A GOOD
THING- I DO WANT TO JUST SAY.
AS IT RELATES BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
SPEND. A LOT OF TIME WILL
HARDLY IF ANY EXIT MAKING
REFERENCE TO THE FACT OF THE-
PANDEMIC IN THE TRANSFER OF ALL
INMATES. ARM AND IT SEEMED TO
ME THAT A LOT OF THE REACTION
AND COMMENT. IN THE BACK UP
THAT OUR STAFF WORK SO HARD TO
PREPARE FOR US WAS THAT THIS
WAS REALLY THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE FEDERAL RECEIVER. I
HOWEVER I DO HAVE A CONCERN
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE ACTUAL
TRANSFER WAS THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF CDCR STAFF. AND THERE SEEM
TO BE SOME INDICATION THAT
THERE WERE. INDIVIDUALS AND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ARENA THAT HAD
CONCERNS AND POINTED THIS OUT.
SO WHILE THE RESPONSIBILITY MAY
BELONG TO THE FEDERAL RECEIVER
I JUST WANNA MAKE A POINT THAT-
I HAVE CONCERNS WITH THAT THAT
ANSWER TO THE DEGREE THAT. I
THINK THIS IS A PARTNERSHIP
AND- THE PRACTICE OF HELL THAT
TRANSIT THOSE TRANSFERS HAPPEN
IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF CDC
ARE SO I WILL JUST. LEAVE IT AT
THAT- YOU MADE A COMMENT WHICH
I REALLY WAS IMPRESSED WITH
ABOUT. US BEING AHEAD OF THE
GAME R. AS IT RELATED TO SOME
OF THE TESTING ISSUES AND SOME
OF THE PROTOCOLS. AND I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE I SAW
EVIDENCE OF THAT WHEN I HAD OF
PRIOR CONVERSATION- WITH CDC
ARE. I HOWEVER THINK SOME OF
THAT IS OVERSHADOWED BY THE
SITUATION OF THE TRANSFERS AND
I HOPE THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE ANOTHER SITUATION LIKE
THIS PANDEMIC THAT. TEST YOU ON
THAT BUT I DO THINK YOU AND
YOUR TEAM ARE ARE REALLY GOING
TO HAVE TO. LIVE THAT DOWN AND-
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WANT
TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF THESE
ISSUES- SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE TIME YOU GAVE TO ME AND
PARTICULARLY SOME OF THE THINGS
YOU SHARED RELATED TO
EXPERIENCES- IN YOUR LONG
CAREER- THROUGH CDC ARE WHICH
REALLY INFORMS ME ABOUT YOUR-
AND MY MIND YOUR CHARACTER AND
YOUR- COMMITMENT AND YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO DO THIS. SO YOU
WILL HAVE MY SUPPORT TODAY ARM
AND AT THE SAME TIME I KNOW
THAT I HAVE THE ABILITY TO- AND
I WILL ASK YOU TO RE COMMIT.
THAT YOU WILL MEET WITH US ON A
FAIRLY REGULAR BASIS AS THE
FORMER SECRETARY DID. SO THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
OPEN DIALOGUE ON A REGULAR
BASIS ON ISSUES THAT CONCERN US
AND IF YOU WOULD JUST. CONFIRM
THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO DO THAT-
THEN I WILL COULD CONCLUDE MY
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MA'AM
ABSOLUTELY I'M COMMITTED TO
MEETING WITH- ANY ANY MEMBER
COLLECTIVELY AS A GROUP WHEN
WHENEVER NEEDED. AND FRANKLY AT
REGULAR SCHEDULED MEETINGS IS
OFTEN TIMES THAT THE MAYBE THE
BEST OPTION BUT ALWAYS
AVAILABLE. ANYTIME SECRETARY
THANK YOU. OUT WITH THAT WHAT I
AM GOING TO DO I'M GONNA DO
SOME A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN GOING
FOR QUITE A PERIOD OF TIME AND
I'M COGNIZANT THAT WE HAVE A
STENOGRAPHER. THAT SHOULD TAKE
A BREAK BEFORE WE GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. SO WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE I'M GOING TO TAKE
OUR- OF FIVE TO SEVEN MINUTE
BREAK SO THAT WE CAN I GIVE
THAT REST AND WE WILL RECONVENE
IN TEN FIVE MINUTES. THANK YOU.
THEN COME BACK TO ORDER- I MAKE
SURE I SEE. AND. I MAKE SURE I
SEE EVERYONE IS BACK IN PLACE.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I IT WAS A-
IT WAS A LONG DISCUSSION BUT IT
WAS- NECESSARY AND I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTIONS OF MY COLLEAGUES
I APPRECIATE THE PATIENCE AND
CERTAINLY SECRETARY THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO. ANSWER
ALL OF THESE QUESTIONS WE ARE
NOW GOING TO GO TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY AND WE WILL START. WITH
OUR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WANT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT- AND
I AM GOING TO GIVEN THE AMOUNT
OF TIME WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN AND
THAT WE HAVE OTHER. CDC ARE
APPOINTEES WAITING I AM GOING
TO ASK OUR THE SPEAKERS WHO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND IN
OPPOSITION. TO GIVE ME THEIR
NAME. THE ORGANIZATION THEY
REPRESENT IF ANY AND THEIR
POSITION ONLY. I REALLY- AND-
WANT EVERYONE TO GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. AND I
WILL FIND OUT HOW MANY PEOPLE
WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE WHEN WE GO
TO TELECONFERENCE BUT- I WANT
TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BUT I ALSO
KNOW THAT WE HAVE. A LONGER
AGENDA AND OTHERS ARE WAITING
SO I WILL ASK MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO GIVE ME AGAIN. NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION POSITION
ONLY YES OR NO- OKAY LET ME
START HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. AND TO US SEE IF
THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. I DON'T SEE A MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THIS ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I WILL GO
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. AND SEE IF
WE HAVE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THERE. OKAY WE DO NOT SO LET ME
ASK IF OUR MODERATOR- VIA
TELECONFERENCE IS READY. AND-
WELCOME YOU. THANK YOU. FOR
ADEQUATELY DIDN'T. IF YOU DO
HAVE QUESTIONS PRESS ONE THE
ZERO DEDUCTIBLE. IF YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK ON THE MEASURE. WE'RE
GETTING A FEEDBACK HERE ONE BUT
YOU LIKE IT. YES WE ARE READY
TO WORK BUT. OKAY WE'RE WE'RE
CHEST WERE CHECKING ON THAT
MISTER MODERATOR RIGHT NOW.
HOLD ON JUST A SECOND. YEAH
YEAH. ONE ONE MINUTE WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE JUST A MINUTE R.
AS WE CHECK ON THE TECHNICAL
CAPABILITIES HERE SO BEAR WITH
US. THANK YOU.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA
TRY AGAIN MISTER MODERATOR GO
AHEAD AND LET'S SEE IF THIS IS
BETTER. THANK YOU. WE CAN GO
FIRST TO LINE FORTY NINE. A
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS DAVID CALDERON- FOR
MORE SIX RESTORED TO RIFLED
HOME I JUST RECENTLY GOT
RELEASED ALL POLL. HELLO FOR A
YEAR OR SO WELL I'M HERE JUST
TO SHOW. SUPPORT FOR OUR OPEN.
BECAUSE OF OUR BELIEF THAT THE
WASN'T FOR THIS ELEVEN SEVEN
BILLION. ALL REMEMBER DAY HERE
TO GIVE YOU WHAT MY MOTHER NOW-
I'M NOT HERE WERE. ON ORDERS
JOB- AND I'M NOT HERE MY FAMILY
DOCTOR SUPPORTER MILLION- IN
ORDER FOR HIS LETTER SEVEN DID
I WOULD BE OUT HERE IN OUR
TERMS TO BE IMPRISONED.BUT-
LIKE I SAID I LIKE TO. SHOW
SUPPORT FOR HER AND- THEN I'LL
KEEP THIS PROGRAM. ELEVEN FOR
MAY DAY- I'M STILL GOING AROUND.
ELECTRIC ROUTE IMPROVED WAS OF
SELF HELP GROUPS. LIKE- GOEL G.
O. WHY GROUPS IN ORDER. THANK
YOU SIR WILL GO NEXT TO MINE.
FORTY SEVEN. HELLO I'M MY NAME
IS SUSAN CHAMPION I'M CALLING
FROM STANFORD LAW SCHOOL THREE
STRIKES PROJECT I AM- INFINITY
ACTIVELY AND WHOLEHEARTEDLY-
COMMENTING IN SUPPORT OF THE
PALESTINIAN APPOINTMENT SHE IS
WILDLY COMPETENT SHE KNOWS.
INSIDE AND OUT SHE'S ONE OF THE
MOST FAIR COMPASSIONATE AND
HARDWORKING PEOPLE I'VE EVER
KNOWN BUT A LITTLE AND WORKED
WITH INTEL I STRONG AND THEN
FAVOR OF. OUR THROUGH THE-
THANK YOU MUCH OF MR MODERATOR
AS YOU GO TO THE NEXT PERSON
LET ME- HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
SOMEONE WITH EXPERIENCE FROM
WITHIN. THE INSTITUTIONS
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT AND FROM-
CERTAINLY AN ADVOCATE I'M GOING
TO ASK THE SPEAKERS TO GIVE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION IF
ANY AND YOU'RE YES SUPPORT
POSITION WITHOUT A LOT OF
COMMENTARY GIVEN THE TIME AND
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE OTHER
APPOINTEES. SO. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR GO AHEAD. LINE FORTY
AHEAD. HELLO MY BERMAN- AND I
AM THE DIRECTOR TO TREAT PRO
THE CHANCE FOR LAW SCHOOL THANK
YOU JUST A AND I- ALSO ALL
HEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE-
APPOINTMENT SECRETARY OUT SHE
IS REALLY AN OUCH- FOR THE
STATE AND I THAT YOU. UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT SHE TO ME THANK YOU
VERY. MR MODERATOR NECK WITNESS
BOB LINE. FORTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS THE BOND C.
E. FOR AMITY FOR- IS MY FOURTH
YEAR OF FAMILY THAT'S BEEN IN
BY CARS. OR DICTION- SH SUPPORT
THE APPOINTMENT OF A ALLISON.
AND HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH
HER ON RE AND IN THE AND
REPRESENT OUR OF PEOPLE ON THE
PROVIDE REAL SERVER- THAT ARE
RICH HOME AND BASED PROVIDE AND
THEY WERE. THAT YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS. LINE
FORTY ONE. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE S. AS
WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
OPERATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS. ONE SIXTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
SECRETARY OUTLOOK THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. LINE. FIFTEEN MY NAME
IS MARK TAYLOR AND I'M ALIVE
BECAUSE WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION- ALSO A
FORMER LIFE PRISON PRISONER WHO
IS WHOLEHEARTEDLY IN SUPPORT OF
THE CONFIRMATION OF CAP BEING
OUTLOOK AND EXPECT RETIRED
CORRECTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. WHY IN. THIRTEEN I AM
DAVID AMAYA I'M UNLIKELY
PREVENTIVE COALITION ALSO LIKE
ROOM BUSINESS THE CAPTAIN OF WE
COME PERFECT OF THE ON THE
COURT WITH BOTH AND THE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR- NECK
WITNESS. BY THIRTY THREE. HELLO
AND IS KHAN FOR LATE COACH FOR
THE FIRST DIFFICULT AND ALSO
FORMERLY LARGE SUPPORT HOLE THE
CURRENT OF WE ALSO PERCENT JERK
BURKE BECAUSE SHE BELIEVES IN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NINE TWENTY- MY NAME
IS SAM LOWER ON THE THAT OF A
R. C. TO WAS CALL MY SUPPORT
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE COUPLE
MADE OF SUCH KAY ALISON I THANK
YOU MADAM AND ESTEEMED MEMBERS
THE GENERAL COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS.
LINE FIFTY ONE. I MY NAME IS
AND THEIR OF NAY AT AT FOR THE
ENTIRE WITH COALITION SPONSOR.
THANK YOU SO YOUR TEST NAY WIT.
ONE THIRTY SIX. BUT AFTER MY
NAME MULLIN UP LATE I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE ARE DOZENS OF
WHO WERE THEIR UNDER A SEVEN D.
PROGRAM THEM ABOUT AND HAS HAD
A PROTESTER OF IT ALL UP AND IT.
HER REFERRAL SEPARATE ABOUT OF
YEAR AT STATE CAR THREE ON THE
OF MY CLIENT BURKE AND
COMMUNITIES I STRONGLY ENDORSE
HER I CALL OF SECRETARY THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. BLESSED WITH BEEN Q.
IS LIGHT. ONE ONE TWENTY ONE IF
YOU IT HITS A ONE THEN ZERO
AGAIN WE CAN OPEN YOUR LINE WE
DID NOT HEAR YOU. WE HAVE. WELL
I TWENTY ONE PLEASE ONCE AGAIN
HIT ONE THEN ZERO WE CAN OPEN
UP YOUR LINE AGAIN. K. LINE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE PICK UP YOUR HANDSET OR
CHECK COMMUTE FEATURE. WE'RE
HEARING NOTHING BUT- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME MY NAME IS
JANELLE CARTER I'M A LIFE COACH
AND ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION-
I'M FORMERLY INCARCERATED AS
WELL- I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
CONFIRMATION AS SECRETARY
KATHLEEN OUT. THANK YOU SO. FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY- FURTHER OR
WITNESSES MISTER MODERATOR. YES
WE HAVE A COUPLE MORE A MORE
CUTE MADAM CHAIR- WE HAVE LINE.
SIXTY FIVE. HELLO YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DRINKABLE
WATER THE NAME THIS SOCIALLY
DURING VINCE APPLE FOR THE
ENTIRE RACISM BECAUSE AND I
INFORM A LOT OF THE NINE HERE
INSULT IMPOSED OF AB OUT
INCLUDES. OF THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT WE MISTER MODERATE- LINE
SIXTY THREE. HI MY IS THE HORSE
OF THE PRISON PROJECT I MEAN
FOR OF CASH L. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY NEXT WITNESS. WE HAVE
LOWER L. IN Q. THIS TIME.
MISTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH BE
BACK WITH YOU A FEW. SO I'M
GONNA BACK INTO- ROOM THIRTY
NINETY ONE FOR ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT MIGHT BE HERE
IN OPPOSITION. BUT AGAIN I SEE
NO ONE FROM THE PUBLIC HEARING
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I'M
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND CHECK
QUICKLY ROOM ONE TWELVE. OKAY I
DON'T SEE ANYONE HAS ENTERED
ROOM ONE TWELVE SO MISTER
MODERATOR WERE ALREADY BACK
WITH YOU FOR. WITNESSES THAT
MAY BE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
CONFIRMATION. AND IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
CONFIRMATION FIRST ONE ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCHTONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. AN EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
DOING QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME.
OKAY MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HELP I'M SURE WE'LL
TALK TO YOU AGAIN I AND IN A
LITTLE WHILE. LET ME COME BACK
INTO- TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND SEE IF THERE ARE FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. SENATOR
LAYERED I WOULD DOUBLE CURRENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR SO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR- MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
GROOVE KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER I
LAYERED. I BELIEVE I JUST LIKE
TO ENTER ONCE AGAIN INTO
COMMENTS I AM VERY VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF SECRETARY ALISON
I HAVE ASKED FOR A- ACTUAL
WRITTEN ON A DOCUMENT SHOWING%
THE COMMITMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE ON THE OUR PROCESS FOR A
CLOSURE OF THE FACILITY AND
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE EQUATION
BUT I DON'T WANT MY BUILT MY
NON POLLUTING BE INTERPRETED AS
SOMETHING LEFT FANS THIS
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL IS HIGHLY
QUALIFIED FOR THIS POSITION AND
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED VERY
LATE VERY LATE. YESTERDAY THAT
CAUSED QUITE A STIR- I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE SOMETHING AND
DOCUMENTATION FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
ON THE ISSUE OF THE CLOSURES
AND HOW THEY AFFECT COMMUNITIES
THAT WE REPRESENT SO I JUST
WANT IT ALL ON THE RECORD THAT
SHE IS SO QUALIFIED I AM VERY.
SORRY THAT IT'S COME UP SO LATE
AND I AM FULLY INTENDING TO
SUPPORT HER CONFIRMATION. WHEN
WE GET TO THE FINAL VOTE. TODAY
I WILL BE IN A BUILDING. THE
NOT VOTING AGAINST I THINK I ON
CALL AND WE WILL LEAVE THIS ON
CALL BECAUSE US SENATOR IN AT
THE COMMITTEE WE SEE SO- MADAM
I. YOU CURRENT HAVE ARE. THREE
VO. AND WE THE IS A- OR A
RECORD TO THE FLOOR TO CONFIRM
WE WILL LEAVE THE VOTE OPEN SO
THAT SENATOR GROWTH CAN BUT
WHEN SHE COMES BACK SO
CONGRATULATIONS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING. THE
RESPONSES AND ANSWERS AND
CERTAINLY TO WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM THANK
YOU OFF COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. OKAY WE ARE- GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON WITH.
INCREDIBLE GRATITUDE TO THE
APPOINTEES THAT HAVE BEEN
WAITING BUT I'M SURE THIS WAS.
INFORMATIVE TO YOU GIVEN THAT
YOU ARE ALL PART OF- CDC ARE SO
OUR FINAL ITEM UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. ARE THREE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
ONE B. MR. VERA ROSA DIRECTOR
OF ADULT PAROLE OPERATIONS ONE
C. MR- BORK- DIRECTOR OF
FACILITY PLANNING CONSTRUCTION
AND MANAGEMENT. AND ONE D.
MISTER DAVIS ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
RECEPTION CENTER INSTITUTIONS
SO GENTLEMAN LET ME WELCOME
YOU. AND INVITE YOU TO DO-
WHAT- WHAT WE THE SICK TO DO
WHICH IS TO MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE SOMEONE THAT- YOU
WANT TO RECOGNIZE OR OR THANK
AS PART OF THE PROCESS AND THEN
WE WILL GO. RIGHT TO OUR
MEMBERS WHAT I WILL SAY GIVEN
THAT THESE ARE THREE SEPARATE
POSITIONS IN THE PAST WE'VE
TAKEN UP- COMMISSIONERS OF A
SAME BORDER BODY AT THE SAME
TIME AND ASK GENERAL QUESTIONS
I'M GOING TO ASK MY COLLEAGUES
WE GET TO YOU. THAT YOU DIRECT
YOUR QUESTION TO THE
APPROPRIATE INDIVIDUAL AND
APPROPRIATE- POSITION AND TITLE
OF FOR THE QUESTION BUT WITH
THAT WE WILL START- AND WELCOME
YOU MISTER VERA ROSE SET TO
MAKE OPENING COMMENTS. I GO
RIGHT AHEAD SIR WELCOME. THANK
YOU. PARDEE TIME BE OVER OF THE
TIME WAS FEMALE- I THINK-
SERVER HAVING NOT A LITTLE I
WANT MAKE SURE TO A CAN PER-
ARE SO REFERS HAVING A HARD
TIME HEARING YOU SO LET ME ASK
YOU I TO START AGAIN AND LET'S
SEE IF IT'S THE CONNECTION OR
WE JUST NEED- A LITTLE MORE
CLARIFICATION- VERBALLY GO
AHEAD. OKAY. AFTER SPEAKING. WE.
I UNDERSTAND. I IT SOFTLY I
THINK SOME THE CAN AND I'M
TRYING LOOK AT OUR AYE T. FOLK
TO SEE IT MAY BE IS US. THE
MAYBE MAYBE PROJECTED THE MY-
IT MISTER VERA ROSA AND WE WILL
SEE IF THERE HELPFUL. MORE THAN
THREE TO INCREASE. ALL. FIFTY
I'M AYE SHE'S CAN'T HEAR YOU
PHAM. LET SEE EIGHT YOU KNOW IT
IS THE WE CAN HEAR YOU YOU.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE EASY IT
SEEMS WHEN YOU SPEAK IN ONE
DIRECTION WE HEAR YOU BETTER-
WHY DON'T WE TRY ONE MORE TIME.
YEAH ARE YOU ABLE TO. HERE.
IT'S STILL IT'S STILL DIFFICULT
FOR THE MOMENT WHY DON'T- WHY
DON'T. WE AYE WHY DON'T I ASK
AND DIRECT MY STAFF TO FIGURE
OUT A DIFFERENT WAY TO DO THIS
AND LET LET ME WITH RESPECT.
DIRECTOR LET ME MOVE TO MR BORG
ART DIRECTOR OF FACILITIES
PLANNING CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT AND I WILL SEE IF
PEOPLE CAN BE COMMUNICATING OUT
WHILE WE DO THIS TO SEE IF WE
CAN GET A BETTER- AN ABILITY TO
HEAR YOU SO. FORGIVE ME BUT MR
BORK WHY DON'T YOU GO AHEAD AND
GIVE US YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
AND WE'LL SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO
FIX THE SITUATION AND LET ME
SAY WELCOME TO YOU. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DEAN BORG
AND I HAVE THE HONOR TO HAVE
BEEN APPOINTED ME DIRECTOR OF
FACILITIES PLANNING
CONSTRUCTION AND MANAGEMENT.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. IT IS AN HONOR
TO APPEAR BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY AS PART OF THE SENATE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS. THERE'S A
CLEAR CORRELATION BETWEEN
INFRASTRUCTURE CONDITIONS AT
OUR PRISON FACILITIES. ANY
ABILITY FOR CDC. AND THE
ABILITY FOR CDCR STAFF. TO
PROVIDE REHABILITATION AND
TREATMENT MISTER THE- I AM SO
SORRY I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO
SLOW DOWN WE HEAR YOU VERY
CLEARLY- SO WE WERE GOING TO
TEST EVERY POTENTIAL
POSSIBILITY TODAY DURING THIS
HEARING. LET ME JUST ASK YOU TO
SLOW DOWN AND START AGAIN AND
WE'RE ALL GOOD. CERTAINLY I
WILL TALK A I'LL TALK SLOWER A
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DEAN BORG
AND I HAVE THE HONOR TO HAVE
BEEN APPOINTED THE DIRECTOR OF
FACILITY PLANNING CONSTRUCTION
AND MANAGEMENT. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
IT IS AN HONOR TO APPEAR BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY AS PART OF
THE SENATE CONFIRMATION PROCESS.
THERE IS A CLEAR CORRELATION
BETWEEN INFRASTRUCTURE
CONDITIONS AT OUR PRISON
FACILITIES. ANY ABILITY FOR
CDCR STAFF TO PROVIDE
REHABILITATION AND TREATMENT TO
THE INCARCERATED POPULATION. I
AM PROUD TO REPORT THAT
SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS IMPROVING
CCAR'S BUILDING CONDITIONS. THE
HEALTHCARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM IS PROVIDING NEW AND
RENOVATED HEALTH CARE SPACES AT
MORE THAN THIRTY PRISON. CDCR
HAS IMPLEMENTED A STATEWIDE
PLAN FOR PRISON ROOF
REPLACEMENTS THAT IMPROVES
CONDITIONS FOR BOTH HOUSING
UNITS AND TREATMENT BUILDINGS.
AND ANNUAL MAINTENANCE FUNDING
ALLOCATED WHICH PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN INCREASED WHICH IS
IMPROVING THE DAY TODAY
CONDITION OF OUR BUILDING. WITH
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT I WILL
WORK WITH DEPARTMENTAL
STAKEHOLDERS TO CONTINUE THE
PROGRESS WE HAVE MADE IN
ADDRESSING CDC OURS
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AND
SUPPORTING THE REHABILITATIVE
AND TREATMENT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
VITAL TO CDC OURS MISSION. I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT MY FAMILY IS
ABLE TO WATCH TODAY BUT IN
CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY FAMILY AND THE
LOVE AND SUPPORT I HAVE
RECEIVED FROM MY WIFE
CATHERINE. AND MY TWO CHILDREN
ALEXA AND ETHAN THROUGHOUT MY
CAREER AND ESPECIALLY IN MY
CURRENT ROLE. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND- AND I'M
GETTING FEEDBACK NOW. AND MY
MICROSOFT HERE SO. THE LAW.
YEAH OKAY. I AM SO SORRY FOR
THIS DIFFICULTY THAT SOUNDS
BETTER DOES IT OKAY. LET ME
INVITE I MISTER DAVIS C. SOCI
DIRECTOR RECEPTION CENTER
INSTITUTIONS TO GO AHEAD TO
MAKE OPENING COMMENTS AND- AND
THEN WE'LL GO BACK TO MR VIA
ROSA TO SEE IF THAT WORKS GO
AHEAD MISTER DAVIS AND WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IT'S AN HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO BE BEFORE YOU
TODAY- FOR THE CONFIRMATION FOR
THE POSITION OF ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR. FOR RECEPTION CENTERS
AND CAMPS WITHIN THE DIVISION
OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS- MANY
PEOPLE CONTRIBUTED TO MY BEING
HERE TODAY I'D LIKE TO THANK MY
FAMILY MY FRIENDS- AMAZING
COWORKERS MENTORS- MOST OF ALL
MY WONDERFUL WIFE GRETEL. SHE
KEEPS ME GROUNDED. AND I
COULDN'T DO WITHOUT HER LEFT
AND SACRIFICE- I WAS APPOINTED
TO THIS ARE TWO TWENTY TWO-
I'VE WORKED AT SEVEN DIFFERENT
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES OVER MY
TWENTY SIX YEAR CAREER.
PROMOTED UP THROUGH THE UNIFORM
TACITI RANKS AND IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN I WAS APPOINTED
WORKING AT VALLEY STATE PRISON.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN I MOVED TO
SAN QUENTIN STATE PRISON IS
WORKING WORST SERVED UNTIL
DISAPPOINTMENT. DURING MY
CAREER I OBSERVED FIRSTHAND THE
ABILITY OF PEOPLE TO CHANGE
GIVEN THE TOOLS AND
OPPORTUNITY. IN SPEAKING TO THE
MEN AND WOMEN ARE CUSTODY HAVE
SEEN THEIR ENTHUSIASM AND
APPRECIATION. FOR THE
REHABILITATIVE OPPORTUNITIES IN
OUR CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES.
I'M HONORED BY GOVERNOR NEWSOMSUPPORT AND APPOINTING ME TO
THIS POSITION IT'S AN HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO BE BEFORE YOU.
TODAY AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK TO MISTER VERA ROSA
AND- GIVE IT ANOTHER TRY AND
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AS WELL LET'S TRY
AGAIN GO AHEAD AND WELCOME.
IMPERIAL WAR BUT WE'RE STILL
WORK IN PROGRESS HERE TRYING TO
RESOLVE THE- AUDIO I THINK
YOU'RE THAT WAS EXCELLENT I
THINK THAT DID IT- SO LET ME
YOU YOU SAY WELCOME YOU CAN
CATCH YOUR BREATH END TO. AND
MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU- LAKE CITY I WAS ABLE
TO RESOLVE THAT PROBLEM BUT BUT
IT WASN'T IT WAS THE ACTUAL
DEPARTMENT HERE AND THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY I
HAVE BEEN REAL TIME EDITED MY
COMMENTS DOWN TO BE AS BRIEF AS
POSSIBLE ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
DESTRUCTION THAT WE HAD. I THIS
MIGHT NOT BE A MADE. BORN
CALIFORNIA MY SPENT THE-
BALANCE OF MY ADULT LIFE
SERVING THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA A CIVIL SERVANT.
MUCH OF THAT TIME HAS BEEN AND
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION AT EVERY
LEVEL. FROM PRE TRIAL SERVICES
TO. A JUVENILE SUPERVISION TO
ADULT SUPERVISION- AND MUCH OF
THAT TIME SINCE THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND WITH THE CALIFORNIA.
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. I SAY THAT- I'M
TO SHOW THAT I HAVE HAND
KNOWLEDGE. OF VALUE AND THE
CRITICAL ROLE THAT FEDERAL
SERVICES BRING TO THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN OUR
BEST MOMENTS PRO AGENTS SERVE
AS A SAFETY NET FOR THE MOST
MARGINALIZED. AND THE SERVICE
ADVOCATES FOR THOSE BEING
RELEASED FROM PRISON TO BE
GIVEN A FAIR SECOND CHANCE. BUT
THEY DO THIS BY PREPARING FOR
THE RELEASE. OF MONTHS AHEAD OF
TIME. AND BY SITTING WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS IN THEIR HOMES
TO DETERMINE. WHAT WHAT NEEDS-
THIS FORMERLY INCARCERATED
HAVE. ALONE IN ORDER TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND TO AND TO REALLY
BE WHO THEY ALWAYS WANTED TO BE
NOT FOR THE MISTAKES OF BUT
THEM- TO PRISON- WITH THAT
BACKDROP AGENTS ROSS ON THE
FRONTLINE OF SAY. WIENER BEING
BREAK THE SIDE OF DOMESTIC BY.
PREVENTING FURTHER BACK.
ABSOLUTE MOST BAR AND- I'M ALSO.
NOT BLIND TO THE FACT THAT IN
OUR WORST MOMENTS THE PUBLIC
PERCEIVES- COROLLAS IN
DIFFERENT OR MAYBE ON THE WRONG
SIDE OF HISTORY. WHEN IT COMES
TO THE DIFFICULT INTERACTIONS
BETWEEN. LAW ENFORCEMENT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND THE AREAS
OF RACE POVERTY AND GENDER. BUT
THAT'S NOT LIBERAL I KNOW
THAT'S NOT THE POOL THAT MIGHT
LEAD. MANAGER RECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF ADULT PAROLE
OPERATIONS I INTEND ON.
CONTINUING THE REFORMS ALREADY
UNDERWAY TO ENHANCE THE
CONNECTIONS THAT WE HAVE WITH
FAMILIES OF THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED. THE WAY THAT WE
WORK IN CONCERT WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NOW WE BRING
NONGOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
TO THE TABLE AS DECISION
MAKERS- MY FOCUS WILL BE TO
TACKLE THOSE FACTORS THAT
THREATEN REINTEGRATION NAMELY
BOTTOM CLAREMONT. DIFFICULTY IN
FINDING HOUSING AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. FOR THOSE
RELEASED UNDER OUR CARE. I'LL
STOP THERE BECAUSE OF THE TIME
BUT WELCOME. QUESTIONS YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY THANK
ALL THREE OF YOU FOR OPEN COM.
A. N. DOT LET GO AHEAD AND WITH
SOME LAYER- AND DIRECT YOUR T
THE SPA. OF INDIVIDUAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH N. NINE
APPRECIATE CHANCE TO MEET WITH-
ALL THREE OF YOU I JUST- YOU I
WAS GONNA MAKE A CALM ABOUT HOW
YOU THE WHITE DIDN'T WHEN I WAS
IN THE ASSEMBLY. THE TIME YOU
WANT TO PRESENT A BILL WAS
RIGHT BEFORE EVERYBODY HAD TO
RUN OUT TO CATCH A FLIGHT
BECAUSE THAT NOBODY WOULD TALK.
AND THEY WOULD JUST PASS IT AND
SO ARE HOPEFULLY. YOU BENEFIT
FROM THIS OF THE SAME WAY.
THERE ARE NO FLIGHTS TODAY. I
DON'T THINK WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT FLIGHT IN THE PRESENT
DISCUSSION. OF IT LET ME START
WITH RON DAVIS OF BECAUSE-
MISTER DAVIS YOUR JOB HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR FIRE CAMPS
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THAT-
EARLIER TODAY. AND ARE COULD
YOU DESCRIBE THE NUMBER FAR
CAMPS- WHETHER YOU HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE TO COME INTO THE- HOW
THEY WORK WHETHER YOU'RE
LEAVING THOSE WHERE THEY ARE.
OVER TIME JUST GIVE US A
GENERAL DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
FIRE CAMPS IN THE SYSTEM.
ACTUALLY YOU SENATOR SO
CURRENTLY HAVE THIRTY FIVE-
FIRE CAMPS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND WITH THE CLOSURE OF
PROPOSED CLOSURE OF CCC THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL CENTER-
THE CAMPS ALL THE CAMPS ARE
GONNA STAY OPEN CURRENTLY THE
CAMPS ARE SUPPORTED BY TWO
INSTITUTIONS- BEEN ORGANISED
SEVEN CAPS ARE SUPPORTED BY-
ZERO CONSERVATION CENTER
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL CENTER-
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF TWO THAT
ARE LOCATED ON SITE AT
DIFFERENT FACILITIES- WHAT IT
CALIFORNIA MEN'S COLONY WANTED.
THE CALIFORNIA REPUBLIC CENTER.
BUT DIRECTOR OF THE OR LOOK-
THROUGHOUT THE STATES OF BY THE
TWO FACILITIES WITH THE CLOSURE
THAT SUPPORT IS NOW GONNA FALL
SO CON CENTER OF THE SUPPORT
AND TRAINING OF OUR OF OUR FIVE
FIRE CREWS WILL WILL BE
SUPPORTED BY SEC- SO WE'RE NOT
CLOSING ANYMORE CAMPUS- THE
CARE POPULATIONS DOWN RIGHT
NOW- PUBLIC SAFETY REALIGNMENT.
TOOK A LOT OF THE- THE POSSIBLE
POTENTIAL VOLUNTEERS FOR THAT
PROGRAM I MEAN THEY'RE NOT IN
OUR SYSTEM ANY LONGER SO WE'VE
LOOKED VERY THOUGHTFULLY AT OUR
CRITERIA. WE RECENTLY EXPANDED
THE CRITERIA FROM FIVE YEARS
TRYING TO SERVE EIGHT YEARS
TIME TO SERVE TO INCREASE THAT
THAT POOL OF CANDIDATES- WE
ALSO LOOK AT INCENTIVES- TO TRY
AND ENCOURAGE PEOPLE. TO TO
VOLUNTEER FOR THAT PROGRAM-
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN- ALLOWS FOR A CERTAIN
OFFENSES TO HAVE THEIR
OFFENDERS TO HAVE THEIR-
RECORDS EXPUNGED IF THEY'VE
SUCCESSFULLY PULL COMPLETE
COMPLETED THE FIREFIGHTER
PROGRAM PARTICIPATED IN THE
FIREFIGHTER PROGRAM- SO WERE
WERE REALLY PUBLICIZING THAT
OUT TO THE POTENTIAL CANDIDATES
TO TRY AND TO TRY AND DRAW THAT
IN- THE GREAT THING IF
SOMEBODY- IS ABLE TO GET THAT
GET THAT RECORD EXPUNGED THEY
MAKE ONE. ONE MISTAKE IN THEIR
LIFE- AND TO BE ABLE TO DO
SOMETHING TO GET THAT THEIR
RECORDS CLEARED SILVA DATA
DEFINED BY THAT FOR THE REST OF
THEIR LIFE THAT'S A PRETTY BIG
INCENTIVE- SO WE'RE REALLY
WE'RE REALLY GOING AFTER THAT-
ENGINE. JUST LOOKING AT THE CAR
BUT YOU'VE GOT A REALLY BAD
PUBLIC SAFETY- IN MAKING SURE
THAT YOUR PUTTING PUTTING
PEOPLE OUT THERE IN THOSE FIRE
CAMPS BECAUSE IT IS THEY DO
HAVE A LOT OF FREEDOM OUT THERE
THAT IT IS. A SAFE ENVIRONMENT
SAFE FOR THE PUBLIC SO
BALANCING THAT- IS VERY
IMPORTANT- AS FAR AS POPULATION
RIGHT NOW HAS BEEN IMPACTED- BY
KOBE- SECRETARY MINUTE
MENTIONED- YOU KNOW AROUND
THOUSAND WAITING IN COUNTY
JAILS TO COME INTO OUR PRISON
SYSTEM- WE ALSO HAVE MANY
SITTING IN A RECEPTION CENTERS-
THAT THEY WERE TRYING TO GET UP
INTO OUR INDOOR CAMP TRAINING
PROGRAM SO- JUST ALL OF THE
MOVEMENT. WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH OUR HEALTHCARE
PARTNERS ON OUR TESTING ARE
QUARANTINING- OUR OUR MOVEMENT
PROTOCOLS INCLUDING FOR PP SO
WORKING THROUGH THESE
PROCESSES- THEY'RE TRYING TO
TRYING TO GET THOSE NUMBERS UP
SO THAT WE CAN GET THOSE THAT
THOSE VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTERS
OUT THERE TO ASSIST GREAT THANK
YOU AND I DO KNOW THAT IT WAS
AN ISSUE BECAUSE IT. ONE OF MY
LOCAL WHAT WENT INTO THE
JURISDICTION A LOT OF THE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S INVOLVED A
HOLDER COORDINATION THING TO
GET THEM TO CONTINUE TO DO IT.
WHAT MAY I ASK MR BORG. OF JUST.
OUR OUR GIVEN YOUR FISTS. ARE
ARE THE- BEEN A- ABOUT THE NEW
FOR NEW FOR SO OR- DOWN EXIST
ONES. JUST A BRIEF ON THE SUB
OF THE FOR MAKE. WHAT DO YOU
HAVE BEEN DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ARE YOU UP TO DATE A HOW DOES
THAT WORK IN THIS. I THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THAT QUESTION- WE
DO TRACK I DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AS IDENTIFIED- BY EACH PRISON-
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM- WE USE
THAT AND MEET WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT TO PRIORITIZE- WHERE
ARE DOLLARS SHOULD BE SPENT-
SINCETHE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS WILL TAKE SEVERAL
YEARS TO PLAN AND CONSTRUCT
WERE ALWAYS. TRYING TO LOOK OUT
A TWO TO THREE YEARS AND SEEING
WHERE THE NEEDS ARE ARE MOST
ACUTE SO THAT WE CAN- EIGHT. AT
YOUR DRESS ADDRESS SITUATIONS-
BEFORE THEY GET WORSE-
OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE MAIN- BUT
ONE OF THE MAJOR COMPONENTS OF
OUR MAINTENANCE PROGRAM IS A
ROOF REPLACEMENT PROGRAM- WHICH
IS- GOING TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY-
IMPROVING. CONDITIONS
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM- WELL AS
FAR AS THE WAY WE ARE AT AN
INFLECTION POINT- WITH TO
PRISON CLOSURES AND- THE LOWER
POPULATION- WITH BEING ABLE TO
LOOK AT OUR- FACILITY NEEDS
DOWN THE ROAD. AND BE ABLE TO.
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T INVEST
A LAWLER LOT AMOUNT OF MONEY IN
CERTAIN PLACES IF THEY ARE
LIKELY TO CLOSE SO WE ARE
INCREASING- OUR INTERNAL
MEETINGS. WE'VE ALWAYS MET
WITH- VERY STAKEHOLDERS A
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS-
AND- THERE'S NO REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AND- THE MEDICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH CARE- SIDE OF
THE- C. C. H. C. S.
ORGANIZATION- WE'RE ALSO GOING
TO BE LOOKING- TO INCREASE OUR
MEETINGS WITH UNDER SECRETARY
LEVEL- SO THAT WHEN WE'RE-
PREPARING TO MAKE MAJOR
INVESTMENTS- IN. IN EACH FISCAL
YEAR THAT- WE'RE WE'RE MAKING
THOSE DECISIONS SMARTLY-
KNOWING WHAT THAT THAT THERE'S
UNCERTAINTY IN THE FUTURE SO
LET'S MAXIMIZE AND THE.
PRIORITIZE WHERE ARE DOLLARS TO
GO. GREAT YOU VERY. AND THEN
LET ME. A MAN VIA ROSS. ARE WE
TO. OF THIS MORNING JIM ABOUT.
THE CHANGES ADULTS. WITH THE-
BEING DOWN. AND THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE REMAINING
POPULATION IS. SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT THAN IT WAS BEFORE
REALIGNMENT BUT AT THE SAME
TIME YOU MENTIONED TO ME. THAT
YOU GET TO YOUR WORKERS BASED
ON CASELOADS SO- IT IS ARE THE
ARE THE NUMBER OF WORKERS
ADEQUATE. TO THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT. ARE ASSIGNED TO THEM
TODAY. IS THERE ENOUGH
COVERAGE- TO GO AND JUST YOU
TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THE THINGS
THEY WORK WITH THEM ON I THINK
WOULD BE GOOD FOR YOU TO JUST.
TALK ABOUT THAT A LITTLE.
CRESCENTA CONCERN SENATE. NOW
WE DISCUSS THE AT ITS HIGH-
VICTOR. WILL POP YOU. WAS
HOPING FROM HUNDRED FEET EIGHT
HUNDRED AND- THOUSAND. GOALIES
TODAY WE'RE DOWN AROUND FIFTY
THE- MANY OF THOSE ARE THE FROM
PRISON- A RELEASE TO
SUPERVISION HOLDING THE- AND
WILL THAT WE ON PRO SUPERVISION
TEND TO BE- THOSE. EITHER RATE
OR HIGH NEED- AT JUST THAT
REDUCTION IN- AGENT- AGENT WENT
ALONG WITH THAT WE- SOME STAY
AND OF. OUR FUND NUMBER OF THE
SUPER TO AGE. WE HAVE SO OF THE
LOW CASE SO- GRAY FOR HIGH RISK
OFFENDER- AND THE GENERAL
COOLEY ARE FUNDED FIFTY FIVE
ONE SIXTY. FOR TO ONE IT BE. A
CHALLENGE FOR AGE. TO SHIFT IN
THE PAST OF SU. AND THIS THEY
THEY NEED TO PROVIDE ONE ENTIRE
CHIU LOAD HAS FOR THAT HAVE
SERIOUS OR BY CRIME. I THINK WE
TAP TO WHICH- SOME OF THE THAT
PROVIDE- BUT IN ESSENCE TO YOUR
QUESTION THOSE RICH- RATIO IN
THE FUNDING HISTORY SO THERE
ISN'T OVER BY BY. A WHAT HAVE
SOMETIME AND TOURIST WITH BANK
CASE. WE DON'T HAVE THE IS
SUPERBOWL BY THE OF COOPERATION.
I'M YOUR SUPERVISOR. BUT WELL
TO HIGHLIGHTS. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THANK MANAGE
APPRECIATE- INTEREST THE
QUESTION. SENATOR THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR WE YOU LIKE GO
THERE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
YEAH OF LET ME BEGIN WITH A MR
BE WROTE. AND I'M THANK YOU FOR
STERN FOREMOST OF FOUR YEARS.
AND YOUR- IN RAY OF MANY YEARS
THAT YOU'VE TO THIS PARTICULAR.
AREA YOU HAVE THE IT'S QUITE A
BECAUSE I KNOW THE FIX
DIFFICULT HAVE RELAY. ON MANY
YEARS OF AND I WAS REFERRED TO
WEAR HER ITEM OF FRIENDS WERE
PRO. AGENTS ALSO WITH FROM OF
OUR- FIFTY OUT OF WE WERE
WORKING TO N OUT THE DIFFERENT
JOB. I'M CONCERN ABOUT THE OF
THE. I RECEIVED. I READ THAT
CORRECTLY IF YOU ARE READING IT
CORRECTLY THANK YOU SIR BATES
UP HERE REFERENCING- WITH WITH
ANY SUPERVISION AND CITY
THERE'S A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF
THE FOUNDERS THAT- DO NOT
REPORT CHRISTY PROVISION OR
SOMETHING HAPPENS IN THE MIDDLE
OF THEIR SUPERVISION PERIOD AND
THEY HAVE SPAWNED I BELIEVE
YOU'RE REFERENCING THE FACT
THAT- VISION OF ADULT CROSS. IS
HOVERING SOMEWHERE IN THE LOW
SIX THOUSAND AND TERMS OF-
FOLKS WITH THAT WE HAVE ACTIVE
WARRANTS AND THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR- WARRANTS THAT. I'M GOING
TO THE COMMON LAW ENFORCEMENT
SYSTEM- WE HAVE A TWENTY FOUR
HOUR SEVEN DAY A WEEK. WARRANT
SYSTEMS MURDERED DISPATCH
SYSTEM WHAT WE PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHEN THEY CALL IN-
IN THE EVENT THEY- ARE ABLE TO
LOCATE THESE FOLKS. I'M NOT
SATISFIED WITH THAT NUMBER OF
COURSE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. SUPERVISION SERVICES
AND MEET THE NEEDS OF ALL THOSE
THAT ARE. UNDER CROSS. THE
REALITY IS THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN NUMBER THAT- DESPITE
ANY EFFORTS- THE DUDE'S GONE
PROSCRIPTION AND ONCE THAT
HAPPENS WE DON'T STOP LOOKING
FOR THEM. WE DO HOPE TO BRING
THEM BACK INTO THE SUPERVISION
FULL THAT SOME POINT- OF COURSE
THE PANDEMICS HAS MADE IT MORE
DIFFICULT- I THINK THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE REFERENCING WITH REGARD
TO NUMBER WHEN I NOTICED THAT I
JUST THOUGHT THAT THAT COULD BE
REALLY FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
PAROLE AGENTS AND THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ON THEIR CASELOAD
DO THEY GET A FIFTH AND FALL
WITH THE FOLLOW UP ON THEM
BECAUSE THE JOB IS ALREADY
DIFFICULT AND HAVING TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR LOCATING.
WHATEVER THE GIVEN NUMBER IN A
DIFFERENT YOU KNOW SPECIFIC
CAPABILITY IF THAT WOULD BE
DIFFICULT TO HAVE A SEPARATE OF
DIVISION OR A FINE NEEDS TO
FOLLOW UP ON THOSE WHO ARE
REPORTED MISSING FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS CAREFUL. AS A PART
OF REGULAR PAROLE SUPERVISION.
IS DOING FOLLOW UPS AND TRYING
TO FIND THOSE FOLKS THAT ARE.
WARRANTS HOWEVER- WE HAVE PRIDE
OF THE PANDEMIC. HAVE A POOL
APPREHENSION TEAM. SOLELY
DEDICATED TO LOOKING FOR
PORTION OF THOSE FOLKS WERE
DISCUSSING. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ALSO HAS A
SEPARATE FUGITIVE APPREHENSION
TEAM. THAT IS NOT PART OF THE
DIVISION OF ADULT PAROLE
OPERATIONS AND OUR MISSION IS
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT- BUT THEY O
LOOK FOR- SOME OF THOSE HIGHER
RISK. CRUELTIES AT LARGE GROUPS
CONNORS IT MAY ALSO BE INVOLVED
OR WANT TO. JURISDICTIONS
FALLING. ONGOING CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. WELL THANKS FOR THAT
I WAS LOOKING AT IT IN OF THE
BURDEN THAT THAT MIGHT BE ON
THE INDIVIDUAL- PEARL AGENTS
AND WHETHER YOU ARE ACTUALLY
SAVE DID YOU NEED A LITTLE MORE
MONEY. IN THAT PARTICULAR AREA
TO ENSURE THAT YOU HAVE PEOPLE
THAT COULD DO THE FOLLOW UP
WHILE THE A FINE JOB THE AGENT
WAS TAKING CARE OF. OF THOSE
WHO WERE COMPLYING AYE I HAD A
BILL MANY YEARS AGO REGARDING
THE TRANSIENT SLUGGED OUT
WITHOUT TO- MOVE AROUND A LOT
NOT NOT TO AND I GUESS THEY
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO REPORT
AGAIN BUT- GIVE AND NOW WHAT
WE'VE SEEN WITH HOMELESS
POPULATION AND ALL THE
PRESSURES THAT ARE THERE IT
JUST AND HOUSING. INDIVIDUALS
THAT COULD ADD TO THAT
PARTICULAR BURDEN SO ANYWAY
JUST DIED. VERY INTERESTING AND
OUT OF CERTAINLY KEEP A PHONE
THE PRICE OF THAT BECAUSE WITH
OF I THINK OF THE DIFFICULT
AREA AND CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT SHOULDN'T BE A BLOTCH ON.
A WHAT A BLACK MARK ON WHAT YOU
ALL ARE DOING BECAUSE WHEN
YOU'RE SO INVOLVED THESE DAYS
WITH. THE REFORM EFFORTS THAT
ARE GOING ON THE REHABILITATION
EFFORTS THAT ARE GOING ON WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE TOUCH ALL OF THEM. ARE
FULL- JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS
FOR- MISTER BORGE MISTER DAVIS
AND I HAVE TO REFER BACK TO THE
LATE NOTICE THAT WE GOT ON THE
FIRE CAMP SANDO SUSANVILLE
PRISON. CLOSURES AND THAT WITH-
YEAH YOU HEARD PROBABLY A VERY
IN DEPTH DISCUSSION ABOUT WITH-
IF A WITH SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
SO I'M NOT MONEY TO GO BACK
THROUGH THAT BUT GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVES ON THE BALLOT IN.
CONFIRMING THAT THE FIRE
TRAINING CAMP IS IN FACT NOT
BEING CLOSE THAT I DID I
UNDERSTAND THAT CORRECTLY THAT
WAS KIND OF IN THIS.
COMMUNICATION. OR
MISINTERPRETATION. WHENEVER TO
A TWO YEAR MISTER AGAIN MISTER
DAVIS INTERNAL. INVOLVED FOR SO.
MISTER BARKER YOU GO- AND THEN
FOLLOWED UP BY MISTER DAVIS
THANK YOU. YES THANK US
SENATOR- YES WE DID- OBVIOUSLY
WE WERE ON- ON THIS HEARING-
FOR THE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
SECRETARY ALISON SO ALL OF THE
POINTS- REGARDING THE IMPACT OF
COMMUNITY- ARE ARE TAKEN TO
HEART- I HEY I HAVE I'M ONE OF
MANY CONTRIBUTING ROLES- TO THE
PRISON CLOSURE DECISIONS- I DO
PROVIDE INFORMATION REGARDING
THE CONDITIONS OF THE PRISONS
AND- FUTURE PLANS- THAT MIGHT
BE NEEDED- BUT I'M ONE OF THOSE
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WORK
TOGETHER TO REACH EVENTUAL
CLOSURE DECISIONS SO- FOR IN
THE FUTURE AS WE'RE LOOKING AT
THAT- I OBVIOUSLY A SECTOR
ALLISON'S GONNA. WORK WITH US
TO MAKE SURE THAT- WE IMPROVE
OUR NOTIFICATION PATTERNS AND-
CAN HAVE BEEN CONCERNED WITH
THE IMPACT OF THE COMMUNITY- I
BELIEVE THAT MISTER DAVIS HAS A
MUCH MORE SPECIFIC INFORMATION
RELATED TO THE PARK AND
TRAINING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR- SO THE FIRE CAMP
THERE'S A FIRE CAMP THAT'S
LOCATED ON SITE AND WILL CAMPUS
LOCATED ON SITE- I'M IN
SUSANVILLE THE FIRE CAMP IN
THAT AREA IS THAT BACK CAMPUS
STAYING OPEN THE TRAINING
PORTION FOR TRAINING
FIREFIGHTERS HAPPENS WITHIN THE
PRISON ITSELF THE TRAINING
PORTION. IS GOING TO BE CLOSING
IN ALL OF THE TRAINING WILL BE
HAPPENING DOWN AT SIERRA
CONSERVATION CENTER DOWN IN
JAMESTOWN. THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION WHY DID ASK
SECRETARY ALISON FOR SOME
INFORMATION TO PROVIDE TO ME IN
WRITING REGARDING THE ISSUES ON
NON THE IMPACT TO THE
COMMUNITIES ON A NUMBER OF
ISSUES AND I KNOW YOU'LL ALL BE
COLLABORATING ON THE OUT SOLE.
I WAIT TO GET THAT INFORMATION
FROM ALL OF YOU AND THAT FROM
ABOUT ALL THE QUESTIONS I HAVE.
FOR THIS AFTERNOON BUT AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK BOTH OF YOU ALL
THREE OF YOU FOR YOUR
DEDICATION TO THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE IN OUR STATE.
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN INCARCERATED
OF BACK ON THE RIGHT TRACK SO
THEY CAN CERTAINLY ENJOY- OF
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
GREAT STATE PROVIDES EDUCATION
WISE FONG OCCUPATION LIES
PROFESSION GETTING PEOPLE. WHO
UNFORTUNATELY FELL INTO YOUR
SUPERVISION BACK WITH- THEY ARE
COMMUNITIES TO CONTRIBUTE CHEN
AND THEM WANTING TO CERTAINLY
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAMS
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND I
KNOW YOU'RE ALL VERY DEDICATED
TO THAT PARTICULAR OUTCOME SO
THANK YOU AND- WE'LL BE TALKING
BEFORE WE THIS COMES BEFORE. ON
THE SENATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR ASANA GROWTH BEFORE YOU
HAVE TO SCOOT BACK OVER TO
HEALTH LET ME LET YOU GO.
NETTING'S YOUTH MADAM PROVED
HIM AND I DO APOLOGIZE IF THESE
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ASKED. I'VE
BEEN KIND OF BOUNCING BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN AND COMMITTEES. I
DO HAVE SOME- WHO- QUESTIONS
FOR IT- DIRECTOR AT VERO SAYS.
AND MAYBE ONE OR TWO FOR
OTHERS- I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW UP
ON ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS FROM LOS ANGELES
REGARDING- HER QUESTIONS- WITH
MISS ALICE AND- I'M AND I
WASN'T AWARE OF THIS- I WASN'T
AWARE OF THE FACT THAT
CONTRACTS THAT ARE MADE WHERE
PEOPLE MAKE THINGS ARE HAVE YOU
KNOW- THINGS DONE IN PRISON
THEY HAVE A LOWER WAGE AND THEN
WHEN THEY GET OUT. THOSE
COMPANIES I REFUSE TO HIRE
INDIVIDUALS I'M I'M A FIRM
BELIEVER THAT AS IT IS THE
BEST. SOLUTION FOR RECIDIVISM
RECIDIVISM AND POVERTY IS A JOB
AND THAT IF PEOPLE HAVE A JOB
THAT GIVES THEM A SENSE OF SELF
WORTH AND ABILITY TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND SO MY
QUESTION IS THAT DO YOU HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH SOME O THOSE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE THOSE
CONTRACTS WITH CDC ARE- WELL
PEOPLE IN PRISON IF YOU DO OR
YOUR TEAM DOES WHAT'S YOUR
OUTREACH PLANS SO THAT WHEN
THESE INDIVIDUALS GET OUT OF
PRISON. THEY CAN GO APPLY FOR
THOSE JOBS AND- THE- THE-
CONTRARY TO MY COLLEAGUE IN LOS
ANGELES- PURPOSES AS WELL I
DON'T THINK IN PRISON THEY
SHOULD MAKE. A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY ROOF I MEAN I'M
YOU KNOW I'M NOT ADVOCATING FOR
THAT. BUT I THINK THAT IF THEY
GO TO APPLY AFTER THEY GET OUT
OF PRISON AND THEY'VE ALREADY
SHOWN THAT THEY CAN DO THE WORK
THAT THAT SHOULD DEFINITELY BE
A CONSIDERATION AND SO WHAT'S
YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH SOME OF
THESE CONTRACTORS THAT ACTUALLY
I DO THIS WORK. AND WHY IS IT
THAT THEY DO NOT OFFER- THESE-
EMPLOYEES- JOBS SINCE THEY'VE
BEEN DOING THE WORK FOR. SO
MANY YEARS. THANK YOU CENTER
GOODBYE. I CONCUR WITH YOUR-
ASTUTE- COMMENT THAT. THE
EMPLOYMENT IS CRITICAL BE ABLE
TO RE INTEGRATE SOME OF THESE
FOLKS AND THAT MANY TIMES- WE
SEE THAT- ONE OF THE CRITICAL
FACTORS FOR. LEADING OTHERS
UNDER SUPERVISION BACK INTO
CUSTODY REALLY FOR FALL AROUND
AREAS OF POVERTY AND HAVING THE
ABILITY. TO HAVE APPLICABLE
SKILLS. UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T
THINK I CAN COMMENT TOO MUCH ON
THE INCLUDES THAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING- WHAT I CAN TELL
YOU I'M I'M I JUST DON'T. I'M
GONNA OF WHO THEY- MY- AM OPEN
TO RECEIVING INFORMATION BUT
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT-
THE EFFORTS THAT THE DIVISIONAL
PRO OPERATION UNDERTAKES FIND-
SUSTAINABLE PAINT JOBS- WE GO
TO GREAT LENGTHS AN EFFORTS IN
TERMS OF BOTH EMPLOYABILITY AND
HAVING FOLKS OUT- PROGRESS WITH
THEIR ACADEMIC SKILLS THAT ARE
SORT OF A- A- FACTOR TO THEN BE
TRAINED AND BECOME EMPLOYED
LONG TERM. WE HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH- OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT REHABILITATION- ONE
OF. THE GREATEST ENDEAVORS OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS IS THE
VENTURA. TRAINING CENTER WHICH
IS A FIRE. FIGHTER TRAINING
CENTER- THAT. WAS ESTABLISHED
TO ASSIST WITH TRAINING
FORMALLY INCARCERATED BE ABLE
JOIN THOSE RANKS IT'S A
RESIDENTIAL LONG TERM PROGRAM
IN WHICH THEY RECEIVED A
TRAINING- I HAD GREAT SUCCESS
IN THEIR EMPLOYABILITY AND BOTH
THE FIRE FIGHTING FIELD AND
EMPLOYMENT IN OTHER SECTORS. SO
WE ARE EYEING PERSONALLY ALWAYS
WILLING TO MEET WITH FOLKS THAT
CAN HELP THEM FIND EMPLOYMENT
OR TRAINING FOR OUR POPULATION-
I CERTAINLY THINK THAT. IT IT
IT FOLLOWS IT WOULD BE DIRECTOR
ANY TRAINING THEY RECIEVED IN A
PRISON- FOR US AND CRUEL TO
ASSIST- THOSE UNDER OUR
SUPERVISION AND FINDING
EMPLOYMENT AS BEST WE CAN- BUT
IN TERMS OF SPECIFICS AT YOUR
QUESTION I DON'T THINK I. CAN
COMMENT THAT'S OKAY AM I JUST
WAS CURIOUS ABOUT YOUR
RELATIONSHIP OR YOUR TEAM'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH THESE
CONTRACTORS AND IF YOU DID
KNOW- WHY THEY WOULDN'T
EMPLOYEES INDIVIDUALS- THAT
ALREADY SKILLED IN THAT
SPECIFIC JOB- ONCE THEY GOT OUT
OF PRISON TO HELP THEM ACHIEVE
THE- MORE POSITIVE LIFE- I DO
KNOW THAT- I MEAN I DO KNOW I
MEAN WE HAVE WE HAVE A RANCH
PROPERTY IN OUR FAMILY THERE IS
A FIRE ON IT AND WE HAD A IN
MEAT- FIREFIGHTERS THERE AND-
THEY WORKED. ALONGSIDE OUR CAL
FIRE AND THEY WORK JUST AS HARD
AND JUST AS LONG AND THEY DID A
REALLY GOOD JOB I ALSO KNOW
THAT TIME WE HAD A LOT OF
POORLY TRANSFERS FROM LOS
ANGELES TO WORK IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY BECAUSE IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY IN KERN COUNTY-
THERE'S A LOT OF JOBS WERE YOU
CAN MAKE A REALLY GOOD LIVING.
AND DEAD YOU CAN KEEP YOURSELF
OUT OF TROUBLE AND YOU CAN AND-
AS LONG AS YOU CAN SHOW UP ON
TIME AND TAKEN DIRECTION RIGHT
THAT'S WHAT THE BASIC
REQUIREMENTS ARE SO. AND I DO
HOPE THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK AND DEVELOP EMPLOYMENT AND
FOR INDIVIDUALS ONCE THEY'RE
RELEASED- BECAUSE- THAT IS
ESSENTIAL TO MAKING SURE THAT
THEY DON'T GO BACK. I DO HAVE-
A QUESTION. FOR THANK YOU SIR
FOR THAT. I APPRECIATE THAT I
DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR. MISTER
DAVIS. THREE DAVIS THEIR- YES
HE IS THERE OKAY ON THE- ON THE-
MISTER DAVIS THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY- YOU HAVE
OVERSIGHT MANAGEMENT
RESPONSIBILITY OF TEN ADULT
INSTITUTIONS AND THIRTY FIVE
FIRE CAMPS INCLUDING THE
RICHARD J. DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY IN OTAY MESA. A RECENT
TWO PART INVESTIGATIVE REPORT
FROM- IN NEW SERVICE
HIGHLIGHTED- THAT R. J. DONOVAN
HAD THE WORST TRACK RECORD
AMONG THE PRISONS FOR ITS
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC
INCLUDING THREE INMATES THAT
WERE FOUND UNRESPONSIVE IN
THEIR CELLS. AND. WHAT'S YOUR
ROLE IN OVERSEEING THE R. J.
DONOVAN AND OTHER- PRISONS AND
DO YOU RESPONSIBILITY IN
RESPONDING TO THE PANDEMIC
BECAUSE THAT. I MEAN I WOULD
THINK THAT THAT EVEN WITH OUR
EARLY BAD CHECKS OR YOU KNOW
AND. AGAIN I'VE TOURED SEVERAL
PRISONS IN- KERN COUNTY. AND IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY I WOULD
THINK THAT SOMEONE WOULD NOTICE
THAT SOMEONE WAS ON THE FLOOR
AND RESPONSIVE. YES THANK YOU
SENATOR- SO YES I AM OVER- AS
YOU MENTIONED TEN TEN
FACILITIES INCLUDING R. J.
DONOVAN AS WELL AS A THIRTY
FIVE FIRE CAMPS- I MAKE REGULAR
TOURS DOWN TO ALL OF THE
FACILITIES- TAKING A LOOK AT
YOU KNOW. BE COMPLIANCE-
WALKING TALKING TO STAFF AND
POPULATION- ARE COATED OR
COMPUTER RESPONSE IS REALLY A
JOINT EFFORT WITH OUR PARTNERS
FROM HEALTH CARE- AND WITH WITH
NURSING ROUNDS WITH CUSTODY
ROUNDS-CHECKING. CHECKING ON-
THE INCARCERATED POPULATION- AS
WELL AS AS WELL AS DOING
TESTING WHEN SOMEONE IS
IDENTIFIED AS BEING POSITIVE
MOVING THEM INTO THE TO THE
APPROPRIATE ISOLATION UNIT SO
AS NOT TO INFECT OTHERS- WHEN
PEOPLE POTENTIALLY COULD BE. AT
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED MOVING THEM
INTO A QUARANTINE AREA SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO- ACTUALLY
EXPOSE ANYONE ELSE- B. B. THE
STAFF DOWN THERE- I THINK
DEALING WITH THE SITUATION- AND
THE VOLUME THAT THEY THAT THEY
WERE HIT WITH IT ONCE- IF THEY
HAD A VERY DAY IT WAS A VERY
CHALLENGING TIME FOR THEM- I
CAN'T SPEAK TO THOSE THOSE
PARTICULAR CASES- BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THE STAFF ARE DILIGENT
GOING AND CHECKING- ON THE
WELFARE OF THE POPULATION- AND
MEDICAL AS WELL AS THE NURSES
GOING AROUND TO DOING THEIR
ROUNDS- BUT I CAN'T I DON'T
KNOW THE SPECIFICS ON THOSE. ON
THOSE CASES THAT YOU MENTION.
OKAY THANK YOU I'M AND SO-
THERE ARE ALSO CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE FAMILY AS I'M
INDIVIDUALS IN THE RICHARD J.
DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL FACILITY.
AND THAT IT WAS WEEKS- SEVERAL
WEEKS GOING INTO MONTHS BEFORE
THEY WERE EVEN NOTIFIED THAT
THEIR RELATIVE OR FAMILY MEMBER
WAS- ILL OR HAD CONTRACTED
COVERT NOW. I'M NOT I AM NOT
CASTING ANY BLAME MY I KNOW
THAT COOLEY TOOK EVERYBODY BY
SURPRISE PEOPLE HAD TO ADAPT
IMMEDIATELY- IN A JUST AND
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN YOU KNOW
DO DIFFERENT THINGS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY MET THE
GUIDELINES THAT THEY DID WHAT
THEY HAD TO DO TO KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE- BUT- I. I JUST THINK
THAT- I MEAN. IF SOMEBODY IN MY
BUSINESS- IN MY EMPLOYMENT IN
THE REAL WORLD- GOT CO WOULD BE
NOTIFIED AT A FANCY WE NOTIFY
PEOPLE INSTANTLY LIKE. ACTUALLY
I THINK THAT THEY STARTED A LOT
OF REQUIRED US TO DO WITHIN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS. RT EXECUTIVE
ORDER- AT. IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT. A WITH EVERYBODY AT CDC
ARE IN A STATE RUN FACILITY
THAT THAT IT TOOK WEEKS TO
NOTIFY- ANYBODY THAT THEIR
FAMILY MEMBER WAS ILL CAN YOU
COMMENT ON THAT. AGAIN TO
MISTER DAVIS I APOLOGIZE. YES
THANK YOU SENATOR- AS FAR AS
NOTIFICATION OF THE FAMILY-
THAT'S NORMALLY- ONLY GONNA BE
DONE IF THEY'RE IF THEY'RE SENT
TO LIKE AN OUTSIDE HOSPITAL-
THE ILLNESS ITSELF MANY MANY OF
THE- OF THE POPULATION WHO. WHO
WERE TESTING POSITIVE- FOR A
SYMPTOMATIC AND STILL HAD
ACCESS TO- TO MAKE CONTACT WITH
THE FAMILY MEMBERS THEMSELVES
IF THERE WERE INDIVIDUALS THAT
WERE UNABLE TO DO SO- AGAIN I
DON'T I DON'T HAVE SPECIFICS ON
ON THE INDIVIDUALS. WERE THE
COMPLAINTS CAME FROM- SO IT'S
DIFFICULT TO SPEAK ON SPECIFIC
SITUATIONS BUT IN IN MOST
SITUATIONS- WHERE WE DID HAVE
CODED- THE POPULATION STILL DID
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE
CONTACT WITH THEIR FAMILY- EVEN
WITHIN- THE QUARANTINE AND
ISOLATION UNITS. THANK YOU ON
MY LAST QUESTION I HAVE IS ON
BEHALF OF MY THREE SHERIFF'S.
ST TO M. MY DISTRICT IS SO BIG
IT SPREADS OVER THREE COUNTIES
AND THEY'RE ALL THREE IN THE
SAME POSITION AND- HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE SENTENCED TO PRISON
THAT REMAINING CALLIE COUNTY
JAILS DUE TO THE SUSPENSION OF
INTAKE DURING COVERT NINETEEN.
AND DEM. ANNA NGUYEN. ARE YOU
GONNA RESUME INTAKE. MISTER
DAVIS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR- THE NUMBER IS AROUND
TEN THOUSAND I DON'T HAVE THE
EXACT FIGURE RIGHT NOW- WE ARE
CURRENTLY DOING INTAKE AND
WE'RE MAKING PLANS TO INCREASE
INTAKE TO TRY AND HELP CLEAR
THAT COUNTY BACKLOG- AGAIN WITH
THE WITH THE CHALLENGES OF KOBE
AND WITH WITH THE- TESTING
REQUIREMENTS IN QUARANTINE
REQUIREMENTS UPON RECEIPT- AS
WELL AS TRYING TO GET THAT
MOVEMENT BACK OUT OF RECEPTION
CENTER FOLLOWING. A RECEPTION
CENTRE PROCESSING- KOBE JUST
ADDS A WHOLE NOTHER LAYER OF
CHALLENGES ON TO THAT BUT WE
ARE CURRENTLY DOING INTAKE-
IT'S BEING COORDINATED WEEKLY-
AND COUNTY BY COUNTY
ARRANGEMENTS ARE MADE TO AND
TAKE WHAT WE CAN WHAT WE HAVE
SPACE FOR- AND THAT SPACES JUST
GENERALLY DICTATED BY. SPACE
FOR QUARANTINE. AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE- I DO
BUT I NEED TO SUBMIT TO YOU
THAT OUR LOCAL COUNTY JAILS IN
OUR COUNTY COMMUNITIES ARE NOT
AND- AS LONG TERM FACILITIES.
THEY ARE FOR SHORT TERM- EVEN
YOU KNOW THEIR SHORT TERM
FACILITIES AND- SO THE PANDEMIC
WHEN YOU SAY WE'RE NOT TAKING
AT DO DOING INTAKE BECAUSE CODE
AND IT DOESN'T ALLOW US- PEOPLE
ARE STILL BEING ASSIGNED TO
THAT COUNTY JAIL. AND THEY HAVE
FAR FEWER FACILITIES AND FAR
FEWER. ARE FAR LESS SPACE. THAN
YOU DO AT- ONE OF YOUR- PRISONS
THAT YOU OVERSEAS SO I WOULD
ASK YOU TO. TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION. MISTER DAVIS.
YES THANK YOU SENATOR- AS I
STATED WE ARE WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON A PLAN- TO INCREASE
OUR INTAKE TO ASSIST WITH THAT
COUNTY BACKLOG SO WE CAN HAVE.
SO WE CAN. I BELIEVE IT THAT
PROBLEM FOR THE COUNTIES I'M
WORKING WITH OUR HELP HEALTH
CARE PARTNERS- ON OUR ON OUR
MOVIE MATRIX SO THAT WE CAN GET
THE NECESSARY INTERNAL MOVEMENT
TO CLEAR THE SPACE TO DO THAT
COUNTY INTAKE I AM THANK YOU
DOES THAT PLAN INCLUDE ANY
FUTURE PANDEMIC RESPONSES SO
THAT THE COUNTIES AREN'T
ABSORBING- AGAIN IN IN LESS
SPACE AND LESS ADEQUATE
FACILITIES BECAUSE THEY ARE A
COUNTY JAIL NOT A FULL PRISON
SYSTEM- IS FUTURE PANDEMICS OUR
FUTURE ISSUES THAT WE MAY FACE-
I MEAN IT'S GREAT THAT YOU GUYS
JUST HAVE THE ABILITY SAY NO
WE'RE NOT TAKING THEM. BUT
THEY'RE STILL GETTING THEM SO
AND DO YOU HAVE A PLAN THAT TO
NOT LET THIS HAPPEN AGAIN OR IS
THAT PART OF YOUR PLAN. THANK
YOU SENATOR- I THINK WE'VE ALL
LEARNED A LOT WE'RE STILL
LEARNING FROM WHAT WE'VE GONE
THROUGH WITH THE PANDEMIC OVER
THE PAST YEAR- I THINK WE CAN
TAKE WHAT WE LEARNED AND
PROBABLY BE MORE EFFICIENT
GOING FORWARD- WHAT ANOTHER.
POTENTIAL PANDEMIC COULD BRING
TO US- IT'S DIFFICULT TO SAY
WHAT THE FUTURE MIGHT HOLD.
GIVEN WHAT THAT MIGHT BE- BUT I
THINK WE WE'VE WE'VE DEFINITELY
LEARNED A LOT FROM FROM. THIS
SITUATION. AND I THINK WE'RE I
THINK WE'RE MUCH BETTER FOR IT
OPERATIONALLY- SO I DEFINITELY
THINK IT WILL HELP US IF WE'RE
EVER FACED WITH SOMETHING. OF
THIS NATURE AGAIN. I AM THANK
YOU AGAIN I JUST WANT ARE JUST
SUBMIT TO YOU THAT- YOUR
FACILITIES ARE MORE HIGHLY
QUALIFIED TO TAKE INDIVIDUALS.
IN A PANDEMIC OR ANY OTHER
EMERGENCY SITUATION. THEN YOU
GUYS RECENT REFUSING TO RECEIVE
THOSEINDIVIDUALS IN KEEPING
THOSE INDIVIDUALS MORE CONFINED
IN A COUNTY NON LONG TERM
LOCATION. SO I'D LIKE TO SEE
YOU GUYS LOOK AT A PLAN TO
WHERE YOU'RE NOT PUTTING THE
COUNTY JAILS- IN THAT POSITION.
BECAUSE IT'S ALMOST AS IF AND
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE NEGATIVE
BUT IT'S ALMOST AS IF YOU JUST
WASH YOUR HANDS AND SAID. YOU
KNOW WE'RE NOT TAKING THESE
PEOPLE. AND IN YOU HAD A BETTER
CAPACITY TO TAKE- DO INTAKE
THEN KEEPING THOSE PEOPLE IN A
COUNTY JAIL IN A SMALLER
ENVIRONMENT- IT IS IN A LESS A
SUFFICIENT ENVIRONMENT FOR
WHAT- WHAT IS REQUIRED. AND SO
PLEASE THINK ABOUT THAT WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT YOUR LONG
TERM PLAN GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MATTER PROTECT.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE-
SENATOR COM LONGER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION I THINK FOR EACH OF
THEM ALL START WITH- STERN
BOARD WE TALKED EARLIER ABOUT
WATER- AND WE KNOW THAT- I
THINK SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
THREE PRESENCE OF OUR PRISONS
HAVE BEEN CITED ALMOST TWO
HUNDRED TIMES A FOR VIOLATING
DRINKING WATER STANDARDS WE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE STOCKTON
FACILITY AND THE CONTAMINATED
WATER THAT STILL PRESENT THEIR-
IN I WOULD JUST LIKE A. M. A
RESPONSE TO THAT CONCERN I. I
THINK I HAD ASKED- AN ISSUE NOT
JUST WITH THE FILTRATION SYSTEM
BUT THE FACT THAT BOTTLED
WATER- IS BEING- SHIPPED IN.
WHEN THAT CDC OURS USING
BOTTLED WATER AND SHOWER
FILTERS AS A SHORT TERM
RESPONSE- TO THIS ISSUE AND IN
JOKES. IN JUST I THINK I ASKED
IF- YOU WOULD DRINK THE WATER
IN THE FACILITY BUT IT IS A
DEEPER QUESTION ABOUT- HEALTH
STANDARDS THERE- ARE PIPING OR
PLUMBING SYSTEM THE
CONTAMINATION THAT MAY BE
FLOWING THROUGH. OUR PIPES AND
WHAT IS BEING DONE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE LIVING AND WORKING
N THE PROGRAM PRISONS ARE
SAFE- AND HAVE SAFE WATER.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND ON OUR
EARLIER CONVERSATION- SO YOU'RE
GOING BACK- TWO YEARS WHEN THE
LEGIONELLA WAS FIRST
DISCOVERED- AT THE STOCKTON
FACILITY- NUMBER STEPS WERE
TAKEN- ONE AND INCLUDED A I FOR
CHLORINATION OF ALL OF THE- OF
FACILITIES IN ORDER TO. OUR OF
WRITTEN TRAIN AND- YOU KNOW
SHOCK THE SYSTEM AND LIMIT. AS
MUCH- LEGIONELLA AS POSSIBLE AT
THAT POINT IN TIME WE'VE ALSO
IMPLEMENTED NEW MAINTENANCE
PROCEDURES WHICH- WORKS TO
LIMIT THE ABILITY FOR WATER TO
BECOME STAGNANT WITHIN THE
SYSTEM- AND THAT WAS- FUNDED
WITH ADDITIONAL MAINTENANCE
POSITIONS OF THESE ARE
ADDITIONAL STATE EMPLOYEES. WHO
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING
THAT WE ARE ARE HAVING ADEQUATE
WATER FLOW THERE IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN- THE CHLORINE LEVELS
WITHIN THE WATER. WE'VE ALSO-
AS OF FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR
BECAME OPERATIONAL WITH
ADDITIONAL CHLORINATION
EQUIPMENT THAT NOW HAS US AS A
LICENSED- WATER PURVEYOR- AT C.
H. CF IN STOCKTON. ARE THAT
WILL ALSO ALLOW US TO CONTINUE
TO MONITOR OUR OUR LEVELS OF
CHLORINE AND AT THE SAME TIME
CONTINUED TO DO TESTING FOR
LEGIONELLA. SO ON A MONTHLY
BASIS WE DO TESTING FOR
LEGIONELLA THROUGHOUT THE US
SYSTEM AND THOSE I AM WITH THAT
THROUGHOUT THE- PRESIDENT
STOCKTON PARDON ME- AND THAT
IS- THAT INFORMATION IS USED TO
IDENTIFY WITH THE BUILDINGS.
SHOULD BE ON WATER RESTRICTIONS
ARE NOT SO NUMBER BUILDINGS
HAVE BEEN REMOVED FROM WATER
RESTRICTION BASED ON THE
MONTHLY TESTING SHOWING ON A
VERY LOW LEVELS OF LEGIONELLA-
AND THOSE ARE BASED ON PUBLIC
HEALTH STANDARDS- AT THOSE
LOCATIONS. OTHER ONES WHICH DO
SHOW- HIGHER LEVELS OF BOTTLED
WATER IS- UTILIZED IN THOSE
BUILDINGS.BUT IN EVERY
BUILDING ALL OF THE DRINKING
FOUNTAINS AND ICE MACHINES THAT
WOULD BE USED QUITE FREQUENTLY
DO HAVE FILTERS MAKING THAT
WATER US SAFE TO DRINK- IN THE
SHOWERS OF COURSE OF HAVE THOSE
FILTERS. BUT OUR OUR LONG TERM
PLAN IS TO YOU NEED TO WORK THE
MAIN. AND ESPECIALLY WITHIN. OF
THE ADDITIONAL. OR THE NEXT TO
TWELVE MONTHS WOULD BE ABLE TO-
COMPARE. LEGIONELLA RESULTS
GOING FORWARD WITH THE
ADDITIONAL LET CHLORINE LEVELS
TO THE SAME LEVELS A YEAR AGO
BECAUSE THERE'S ALSO SEASONAL
DIFFERENCES AS FAR AS WHEN
LEGIONELLA MIGHT BE MORE-
PRESENT ONE MIGHT BE MORE
LIKELY TO PROPAGATE IN THE
SYSTEMS. SO THOSE ARE ARE ARE
ARE THE METHODS WERE DRESSING
DOWN IT- STOCKED IN- ELSEWHERE
IN THE SYSTEM A COUPLE OF
THINGS I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT-
WE HAVE RECEIVED- INCREASED-
MAINTENANCE FUNDING BOTH- ONE
TIME DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING. AND ALSO ONGOING
ANNUAL MAINTENANCE FUNDING OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THAT IS
pESPECIALLY ON CRITICAL ITEMS
SUCH AS WATER. AND DRINKING
WATER SYSTEMS WE ARE NOT
LETTING MAINTENANCE OR REPAIRS
LAG ON THOSE BUT MAKING SURE WE
PRIORITIZE THOSE. ONE LAST
THING I'D LIKE TO EMPHASIZE IS
WE ABOUT ONE THIRD OF OUR-
PRISONS OPERATE OFF OF THE
MUNICIPAL WATER SYSTEM AND THAT
WAS A SIMILAR SITUATION THERE
AT STOCKTON- WE- HAVE IN. DONNA
AUDIT OF THOSE PRISONS. SINCE
OUR EXPERIENCES OF STOCKTON IN
ORDER TO IMPLEMENT BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES AT THOSE
LOCATIONS MAKE SURE THE REGULAR
TESTING OF CHLORINE LEVELS.
AND- OTHER- BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES ARE IN PLACE IN ORDER
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE GOING
TO AVOID HAVING LEGIONELLA OR
OTHER WATERBORNE INSTANCES OF
THOSE LOCATIONS. THE OTHER TWO
THIRDS OF OUR PRISONS HAVE-
OPERATING OPERATE A WATER PLANT
THAT'S ALREADY LICENSED BY THE
DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER. AND
WE FEEL- BETTER AT THOSE
LOCATIONS BECAUSE WE KNOW WE'RE
ALREADY TESTING AND SENDING IN
REGULAR REPORTS. TO THE A
DIVISION OF. DRINKING WATER AT
AT THOSE LOCATIONS. SO MY
ASSUMPTION IS THAT AND CORRECT
ME IF I'M WRONG THAT THE
WARDENS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE- THE MAINTENANCE OF THEIR-
FACILITIES MAKING SURE THAT
THINGS ARE CLEAN AND SAFE- BUT
THAT. YOUR DIVISION IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR MONITORING THEM
AND HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN ARE
THEY SPOT CHECKS- ARE THERE
SORT OF- ARE THEY- SCHEDULED
VISIT SENATE HOW. ARE YOU DO
YOU GO BASED ON COMPLAINTS THAT
YOU GET I MEAN. AND I ASK
BECAUSE AND I THINK I MENTIONED
THIS IN OUR DISCUSSION- I
RECEIVED PHOTOS OF CONDITIONS
INSIDE- THE PRISONS. DURING
COBIT AND- DEBTS IMAGES WERE AS
SHOCKING AND- TO SAY THE LEAST.
BUT IT LOOKED LIKE A TORNADO
HAD HIT- INSIDE THE FACILITY
AND SO JUST DIDN'T KNOW HOW HOW
THAT KIND OF MONITORING.
HAPPENS. THANK YOU SENATOR- WE
DO HAVE A REGIONAL MAINTENANCE
MANAGERS ARE THERE ARE
EMPLOYEES OF OUR DIVISION HERE
THAT ARE SIGNED A GROUP OF-
PRISONS- FIVE SIX SEVEN
WILL- ROME ON A REGULAR BASIS
TO GO OUT TO VISIT THAT PRISON-
THEY MEET WITH THE STAFF OUT
THERE TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE. AWARE OF THEIR CONCERNS OF
ANY SPECIAL NEEDS THEY HAVE- WE
ALSO AT THE BEGINNING OF EACH
YEAR- GET FROM THEM AN ANNUAL
WORK PLAN WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY
A SPENDING BUDGET. SO THIS IS
HOW MUCH MONEY THEY'RE
ALLOCATING FOR REPAIRS THIS IS
HOW MUCH ALEX REID THEY'RE
ALLOCATING FOR DIFFERENT
SERVICES AND FOR DIFFERENT
CONTRACTS FOR- YOU KNOW
SPECIALIZED- SERVICES BECOME
AND LIKE FIRE ALARM FIRE
SUPPRESSION SERVICING THINGS
LIKE THAT. SO THOSE ARE A
COUPLE OF THE DIFFERENT WAYS IN
WHICH WERE MONITORING- AND
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
TO THE PRISONS OUT THERE- WE
ALSO DO- ASK FOR WHAT WE CALL A
CALL LETTER PROCESS WHERE- ONCE
A YEAR WOULD YOU ASK THEM TO-
UPDATE US ON ANY MAINTENANCE
NEEDS A LARGE SCALE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE MEANS THAT- WE DID
NOT PREVIOUSLY KNOW ABOUT. OR
THAT THE PERSON HAD NOT TOLD US
ABOUT SO THAT WE MAKE SURE
WE'RE PRIORITIZING THEM- WITH-
WITH THE- PROPER ASSISTANCE-
BUT ONE OTHER ASPECT ON STARTED
TO CONTINUE- WITH THE ANSWER
BUT I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
WE DO WORK. WITH THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR SO SUCH AS MR DAVIS-
WE WORK WITH THE HEADQUARTERS
MISSIONS AND WE SHARE
INFORMATION WITH THEM ABOUT HOW
THE MAINTENANCE FUNDING IS
BEING SPENT THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR. AND SO WE SEE THAT-
PRISON AS A HALFWAY THROUGH THE
YEAR EIGHT MONTHS OF THE YEAR
AND THE MAINTENANCE FUNDING
HASN'T BEEN SPENT WE'RE GOING
TO ALERT- THE- THE- DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS. MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR- AWARE OF THAT THAT
THEY'RE GONNA BE WORKING DOWN
THERE CHANGE TO OUR HELP THERE
ARE WARDENS AND THEIR- PLANT
OPERATIONS. STAFF- PERFORM
THEIR FUNCTIONS. THANK YOU FOR
THE- I'M MISTER B. AT YOU. WE
ALSO SPOKE- TODAY AND TALK
ABOUT- THE- HOMELESS PEOPLE ON
PAROLE AND I KNOW THAT- THE-
PROBOARDS HAS INDICATED THAT
WHILE HELPFUL HAVE A HOUSING
PLAN ISN'T NECESSARY- TO GRANT
A RELEASE DATE- BUT I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT- GRANTING FOLKS
RELEASE AND HAVING FOLKS ON
PAROLE WITHOUT HOUSING- IS A
FAST TRACK- BACK TO
INCARCERATION. OR RE
INCARCERATION- AND I JUST CAN'T
WRAP MY HEAD AROUND HOW WE'RE
LETTING FOLKS OUT ASKING THEM
TO RE ENTER SUCCESSFULLY INTO
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND WITHOUT
HAVING ANY HOUSING- AND SO I AM
SURE I KNOW YOU'RE NOT THE-
GRAND MASTER OF ALL THINGS
HOUSING FOR PAROLEES BUT- CAN
YOU JUST HELP ME RECONCILE.
WHAT DISCUSSIONS ARE WHAT PLANS
ARE IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS ARE BEING RELEASED WITH
AS MUCH SUPPORT AS POSSIBLE IT
IS INCOME CRITICAL THAT SOMEONE
HAS A PLACE TO LAY THEIR HEAD
JUST LIKE IT IS CRITICAL THAT
SOMEONE HAS OPTIONS FOR
EMPLOYMENT. JUST LIKE IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT SOMEBODY HAS-
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS TO HELP THEM ONCE
THEY'RE OUT. YOU CAN WITH
ASSESSMENT OF CENTCOM WATER IN
THAT- HAVING RESIDENTIAL
STABILITY IS CRITICAL AND TO
THAT END- THE STAFF FROM THE
DIVISION OF ADULT PAROLE
OPERATIONS- BE WITH OUR-
APPROACH BEFORE THEY'RE
RELEASED TO START. MAKING A
PLAN AND ESTABLISHING PLANS AS
TO WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
RESIGN. NOW MOST OF THOSE
RELEASED HAVING STABLE
RESIDENCE IS NOT A REQUIREMENT
TO BE RELEASED THAT IS TRUE
MINOR STATUTES BUT THAT IS OF
CONCERN TO EVERY AGENT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEIR
ABILITY TO BE SUCCESSFUL WITH
THE PRO LEVY AND LARGE PART
HANDS ON THE STABILIZING
FACTORS. AS IN SPAIN ONE. I
WILL SAY THAT THAT IS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR ME- THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS IN WHICH YOU
PARTICIPATE TRYING TO SEE
HOUSING- BUT AT THE SAME TIME
WE YOU KNOW WE WILL WE WILL
MEET ANYONE UNDER OUR
SUPERVISION WHEREVER THEY ARE
WHETHER THEY HAVE RESIDENTIAL
STABILITY OR NOT. THAT THAT
ISN'T. AFFECT WHAT ADDITIONAL
SERVICES WE OFFER THEM A STRONG
IT DOESN'T AFFECT THE
REPLICATION. WE ARE DEFINITELY
IN CONCURRENCE THAT THAT THAT
IS THAT IS A PILLAR FOR THEIR
THEIR ABILITY TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
RIGHT WELL WE HAVE OVER SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED OF OUR FOLKS ON
PAROLE WHO ARE UN HOUSED IN.
MEETING THEM WHERE THEY ARE IS
ONE THING MAKING SURE THEY
DON'T COME BACK INTO THE SYSTEM
IS THE THING THAT I'M MOST.
CONCERNED ABOUT SO MY HOPE IS
THAT THERE'S A MORE LASER FOCUS
ON MAKING SURE THAT FOLKS HAVE
THE SUPPORTS THAT THEY NEED. SO
THAT WE'RE NOT SEEING THEM BACK
BECAUSE AND THAT MEANS WE
FAILED. I'M MISTER DAVIS I HAVE
A QUESTION FOR YOU AND I'M- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE RIGHT AND TO
THE RIGHT OF ME ASK THE
QUESTION ABOUT- INTAKE BEING
CAUSED BECAUSE OF COVE IT- SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TWO THINGS
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FIRE CAMPS
AT C. I. W. BUT SINCE- WE'VE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT IT I JUST
WANT TO SHARE THAT I HAVE HEARD
IN. A NUMBER OF INSTANCES
WHERE- WOMEN AT C. I. W. ARM
AND THESE ARE COME THIS IS
COMING FROM FOLKS WHO ARE OUT-
SO NOT JUST FROM FOLKS WHO ARE
IN FACT. HAVE TALKED ABOUT-
INSTANCES WHERE- BEING ACCEPTED
OR RECOMMENDED INTO THE-
PROGRAM THE- THE FIRE CAN'T
PROGRAM WAS PREDICATED ON
SEXUAL FAVORS- AND SO I'M JUST
RAISING THAT BECAUSE I AM
ACUTELY CONCERNED ABOUT ARE
WOMEN WHO ARE INCARCERATED-
AND- YOU KNOW. THE THESE ARE IN.
CHOICE PROGRAMS I RECOGNIZE IN
THERE ONE THAT FOLKS REALLY
WANT TO BE PART OF- AND SO-
SEXUALIZING ARE ARE
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS- AND
BAITING THEM WITH THESE KINDS
OF PROGRAMS I'M IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
TOLERATE SO IT'S DID THAT HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH YOU BY FIRE
CAMPS WAS IN YOUR LITTLE PACKET
AND I FELT LIKE I HAD TO JUST
SAY TO PUT IT ON THE RECORD-
BUT- I DID ASK ABOUT. YOU KNOW
ARMED COMPASS- AND THAT- AND
HOW DURING THE RECEPTION CENTER
PROCESSING IT IS USED TO HELP
CREATE A REHABILITATION CASE
PLAN AND ALSO- STUDIES HAVE
COME OUT THAT HAVE SHOWN THAT-
IT IS IT IT USES AN ALGORITHM
THAT'S RACIALLY BIASED AND SO-
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO HEAR YOU-
TALK TO ME ABOUT COMPASS AND-
STEPS TO MOVE AWAY FROM THIS-
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS NOT
THE SOLE- DETERMINANT TOOL THAT
WERE USING WHEN WE'RE TRYING
TO- WHEN WE'RE HAVING FOLKS
COME AND THE RECEPTION CENTRES
IN WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH AND
TAKEN OVER TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER A REHABILITATION PLAN
FOR THEM. BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
HOW WE CAN PUT A PLAN OF
SUCCESS TOGETHER FOR SOMEONE
USING A TOOL- THAT- SET THEM
BACK. THANK YOU SENATOR- I HAVE
NOT HEARD THAT YEAH THAT.
COMPLAINT AGAINST CONGRESS-
UNTIL GOING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AND DO A LITTLE
RESEARCH MYSELF AND THEN READ
READ SOME SOME ARTICLES WERE
TALKED ABOUT CAMPUS- BEING USED
FOR SENTENCING- AND THE RACIAL
BIAS TOWARDS SENTENCING- I
COULDN'T FIND ANYTHING.
DIRECTLY RELATED TO OUR
PROCESS- I BELIEVE THE
SECRETARY MENTIONS THAT THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT- OTHER
ASSESSMENT TOOLS- I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THAT PROCESS IS RIGHT
NOW- BUT I BELIEVE THAT IS
SOMETHING THE DEPARTMENT IS
DOING RIGHT NOW IS LOOKING AT
OTHER THINGS- BUT I CAN ALSO
TELL YOU THAT THAT'S NOT THE
ONLY. THE ONLY A STEP IS TAKEN
TO TRY AND BUILD THAT PLAN FOR
SUBSTANCE USE- THAT'S HANDLED
THROUGH OUR HEALTH CARE
DEPARTMENT- AND BETWEEN A
COMBINATION OF NURSING AND
SOCIAL WORKERS THEIR INTERVIEWS
DONE TO ASSESS- TO. THEIR SENSE
USE NAY SO THAT'S PART OF THAT
PLAN- THERE ARE INTERVIEWS
DIRECTLY WITH THE CORRECTIONAL
COUNSELOR- TO DISCUSS- TO
DISCUSS THEIR PAST DISCUSS
THEIR HISTORY DISCUSS THEIR
INTERESTS. AND TO KIND OF
DETERMINE THEIR NEEDS WHETHER
BE EDUCATIONAL- CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION- YOU KNOW
THOSE TYPE THINGS- SO IT'S NOT
THE ONLY THING THAT SHOES BUT
LIKE I LIKE I SAID- AND LIKE
THE SECRETARY MENTIONED I
BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT IS
LOOKING AT OTHER. AND ANOTHER
TOOL FOR THAT I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THAT IS RIGHT
NOW BUT- WELL HOPEFULLY THAT'S
FAST TRACKED. I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT- I HAVEN'T LISTENED TO A
NUMBER OF FOLKS TELL ME THAT
SOMETIMES THEY TELL THE JUDGE
JUST SEND ME TO PRISON. BECAUSE
THE PROGRAMMING AND OUR STATE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES. IS
MUCH BETTER THAN WHAT WE GET-
AT OUR COUNTY JAIL FACILITIES.
AND SO- I KNOW A LOT OF THAT
HAPPENS- AT OUR RECEPTION
CENTERS. AND SO I HOPE THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT CAN
CONTINUE. AND I HOPE THAT AS
YOU ARE- WELL YOU KNOW ONCE YOU
ARE CONFIRMING YOUR CONTINUING
TO DO YOUR WORK THAT YOU ALSO
REMEMBER THE DISCUSSIONS WE HAD
ABOUT. DOING ASSESSMENTS AND
MAKING SURE THAT FOLKS ARE-
SAFE BECAUSE WE TALKED ABOUT
THE PRISON RAPE THAT HAPPENS
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THE
HONORABLE POPULATIONS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WHEN THEY
START- AT YOUR CENTER- THAT
THAT KIND OF CONSIDERATION- FOR
THEIR SAFETY. ARM FOR THEIR
SEXUAL SAFETY- IS REALLY TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU I
SENATOR COME WATER AND NOW LET
ME THANK ALL MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THE QUESTIONS- THIS IS BEEN A
AN ENLIGHTENING AFTERNOON WE
ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND- GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WANT TO TESTIFY AND- LET ME-
JUST. GO AHEAD AND MAKE SURE AS
A REMINDER FOR WITNESSES WAS
WISHING TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA
PHONE THAT OUR PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER WE'RE GOING TO PUT
ON THE SCREEN AGAIN AT THIS
POINT IT'S EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE
THE ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT ONE
SEVEN NINE FOUR FOUR FIVE. AND
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND START WITH
WITNESSES IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE LET ME SAY- TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHETHER
IN PUBLIC OR ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ON- IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING FOR AN INDIVIDUAL.
APPOINTEE TO BE CONFIRMED
PLEASE- IT KNOWLEDGE THEM BY
NAME- AND IF YOU'RE SPEAKING
FOR ALL THREE YOU CAN SAY THAT-
COLLECTIVELY JUST MAKE SURE WE
KNOW WHO YOU'RE TESTIFYING. IN
SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION OF
SO- AS WE START HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE- LET ME
SEE I SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
AND THIS IS FOR IN SUPPORT OF
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT. I'M LOOKING AT ROOM
ONE TWELVE I DON'T SEE ANYONE
HAS ENTERED ROOM ONE TWELVE. SO
MISTER MODERATOR I'M GOING TO
WELCOME YOU BACK. AND AGAIN
WITH THANKS FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND TO ASK IF YOU WILL T.
PEOPLE UP TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE WAITING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT I'M GONNA
ALSO AGAIN SAY- IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME YOUR NAME. YOUR
OPPOSITION OR WHO YOU REPRESENT
IF ANY- OTHER THAN YOURSELF AND
THEN YOUR- SUPPORT FOR WHICH
APPOINTEE BEFORE US- THIS
AFTERNOON DIRECTED DIRECTOR. OF
YOUR ROSA DIRECTOR BORG AND
DIRECTOR DAVIS SO WELCOME MR
MODERATOR BACK WE CAN BEGIN. IF
YOU LIKE TO COME IN SUPPORT
UNIT PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
OF COURSE WE GO TO LINE SIXTY
THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELCOME.
BY THREE LINES OPEN UP. NINETY
THREE MAY HAVE TO ON YOUR PHONE.
WE HAVE NO RESPONSE ONE SIXTY
THREE- THERE NO OTHERS IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OKAY.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND COME BACK
INTO THE ROOM- THERE IS THERE
ARE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE- THIS WOULD BE FOR
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. I STILL
SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SO- MISTER MODERATOR CANNOT
COME BACK TO YOU AND SEE IF YOU
HAVE PEOPLE WAITING. IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU LIKE TO COME
IN OPPOSITION IN A PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE'S NO
WINNING Q. MISTER MODERATOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
HELP TODAY WE DO APPRECIATE IT-
I'M GONNA COME BACK TO MY-
COLLEAGUES AND TAKE MOTIONS I'M
GOING TO DO SEPARATE MOTIONS
FOR EACH ONE GIVEN THAT THE
POSITIONS- ARE SEPARATE- AND SO
I SEE YOUR LIGHT- SENATOR
LAYERED SO LET ME ASK IF YOU
ARE MAKING A MOTION IN SUPPORT
OF. DIRECTOR OF VIA ROSA FIVE
AM ITEM B. ITEM B. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM ONE B. GROVE.
I GROVE I KAMLAGER HI MORE FIVE
LAYERED THERE HI EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT I ATKINS FIVE CONFIRMED
CONGRATULATIONS THAT WAS
UNANIMOUS YOUR- CONFIRMATION
WILL BE FORWARDED TO THE FULL
SENATE CONGRATULATIONS AND I
WILL MOVE ITEM C. DEAN L. PORK
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR-
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ROVE FIVE. I KAMLAGER
HI I'M LONGER AYE LAYERED AYE
AYE BATES VOTING BASE NOT
VOTING ATKINS AYE ATKINS R. N.
MADAM CHAIR I WOULD MOVE ITEM
D. RONALD C. DAVIS THANK YOU
SENATOR OF MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ROVE HI I
KAMLAGER HI LARBRE I LAYERED I.
AYE THEY PROMOTING IS NOT.
ATKINS HI INSIDE WAS THERE
CONGRADULATIONS- THESE
APPOINTMENTS OR CONFIRMATIONS
WILL BE FORWARDED TO THE- FULL
SENATE- I THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR SERVICE AND AGAIN FOR YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY- I WILL REMIND
STAFF THAT WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS THAT
WE'VE MADE REFERENCE TO. THE
SECRETARY AS WELL AS TO- THE
OTHER APPOINTEES TODAY AND WE
WILL EXPECT TO GET- THOSE-
COMMENTS IN WRITING BEFORE
THESE APPOINTMENTS MOVE TO THE
TO THE FLOOR. SO THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR- ATTENTION TODAY AND
CLEARLY FOR YOUR PATIENCE FOR A
LONGER THAN USUAL- SESSION. OUR
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU ON CALL
BILL- WE HAVE ONE ON CALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH MADAM SECRETARY.
YOU SEE WHY WE NEED YOU ARE
OBVIOUSLY FOR MANY REASONS BUT
OBVIOUSLY FOR THIS AS WELL WE
HAVE OUR ITEM ONE A. SECRETARY
ALISON ON CALL WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ROOF I. I THANK YOU SO
THAT WAS FOUR VOTES OUGHT TO
MOVE THE CONFIRMATION FORWARD-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASA.
SENATOR GROVE I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN GOING BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN- HEARINGS- THIS
CONCLUDES TODAY'S AGENDA I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY. THAT I'M I
PARTICULARLY WAS IMPRESSED WITH
THE NUMBER OF THE FORMER
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WHO TOOK THE TIME.
TO CALL AND WAY IN THE
ADVOCATES AS WELL AND THE
PEOPLE WITH PROFESSIONAL
RELATIONSHIPS BUT- I DO THINK.
WE HAD A LOT OF CONVERSATION
TODAY. ABOUT ISSUES THAT NEED
TO BE CORRECTED THINGS THAT
NEED TO. BE LOOKED AT AND
FOLLOW UP ON BUT- GOOD
TESTIMONY FROM INDIVIDUALS WHO
DIDN'T NEED TO PARTICIPATE
TODAY WHO CHOSE TO DO SO
BECAUSE- OF THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCED FIRST HAND OF BEING
INCARCERATED IN THE SYSTEM AND
TOOK THE TIME. TO WEIGH IN-
TODAY SO WE APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT I WANT TO THANK ALL
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFIED
TODAY. PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR TESTIMONY IS INCLUDED IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS.
SO WITH THAT LET ME AGAIN THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR COOPERATION
AND PATIENCE OF THE COMMITTEE
ON RULES WILL BE ADJOURNED.